[Music]
n
n nah
[Music]
n
nah
[Music]
n
yeah yeah yeah yeah my check my check
what is going on real how we doing out
here how the levels is going they my
murderer that my
[Music]
murderer we wet them up wet them up we
back him down back him down I'm on my
uncle Mur
today what's going on BR talk to me
what's what's the dealing out here
what's are we sounding good I appreciate
y I appreciate y'all no doubt no doubt
shout out to IM no doubt he in here with
the numbers early he letting us know
what
happened Jason M what's going on Salute
straight out straight up Bill I like
that just bill that's it he's here no
doubt he asking y'all funny with these
numbers now now now yall want to talk to
numbers
today Zach Ry what's going do doing Mr s
digit I see you a a fan salute piss
squeak or pie squeak I guess Gerald M OG
Bay Area okay we going to keep it
respectful no doubt let me get these
Super Chat y'all got super chats in
early oh man y making making me work
like first person damn I got to see I
got to see if I can catch that who that
was let's do fans for we got to get the
right shot out okay shout out to Jericho
you know what I'm saying that joined the
realm shout out to Lord Star Killer
congratulations St Starfield for being
the number one selling game in September
and the number seven selling game this
year welld deserved for this great game
yes indeed yes indeed we will talk about
it Gerald ma the OG $5 Super Chat at
this point the bugs are so egregious and
some of the reviewers are forced to tell
the truth in order to save what's less
of their integrity # xwo
okay you going in you bust you g early
okay I see what's going on out here
remember none of that I know y'all on
that for the north joint I know know I
know it's revenge for some people out
here but it's all good let's see what we
got up in here um lanc oh I like that
Lancelot see what going on he he that's
not what he held the line for okay no
doubt theado salute D Omar my the god
the homie salute a fan you know what I'm
saying lady and master I see you salute
salute salute popn what's going on lyd
Metro what's going on he said sorry for
Sonic
but one do arriv you listen man as far
as I'm concerned no games released this
weekend nothing came out this week
except the Tekken eight closed Network
Tex B that's the only game that dropped
this week as far as I'm concerned cuz
that's all I've been really playing I
was forced to get off I was forced to
stop when the servers went down Zach
Riley what's going on F we got up in
here Danny passion official I see you
peeve what's going on Tim perv 21 Dion
78 Mr glass ninja squirrel year I like
that name e ranks salute xzone xdj no
doubt young Dre The Young artist I see
you you know what I'm saying Antman
what's going on we going to have a fun
show we got have a fun show dude's
running late all right I got to see if
adct is uh oh it's funny adct adct is
not late King is here first but I got to
go because he got music and we not
trying to get the B times catch y'all
later here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
was random but I am addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arsing up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I got now
let's switch that
what did you do Don't Stop N that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you can say that I'm very spoil feel to
be your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making vultron with a
gang of cougar and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sson up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest of start
regardless back we was messaging people
on a check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still I
[Music]
got keep that going go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoal
feel them to be your dog they very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't
heard the boy you ain't got to say it
I'm embarrass for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am U
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on
check myter but I'm anal love my city
but I'm Co I
got don't stop that was dope keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead look I guess you can say that I'm
very spoil feeling to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't going to hold you
I ain't heard the boy you you ain't got
to say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that again
here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head is be swearing they real
but to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they they can sarson up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the RS you just a Target when
I'm in the r I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on a check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still byal I got's Swit what did you do
don't stop that was dope keep that keep
that keep that going keep that going n
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoal feel them to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertain until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y got to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
lame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got let's Swit
that you stop that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going no go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoil to be your dog
they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault Tron with a gang of cougars
and I'm going play better tell a uber
cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on Fry
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I
got what did you doing don't stop that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
to be your dog they very loyal but I
ain't going
to oh yeah
[Music]
calloud and clear a proclamation of
invitation turn not on
me I cry the prises of
the
matal near the river St lawence with the
St
[Music]
through I'mma just chill and watch them
next in the attic I wanted to chill with
the pack and be like a young Whooper
then they would mistake me for atct if I
can imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give her that
option you going to be single player
like sere you going to get tossed in the
bushes by King David royalty and not a
pretender detrimental to an elemental
what a avatar to a knee Bender I got to
be NE I know it's my destiny work too
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be steo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that King still
be the king of the statue since a
juvenile I've been cursed with a curse
to be Musical and if you hate it we'll
meet an able other than that it's cool
and it's beautiful we let you know that
your dreams are pursuable whatever you
want to do then it's doable if you got
work on a Sunday it's suitable cuz you
can listen to this in your cubicle on
the Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a Lord's
day oh yeah yeah oh yeah
I want see I want to see what he had to
say too Mike sah what's going on Mike
check real what's going on start with
the young wolf right quick let me hit
the young wolf where he at myo hello
crispy crispy I see that 10K I like that
no doubt no doubt we should have had a
20K shirt I a about that yeah you like
yeah we act like people do that all the
time so like felt like we hit 10K then
we turn around and hit 20K yeah yeah for
sure for sure we got to we got to think
about what we're going to do for the
next Mone solve we got to give away
their console we need to give away the C
St playing that's what we do behind
behind behind aall on
that back says we're behind don't don't
worry but we we're not Shing y we're not
Shing y d k by check the tax man came
tax the the large what would they call
the golden
company they came through they came
through the iron bank always pays his
debts yeah we got to pay our debts man
with the golden company
come always pay their debts that's right
they don't play around K what's good
Mike checks and all out how y'all doing
today even though I can't hear myself
this is garbage oh my God here we go I
know he won't be DJ premere over here D
manash that's right take it for us you
sound fine you sound you sound fantastic
that's that's kind of crazy like when
when we talk we hear ourselves right
when you talk when you talk no I'm
talking about in general like when we
talk so right now this don't feel
good but you can literally hear yourself
in the present F you don't you don't
need a Reverb of you hearing yourself
and you're in the same room
right stop stop playing
semantics what's up
K King King have to hear that inner ego
come out on the mic that's what he got
to hear I got to know if I'm coming
across
good here you hear ye and we are live
welcome to the io's podcast LLC and also
live on Lords of gaming.net episode
number
327 it's another glorious Sunday and
we're back at the round table on the
Lord's day and today we've got
Spider-Man 2
Impressions Starfield wins
NPD say Ain't So Phil Spencer on abk's
future Mario Brothers wonder and D
Bowser's latest interview to discuss so
we going to get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original gaming nights here at the
realm at the round table my co-host the
Coos my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord at it back to back how we doing
what's going on guys yeah it's a it's a
long week man you people sitting there
they're like addict how how did you beat
Spider-Man so fast well it it helped it
was it was relatively on the short end
and uh it's nice when you don't sleep
you know shout out to that sleeping
living up to your name sake yeah I
stayed up for like almost 30 hours
straight I knew was on cuz me and you
usually speak at least once a day for an
extended period of time and I was like I
a get my addict call I was like you know
what I'm saying I was like what's going
on I think think we messaged each other
so D like yo I saw it in our chat you
like beat him I was like yo he's a
Savage I think he called me like I think
it was Friday I was still at work he's
like I've been going for a lot of
hours I was like oh you haven't even
touch Mario yet right but now I got the
guy I got I got to the first boss of
Mario I'm like what yo he's a Savage bro
he's absolute Savage he out does Kai
Basu like yeah Kai Kai in his prime I'm
sorry I got a I'll let you forget I did
I did three worlds on Mario over Jesus
this I've always been relatively decent
at Platformers so those always come
natural to me yeah and what's funny is
like you know we'll get to the
Spider-Man thing but I got some stuff to
say about that too yeah we got things to
talk about seems like all of us have
things to talk
about so besides
blazing uh Spider-Man 2 and and looks
like you stuck in some uh Mario wonder
and and that's been it right yeah um you
know I have been still playing from time
to time Persona because I look I I get
it I don't have to go back but there's
this there's this like boss in in the
momentums called The Reaper and he's
like there to make sure you don't stay
in the momentums too long because people
would grind like they would just they
would Farm the momentums if you could
just sit there forever so he shows up
and he's like uber powerful he's like
strong he's like justice he's either
stronger or just as strong as the last
boss so I was like I know I don't have
to kill him every every time I sit down
and I think about game the back of my
head it's like that dude still he
running
around I didn't like that I'm the same
way that so it's like but in order to
get like the strongest owners of the
game you need a certain confid on to a
certain level and I'm leveling that up
as right now but the problem is I had to
I had to start the game over a new game
plus oh no I give so I I went from level
96 to
two so I'm leveling that but the good
thing now is that I don't I don't listen
to any of the dialogue I skip everything
yeah because you kind of yeah I makes s
now shout out to you all that there was
a um boss in Final Fantasy 7 crisis card
remake recently I had the same situation
and they like oh he optional and I'm
like nah he out here destroying yeah he
been bullying me and I didn't know what
to do to beat him and I was like all
right I had to change my material up and
then I got him but yeah I know exactly
what you be with that but yeah you doing
your thing you're doing your thing I I
plan on killing that dude so that sound
too sadistic well in Persona 5 like you
at the very end you uh the main
character like unlocks this Uber
powerful Persona yeah but you never get
to use it but I I I saw in in um in the
new game plus you can unlock him now oh
so I'm like oh yeah I'm getting it no
doubt and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gam list
for the single player selfish experience
and also the sadis the Lord of clarity
and Lord Patriot of the iron bank PC
Master races own show us your build
Lord show us your build show us your
build show us that there was no build
going on last night cuz I went in I had
to do a restart on the my my beautiful
AMD Edition you know made that NXT
Edition that buts um and I went in and
it I said oh it needs to restart
whatever hit the restart and it froze I
like damn it damn so no no but I you
know I turned it all came back on
everything's beautiful now so that
that's nothing
I I couldn't do a reaction with King cuz
my my uh my mic wasn't working for some
reason so I'm sitting here like I
troubleshoot probably two hours I'm like
I ain't doing this reset
computer clearly because what happened
is when I was trying to download zoom
and I uninstalled zoom and then I was
thinking I uninstalled the software for
this no this is a sure Mich yeah we're
on Zoom this is a pod track 4
Zoom no sense so I'm just I'm just
resetting to a prior date reset to a
prior date still wasn't working so I'm
say you're going like 10 15 minutes like
what is going on find out that someone
turned it all the way down someone oh
wow that's a violation that's a
violation that's a
violation obviously I'm not going to I'm
not going to to register voice yeah but
I was so upset I was like I got to
redownload everything oh that sucks you
thought it was some complic that
happened to me yeah the volume that
happened to me too what time I remember
the volume was a joint anyway so so once
I did that I was able to install the
tecken 8 beta but that's all that the
the the launch screen looks beautiful
it's very nice oh wow you saw y kazuya's
faces look crazy I to see I got to see
that that video that they showed a long
time ago high res that real nice the
better question so can you tell me the
quality of the game off the start menu
it's it's a it's a nine it's a nine
anything less than a nine ad be messy I
know what he doing I know what he doing
anything else of course so uh I actually
I I played a little Spider-Man so we'll
be talking about that I got to play a
little bit um but you know as you guys
know my life despises me so I wasn't
able to play too much of Mario wonder
which is actually my topic which is
funny but um yeah what I played of Mario
wonder I got I got thoughts man I
got
there wasn't a lot that you could have
done for that situation you know two two
high prominent Games come out the same
day on the same weekend and we had two
days to play them like yeah it was a
crazy week cuz it fall n and somebody
put their meat on the table and said I
don't care it's your birthday he said
I'm not moving I'm not moving it's our
birthday yeah that was that was a
gangsta move though I really was like
you know what
and not the end not the end and one dude
knew you know I could beat you right I
want to say uh you what you call it's
going to be interested next month to see
how s all that I already know how I
already know how it was shaked out you
know we G to see Sony dudes do not buy
games so we know them Nintendo dudes
them Nintendo them them them them switch
guys they purchase I I we got to keep in
mind that this first off the uh you know
Nintendo games normally outsell
PlayStation games that's right
Spider-Man's different but at the same
time it ain't nothing different about it
Spider-Man Spider-Man is selling to like
50 million and switch is selling to like
150 so it's like there's more and it's
like I said you know with with it I
personally feel like there's not a whole
whole lot to play on
the you know those numbers are not
something to King said say Sony selling
a 50
million to
whom how many of those are in the
warehouse King exactly remind us I say I
say 35 million of them is some Warehouse
someplace that never been turned
on I know I know Nintendo dudes day
purchase they knowas add up yo made up
they make sense but but it made because
it adds up S they be like yo yeah we
sold 20 million of Pokemon H about that
I'll sayead
I'll say Spider-Man will sell five
million the first month and nintend uh
Mario sld 10 million the first one oh
okay hey no Mario sold 10 million that
same week now
Spiderman yeah we can go with see let's
let's see what happens anyway s that's
been it sir yeah that has been it I
think oh ex and Shout Shout out to Sam
Lake and and Allan Wake doing the smart
thing and going the next week I love you
appreciate apprciate y sometimes
sometimes there's no and and what know
what sometimes you know what listen man
sometimes you got to move your product
off the block there other dudes here and
you got to you got to go sell down the
way you got to exactly exactly you got
to go sell down the way you know and and
have a clear Lane for yourself yeah for
yourself exactly no doubt mess with
those dudes little and of course we have
the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
excess gamer ooh the prophet of Xbox
swamy King of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
advanced Aline
movement beloved Lord King how we
doing I'm doing fantastic yo so I'm G
get into what I was playing all right to
to hell with uh it was the whatever's
fights and stuff last night okay my
PlayStation VR2 oh okay all right all
right right so um I get this thing and
I'm that's like all right um wifey never
been in VR so I said this is VR
Saturday I gotta say PlayStation
VR1 had a better demo presentation to
show
people right like this and I wanted to
show off like the best and brightest
right they forc you to go buy
something well you know what it is you
they're deos you just got to go and look
for them in the in the store it's not
like oh here is here is the demos for
the you know whatever 10 launch games or
whatever here they are no you got to go
search for them in the store so it is
one of those things that if you look at
it you just think it oh it's Horizon and
that's it and like the problem is they
should have a VR section yes it's there
but not it's not
really not Cur not well curated because
I think VR was a passion project and was
afterthought because like when I even go
in there I can download a game for uh
Playstation VR but I downloaded as
PlayStation VR 4 I mean for PlayStation
4 VR1 and it is not compatible we
already know it's not comp why is it not
compatible guys right um so I was very
limited in what I was able to show her
so I was able to show her Call of the
Wild or Call of the mountain whatever
that is um and she was thoroughly
impressed by it okay yeah when get it
start on the B
she was like oh I'm in a
kayak I was like I said you can look all
the way around so she did the whole look
around thing the W had to tell her watch
out for the wire shot the little arrows
at the top of the stuff no no when when
everything started going haywi and she
had to run across the help help me help
they coming after me and she had to
climb up the mountain but yeah she had a
good time with it but she wanted to see
some stuff that I could play with it so
I played the NFL demo uh I I did a
little bit more of the call of the
mountain thing um so she could see more
stuff of it uh she was impressed by it
but I wanted her to be blown away got
like cuz when my sister came over to
play the PlayStation VR1 that shark
joint when you remember when you go down
and you go you oh my God that is like
one of the best demos and then the
getaway demo and all that other stuff
that get demo did you ever do the the
demo um the walk the one with the dude
walking across the the Twin Towers back
you have to look down you looking down
czy my God crazy yo it's horrifying all
right so played that played Spider-Man
got thoughts for that um played
Starfield I played uh oh uh uh what was
it um the Knights game uh the knights
the knights the uh uh the Batman game um
oh Gotham Knights Gotham Knights oh I
it's a gay pass right I want I got you
know I you know I was going to touch I'm
so glad that it I'm glad I I'm glad I
held Advanced the line held the line
with with that cuz I knew I was like
that feel like it's going to come and
I'm going to
wait I heard like really good that and a
certain other remake that I that is also
out very soon I think out already if I'm
not mistaken uh Dead Space oh yeah
that's out I think that's out no you may
be right no it's coming out week yeah
yeah um and I'm played Mario Wonder so I
had and Forza but it was a lot of stuff
and you know fortnite of course but
this weekend this is the first time I
saw two triaa titles come out on the
same day and said pick yeah straight up
and it was it was the hardest thing to
do but I'mma give y'all my pick you know
when you know no doubt and of course we
have the gaming ninja
himself the beefy [__]
over L Cognito SP that realness in the r
with the IOP not telling you what you
want to here but what you need need to
hear shout out to graphic guard shout
out to the to the young artist yeah yeah
beefy is in stores now I know K I know
King has been waiting for this moment
you know what I'm saying but if y'all
want to get that that Lord beefy you
know what I'm saying you want to get
tank
top yo so somebody was asking me to get
tank tops up and all the items that are
in our Teespring store are available in
tank top yeah yeah you got got the tank
tops in there we got the beefy we got
the corporate Cog is also up there you
know what I'm saying so we want to shout
that out so go get that y'all been
waiting a long time see I see the meat I
see the meat in the
CH pause
pause a super pause super pause on that
but this is what y'all been waiting for
so thanks to King and being
expeditiously with our marketing person
as well as our uh
storefront this is an Express order this
is for those who suffered long enough it
is now
available for y'all Corp is in there as
well y Corp C is in there go check him
out he out there he chilling you know
what I'm saying so yeah if you yo father
Gucci said hey yo C want more me yo I'm
done I'm done with I'm done with Y y'
Messi y out of here shout out to um Mr
mdy play Shout out to Def fining Duke
talking about that Starfield which we
talk about as well and what was going on
there shout out to the last word b just
T got Travis holding me down fun episode
talking about what's going on with
Bungie as well as Game of the Year
choices as far as me no other games came
out no other games came out the Tekken a
closes Network test was here it's back
with new characters they got Raven they
got oh oh they got that coffee chick yo
that Co you going like her bounce K like
she her bounce is cuz like she get
coffee she get nice it's like said
somebody get drunk she get coffee I
think she's Peruan she's from from
yeah I don't
know wait hold we got to get Lord Lord
spanish's authenticity here no it's fine
it's just like it's like why is your
superpow caffine like what is going on Y
what what is it is she gets uh like
hyper yeah she's like well she doesn't
drink it in the match but you could tell
like that's her whole backstory whatever
but her bounce is like a quick agile
boxer and then her her weave her we she
be like she's L I ain't going for this
of the best new characters that Namco
has introduced cuz at first I saw I was
like this some joke character like what
they doing her rain zero weave is crazy
she's a problem Peruvian yeah yeah yeah
shout out to Brian e yeah yeah she she
doing her thing um I was out there yo
shout out to Kai box use a Savage sir
use a s use a Pure Savage because um
first of all we got the homies we all
playing so you know Tekken rules Tekken
rules Kings if you don't know the rules
is cuz we IP and Chan Al was buil off
Chanel 5 Chanel 5 is built off Tekken
initially Tekken is what our foundation
is Halo and then Halo came out then Halo
came up exactly so teken was that so
what happens is you know the day one
rule when it come out I see you later
cuz I'm GNA go don't bother me I'm g go
to the dojo I'mma go practice or I'mma
do the single player obviously we can't
do that so I'm messing around they got a
new feature they got it's like a
PlayStation home/ what's that Street
Fighter thing when you run around you an
avatar of yourself run around in in the
world and yo King you going to love it
it's like they got like the Japanese
arcade where they got the little unit so
you can see who playing and there'll be
a four-seater there's a eight- seater
with the rotation like Namco is really
going out with the online portion of it
so I'm messing around so then willhelm
scream in the chat so he's like why
y'all all in the chat and nobody
fighting so I was like nah that's the
rule we supposed to we all try to get
our touch on so he's like yeah but I
just want to see it so I'm like all
right that's the homie like can somebody
stream it can somebody so we all right
so shout out to demon shout out to
everybody so we we rocking so we like
all right we all day one Roy nobody
ain't play so we just like whatever we
just going to go in and mix why your
your brother cof going go off to the
side so we like yo it's been like an
hour we like KY are you getting in the
rotation everybody just free you see him
there you see there and he he clearly
doo in I'mma call you out cuz yo he he
Terrior ized us he brought he came out
all right guys I'm ready and then hour
later brought in Nina after the strong
Doge he
terrorized I was like I hate
him you know that feeling he used to
give you when he was he on top of his
game he in tournament mode yeah also
also when did it start when he he I
think he hit me up did he hit me up
Friday night with it I think it was so
he's been rocking he's been rocking
since Friday I know he been listen he I
knew something was up when he text me in
the DM and said and send me the Cod he
was like yeah the ba is
out yeah yeah he cuz I knew he was
confident I said yo he man he terrorized
I just want to shout out One Last Thing
Before don't go along um yo martial l
king they they they we always say Bruce
Lee closest representation you know what
I'm saying we give it to law a lot right
we I would say Your Man from um Dead
Alive was close one year um oh a drunk
dude JZ Lee he was close sh and then
this guy from Street Fighter Street
Fighter was
close K they got the suit 70s with the
old school 70 shade with the hair like
he fresh off the set of Enter the Dragon
wow his flows bro I don't know nothing I
didn't take no do I was in the mix with
every match L is back y'all I I I was
sleeping but anyway Tekken oh my God me
me me and Sovereign play oh my God it's
it's absolutely stunning and then some
other game called Spider-Man came out
the only reason why I played it is cuz
they the maintenance on Tekken 8 cuz the
only thing came out really was Tekken
eight8 and the big this forced me to
play so I'm like all right Spider-Man 2
I guess I could play you you hot you
know what I'm saying so I did that what
about what about your exploit to Mario
wonder what's going on I'm going to lean
on the Lords
I'm going to lean on the Lord to tell me
I'm not feeling this I'm too old for
Mario thing for you I'm not feeling adct
had to talk with me he was just like
he's like I get it bro I said you know
what it is I connect with Zelda I
connect with Metro I'm just with him I
know just he said nah he's not down with
you're not about platforming Excellence
the P of platforming Excellence just I'm
too old to be in in the playground
Indian style we need you know what we
need we need see C needs kids around him
to to to
make he needs he needs children I need
children you know to kind of keep that
young keep the young Spirit ma mail mail
your children to
car so that's been pretty
much no he said no no
no the younger the better whoa whoo whoo
whoa whoa whoa whoo sir sir pause pause
anyway let's get let's get out of this
Lane let's time on this
Lane you need n and nephews around you
young energy yeah yeah yeah so we did
that I just want to shout out again the
Tekken um played on all almost all
platforms PS5 um that's why my inial
network C I got the Xbox one they look
absolutely stunning the light sauce this
game is absolutely beautiful C on the
Rock Ally 10860 on the
Ally it is outstanding it is a well
optimized so far game so we got that and
then shout out to the trecy brothers I
played um what it cyber Knights flasho
got a chance to play that on Steam they
my turn bra Brothers out there if y'all
like a little Espionage a little spy a
little cyberpunk Vibe anticipation
mechanics stories a little E I wish
there was voice I just wish there was
voice you know what I'm saying but other
than that if you like the pure gameplay
of turn Blaze check that out and I've
been doing Starfield but that's been
pretty much it for me because I'm trying
to finish up I saved the last quest
which is the Crimson Fleet um Attic So I
save that last cuz that's the last
faction I want to finish up and that's
and I played wizard with a gun from deol
devolver that's right we didn't get a
chance to play that at pack oh let's
let's tell them
why yeah you was feeling yourself wasn't
you homey once again once again no Dev
was available shout out to the other
what was the other game that we did play
we talked to the devs and umbrella the
umbrella oh yeah umbrella gella umbrella
yeah so where with a gun did not have
anybody Avail no doubt but come on now
so s we got do super chats we pay the
bills what we GNA do let let's do the
super chats first it's only a couple and
then we'll go into paying the other
bills um we got Lord Star Killer $5
Super Chat congratulations to Starfield
for being the number one selling game in
September and the number seven SE number
seven selling game this year we deserved
this great game yes very impressive very
very impressive Gerald Mack $5 Super
Chat at this point the bugs are so
aggreg just that some of the reviewers
are forced to tell the truth in order to
save what's left of their integrity # x
w is that really happening yeah well
some stuff came out today um that I
believe ACG pointed out and then I
believe Char linman pointed out in
reference to after launch and what
performances I don't I don't no once
once ACG put it out everybody yeah yeah
I you can't thr ACG yeah yeah no ACG
stepped out was like yo um this usually
happens whatever XYZ everybody else yo
yeah yo yeah nah you ain't getting way
like that buddy we will discuss we will
discuss let's put the crest in the chat
for Lord gold uh oh Jer I just want to
know how a day one patch makes stuff
worse like what what PlayStation do like
it happens it happens Accord NCG addict
he was like oh they put the credit card
scamming uh
thing so so so when you walk past the
nft joint would definitely scan see cuz
your your controller is a snip you are
ridiculous yeah add go to ACG toine cuz
he said he seen it before with that
Elder ring and I believe it was another
game where he said the day zero patch
made it worse or something I don't know
but yeah we'll talk then we got Stitch
with the $5 Super Chat good day Lords it
is crazy to say you can play every first
every PlayStation first party game in a
single weekend what happened over there
stop being
messy messy messy messy messy then we
got we got drawn TJ $2 Super Chat
Spider-Man 2 is a broken mess quality
right right y going in already stand on
it you're going to stand on it hey then
we have hush Al gou Super
Chat D with baning them yeah shout out
to Batman bman Sony should bundle a can
of raid with Spider-Man wow doing the
most doing the most much Lord Metroid $2
chat oh a Nintendo topic you dudes
feeling all right
right you can thanks sa for that I was
trying to see if we can move that
[Laughter]
along there we have face 23 bky $20
Super Chat thank you brother uh King
congrats congrats on Starfield being
number one like King is Todd Howard
congrats thank you I appreciate that
thank you I'm being number one on PC and
its only competition was MK1 wonder if
you're going to talk about MPD for
October who do you think will be number
one
stario Mario
Mario
Mario I think Mario's a complete
Juggernaut yeah we G to see we'll see
what happens continue continue and we
have face uh face once again $20 Super
Chat I see XBox guys in their fields
with Spider-Man 2 posting picks of
Spider-Man clipping with NPCs created
with photo mode chill see people they're
not doing this this is what we talk
about about having too much time in your
I told you you I thought it's going to
be dudes that's going to do that for the
north the north remembers I told you
it's going to be that remember the
remember the yeah like we not going to
review bomb you we just going to do do
your dirty in the streets Do Your Dirty
ridiculous we got the time to go review
bomb he's like we're not going to review
bomb you but you know if we see you
walking on the side of the streets and
we see that big water pudle what do they
call it what do they call it when they
put the celebrities faces on porn movies
oh my God deep fate
shout to Lord jez in the building I see
him pull up how we doing
sir I I'm not used to have zoom work so
I was kind of like am I actually here or
not yeah yeah I'm like you early he's
out here working I I was worried man no
you good brother I I was looking on the
the the meeting invite and it was like
7:45 and I was like oh [__] they've
already
started go pay a little bills that's all
you good
do doing good brother doing good just
paying some bills doing some super chats
what's going what else what else we off
then we got zip Davis $5 Super Chat
thank you big link who Oh you mean that
chump who got slumped by Spider-Man and
to back o we wait somebody talking [__]
strong about about somebody talking
strong about Lake wow that's crazy
that's crazy okay things happens out
here that's crazy then uh let's Lord
Johnny uh one pint
Johnny remember for one month FL bronze
a lot of meat on the table just just a
lot of meat a lot of meat a lot of meat
on the table for sure then we got uh
King is overrated
$10 got a question for all of you but
mostly sa I'm curious on how you guys
balance the work life gaming hobby time
and family time I'm currently trying to
find a good balance between them any
advice uh I don't have balance between
them that is how I balance it uh my work
life is Bonkers and then I have to try
to figure out gaming life in between
that and and not taking away from family
time so that's just where where it's at
um but the responsibilities dayto day
just kind of take over and so that's
that so that's why I kind of grav
started gravitating to the rag and you
know the switch and being able to like
take my you know have my my library
across multiple sort of uh things so
that I could just continue my games and
not constantly be restarted in that's
why I kind of gravitated away from the
consoles mostly and now I do mostly PC
no doubt no doubt and what else we got
let me see we got sin Vendetta $20 Super
chatom uh do you guys ever keep track of
your time you've played in a game that
you've you enjoying and see where you
are compared to your friends it's kind
of fun uh it's kind of a fun thing to do
like I just passed addict in Starfield
but I'm still behind Cog oh W that's
what's up yeah yeah I only like what I
consider the ritual games for me when
likey stuff that I live in like Destiny
Tech XCOM what would Beau Halo like C
those are the ones on my ritual games
those are the only time I checked that
but it's a cool stat because you can see
you know what I'm saying who who's in
the mix with you and stuff shout out to
Setta salute I'm not putting no undue
expectations upon my I'm in some weird
competition with [__] no I'm not like no
I'm not going to do that no not
competitively why I I just like when
it's a game that you love and you know
you've been blazing I'm just curious to
see like like how many hours I have it
and then when you with Xbox you could it
just automatically shows you who the
other dudes is you know why I walk away
from that thought of that me and Mr H
yeah I know you remember that a lot of
money a lot of money when you get into
it it could get into a very scary
competitive yeah then you see me have My
Little Pony and you like playing my My
Little Pony just to get the achievements
to My Little Pony bad shout out shout
out to J shout out to I remember one
month cuz Rand is a beast shout out to
my R like every game man was a beast and
I remember R I said to myself I'm going
to beat him one month I don't care cuz
every month it be like dudes will post
up on Twitter yep I'm the number one I
had the most achievements that month man
I went so hard I was buying all type of
Little Indie Games on the side I was
doing all the Telltale Games I made sure
I beat red
out better games to get a thousand gamer
score smooth yes what's up smooth knows
the whole publisher like a whole
publisher releasing games every week
almost like you get a th Gamers score in
like 30 minutes what's up J what you
guys to say you're not going to beat
Rand at get achievement stuff because
the rest of us have to work for a
little I knew he was I knew the SL
chilling all day playing games eating
Doritos and drinking
Mountain how rest of us expect to be
with this I feel he he's very slanderous
when I listen to Xbox to he's always
slander against when are you going to be
you know what I'm saying but now shout
out to my brother he's such a beast I
was just happy I I I tweeted it I
screenshotted I was like I could I could
I could die that I beat him one month in
life I had to dedicate everything but
continue so what know what you got then
we have the professor $5 Super Chat
Spider-Man 2 like God of War Ragnarok
seems to have more cinematics in
gameplay I hope Spider-Man 2 gets better
okay we'll discuss we'll discuss then we
have Danny passion official official one
not the fake one official not the fake
one2 Super Chat Spider-Man 2 is
officially full of bugs he's a
bug wow well all righty and we are
caught up no doubt and anything else we
need to do uh we need to pay any other
little bills we we're going to pay the
bills I'm going to tell I'm going to
tell my uh my co- not to mute their
mics don't mute your mics you can mute
it after not not immediately all right
so let's get let's get into these bills
for a moment
so gentlemen Across the Nation I have an
urgent message for you this episode of
The Iron Lords podcast is brought to you
by manscaped the brand that took your
balls to space is now launching them
into the
ultrasphere introducing the lawnmower
5.0 Ultra featuring a new Cutting Edge
design and Next Generation dual skin
safe blade heads for nine different for
different shaves it's pretty much a
spaceship to take your boys downstairs
to the next level join the 9 million men
worldwide who must trust manscape with
the brand new lawnmower 5.0 Ultra by
going to manscape.com for 20% off plus
free shipping with the code iron Lords
high- tech for Low Places that's
manscaped so you guys are usually used
to me now going into some rant about you
know the the area downstairs you know
different colloquialisms that we use for
testicles and stuff like that I'm not
going to do that today oh okay okay
today I'm going to turn to the realm my
cohorts to talk to you about why
manscapes 5.0 Ultra package is the next
level so I'm G to start out with our
host our Cognito the man with the with
the most unruly beard in in all the
realm out of control out so let's let's
talk about your quickly your experience
with the lawn mower 5.0 package Lords
out here with these Dusty Master swords
I know I know I know you're not handling
your business you know what I'm saying
but look L this the lawn mow joint yo
let me tell you first of look at the
packaging premium very iron Lord see
that gold on the side shout out to
manscape killing in the game but now
this is official this is official
product when you want to handle your
nether regions you know what I'm saying
you got to get it there you got to get
between the crevices because you got to
make sure fre part that everything is
all right you don't want to come in
there and and see a situation that's not
a good situation for you need that
cleaned up trimmed up it's a excellent
excellent utensil so I would highly
recommend the laal and I want to give a
quick shout out though s this even
though it's not his day today I want to
give a shout out to my this this is my
little man little man for real this is
um the weed whacker oh yeah the weed
whacker cuz let me tell you co sometimes
it be a little unsightly you know what
I'm saying with the nose head you get up
in there you throw that bad you hear
that bad boy he's a fish you get up in
there handle your business you know what
I'm saying and you know make sure you
know it's it sometimes it be a beefy
situation you know what I'm saying but
downstairs but you got your upstairs
handle your downstairs handle Lord beefy
approves manscape go get that absolutely
now the man with the actual most
unwieldy beard in all the real lord
King well
um yes I use it okay um I think the the
the bed hedger is uh definitely
something that uh I would tell everybody
to use right so it comes in this case
and it's a beautiful
case zip it open yeah have your hedger
has everything in here Fold It Up nice
and
good it's fantastic so after the show
today I'm definitely going to do my
thing right so when I got it I used the
other one I was down below so I'm
talking about yeah yall talking about uh
unight situation 5.0 yes the the
lawnmower 5.0 I'm going tell you right
now it's better than the
4.0 that we had because it has so many
different heads that you could put on it
so I put the the I think it was the
second head pause I put that on it cuz
two heads are better than
one always always and and they come with
threee heads
hello so um I use that one you can get
real close to the surface without going
you know full you know skin to skin you
know you you can have like a little Buzz
a little peach fuzz down there something
nice you know something clean you know
and um it's just you can do it safely
too CU it has that light the light is so
accurate like you trust me guys you
could do this in the dark because it has
a light and you can don't worry about
nicking and scratching yourself that was
my biggest feir with with raises and
stuff you always Nick and scratch
something and then you sometimes walk
away from handling the little guys down
there so you don't have to worry about
it there this is designed to take care
of the little guys with no fear so check
this out use it and um I want to hear
what adct got I swear I want to hear
what adct got yeah what's going on over
there I mean you know it's you got
sometimes you got to do stuff man
sometimes you got to do stuff you know
if I never get to the point where my
girls ask me can't ever get to that
point so you know got s girls plural
going on here did he did he see s like
it a stable for the bcap you got to you
got to make sure that you know you
handle your another reasion that's why
that's why you know obviously you know
Ju Just to clarification there's only
one
girl I I put you my bad situation where
like what are you not telling me no
there's only one but you know you I will
say this you can never have multiple
ones if you if you if you stuff ain't
straightened out all right how you
expect more than one chick to deal with
that one [__] even have to deal with
that I'm I'm I'm feeling you because you
know what I'm saying we we all we all
have one another realm Studio that we
have to take
care so as for me as for as you can tell
I have not yet the had the opportunity
look at my face to use my my handyman
and to use my uh beard headed I've not
had the opportunity yet a little bit
higher over the so they can see yeah yes
and and I'm sure I'm going to disappear
into the iron Lord's logo in a moment
but here we go um so I haven't had the
opportunity to use these yet but
uh the cigra the closer oh so to speak
this man has has done his work it's done
his work so actually let me show youall
what I I did wait you giving us a live
demonstration
who we are not doing live demonstrations
your NE you put you're putting it on the
wrong the wrong the wrong don't worry we
we'll put this on the exive on patri
that's a different patreon tier that's
that's the joystick tier but thank you
to my cohorts for all of for all of
their uh insights on using the lawm 5.0
so let's get on with the with the rest
of the read so yes as you all know every
man knows how scary it can get when
going for a close shave below the waist
that's why I trust manscape for all my
sensitive areas I'm lucky to be one of
the first few to try the new lawnmower
5.0 Ultra and to say it's a game Cher is
an understatement as and as you've heard
from the rest of the crew it is
absolutely a game Cher manscapes fifth
generation trimmer features two nextg
interchangeable skin safe blade heads a
standard trimmer blade for taking a
little off the top and a new foil blade
to go for that smooth finish whenever
your heart desires no more wet shaving
down there count me in this bad boy also
features dual LED spotlights to provide
contrast on multiple skin tone so you
can shed some light on your darkest Airy
places then we have then we're talking
three length setting com combs for all
of your desired lengths and oh did I
mention this the trimmer is waterproof
too if you're taking it on the go
manscaped has you covered this puppy
comes with a travel case and even a
travel lock feature to avoid any
accidental powering onon and or weird
looks in the airport when you something
is just buzzing your bag the right this
right here is on The Cutting Edge of
cutting pubes upgrade your ball trimmer
and your life will follow so you get 20%
off plus free shipping with the code
iron Lords manscape.com that's 20% off
plus free shipping with the code iron
Lords manscape.com your balls have been
through enough it's time to go Ultra
with manscape I can't with
SL that was excellent reason
he's extra extra extra extra extra extra
thank you guys listen man you know we
when we come on here we talk about these
things these important things that must
be discussed must be discussed why they
got the rocket ship yo and and and it's
and it's really weird to talk about
because those are stuff that men don't
talk about not at all not at all but I I
I appreciate that they've made it a
conversation that's easy to have and
like you said funny to have too right
because they want you to throw in your
own little sort of stories about it and
everybody has a story because again like
adct said you never want you never want
your significant other to tell you it's
time to go handle that like that's you
don't want that no do your due diligence
do your
diligence oh hold on jez is down with
the team hold on jez is down with the
team I did not want to force it upon but
I know J is down with the team yeah yeah
I love this [__] man I got I got tons of
them L just we've been we've been
partner up with manc for a while now sh
the manc down with the team two heads
than one listen I tell you yeah weed
right yo weed whacker that's weed
whacker that's old one all I ask is
language on the launch day
4.0 yeah the we whack is
offici boy I love the beard hedger man I
it down here on sides keep keep it keep
it you know looking even and stuff
beards grow out right like it gets crazy
and you want to do handyman under here
that right products man legit salute
fantastic product salute to manscape we
shout out to manscape hand in the
business all right so we just got a
couple more Super chest so we get into
these topics okay hold on a second let
me get to these we have uh on a second I
can do payon questions if you want no I
have it right here didn't tendon diaku
remember for five months Lord silver I
want I want what he's smoking big link
did1 18 million in one month Spider-Man
is St he would be lucky to sell that at
the end of the
generation down I knew Nintendo was not
yeah he was he was going to come for you
knew come for you no doubt then we have
Cory Tidwell $2 Super Chat y'all little
man little man is
crazy you got to have a little man for
the little man you know what I'm
saying there we go shout out to Cedric H
put the CR in the chat for Cedric H for
gifting five ILP memberships thank you
brother appreciate that salute here we
got s Jutsu Sage 30 months Lord gold
King said the manscape law more 5.0
Ultra comes with three heads as a one
piece fan that means it should be
nicknamed Blackbeard if you know you
know King do we approve he's he's
smiling he's yes
okay what else we got then we got DJ
Berto dos $5 Super Chat Lord Sab save
that display show for
joystick I'm sure you wouldn't mind
seeing the show downstairs yeah that's
your only Sol
accounts
exactly uh we caught up all right I was
saying to myself I was like did he lose
his mind today yo I I really thought he
was about to do something I got really
nerv about to unpin
him get him out of here he's like turned
the camera off yeah cuz he stood up I
was like whoa yeah what happened
joystick showed up to my stream
yesterday oh yeah I saw you was out
here beefy outside with it too we can
move on oh we a going to talk about that
we going talk about that about that
you can't bring it up and not talk about
it back to you
s we're good we're done we have time we
have time do have to take all right so
patreon questions real quick shout out
to Anthony Capello soon to be in the
realm he joined the uh patreon guest
here so we will be having him in the
realm soon good good Sunday my lords
with games like Spider-Man 2 Mario
Wonder Call of Duty and Allan Wake
ending this giant year of gaming will
this take the top spot in gaming history
as the best year ever have a beautiful
Sunday and happy star hunting um what do
we think guys let's start with actually
JZ for a little bit I'm just curious
what he thinks about um is this the best
gaming year ever according to Anthony
Capello man it's it's it's hard to it's
weird right because it's it's been such
an amazing year of content like Game
Pass has never been so strong there so
so many games were backlog I was like
looking at like um XBox has this play
later featur right yes which I've
started started using a lot more now and
um some people are telling me to turn up
my mic you guys hear me all right no you
sound great you sound fantastic yeah
you're good excellent excellent well um
anyway uh yeah I was looking at my play
later list and I've got games going like
you know I got still got W long Fallen D
which is W when did that launch launch
in like February right February very
early yeah and it's and it's like how do
I fit all this stuff in so from a from a
game perspective yeah it's been
incredible but then you look at the
other side of the industry there like
layoffs left right in center Unity
exploding
itself and you know all this other crazy
chaos and stuff going on so it's like
selfishly for me yeah it's I it's it's
been a long time since we've had maybe
even going back as far as the 360 area
where there's just been Banger after
Banger after banger but then like when
you are sort of in the podcasting space
or journalist or YouTube or whatever and
you sort of take a more a deeper look at
the industry and a more analytical
approach it's hard it's hard to like
feel totally celebratory about it when
you got like all these layoffs and stuff
popping off I don't know man no I feel
you so so yeah mixed back bro mix valid
points I feel you bro uh who else I want
to jump in as far as uh start with you
adct is this the top spot in gaming
history ever this year 202 I wouldn't
say like top in gaming history but I'll
say like in the last decade
like it's it's I can't remember a time
where like most of the time this is the
only time where like the games defeated
me like I I just I just don't have time
for everything I had to drop Liza P I
had to drop like a variety like it got
to the point where if I didn't get a
review code for your game so I can
schedule to play your game I wasn't
playing your game because the moment
you're that game came out like a day
later something else came out and then
Boulders gate Starfield popped out and
it said we're taking up the majority of
your year and then it just it's crazy
Zelda thank God I dropped Zelda you know
you know I I I don't I don't know if I
could have done it if I kept that game
in the rot big link big link yeah no uh
it was little link to me oh okay okay so
that's not your game of the year then n
it's not voters gate three is my game no
doubt no doubt we know that ain't going
to get it so oh my
God you are out of control sir Lord s
greatest uh gaming year uh yeah I mean I
I agree with jez like it's it is that
thing where it's like on the one hand
you have more games coming out now than
ever right so for that level of quality
to that bar to remain up there is kind
of crazy because when you look back at
these other great years in the past just
the amount of games coming out just
pales and comparison to now so the fact
that we have so much stuff and the pro
the the potential for so much drible to
be coming out for so much of it to be
good um and we're not even talking we
talk about the big releases and stuff
like that but even the stuff that's
under the radar very very good quality
game so it's it's it's up there it
definitely is up there but again the
stuff that's going on in the industry is
just weird because it's again it's more
and more money driven everything is
money driven everything is bottom line
so we we're going to continue to see
like great product come out but on on
the back end you know the people making
the games maybe not in a stable of a
position as they'd like to be but um
yeah there there's just a lot of great
games coming out and again I can't even
quantify it completely yet cuz we don't
have Allan Wake out yet yeah still more
to come still still more to come like
and and I missed to the backlog uh point
I have I turned I turned Zelda on for 10
minutes oh wow I turn Zelda on for 10
minutes it's crazy I call it Corporate
Quarter chasing they always trying to
make more money than they last did the
last quarter it's like no no longer it's
it's it's a good thing we making
billions of dollars of of profit we we
got to make a billion and two next
quarter
a lot of corporate cogs outside right
now they try trying to get that
money no doubt Lord King greatest year
off in gaming for you this year what you
feel yeah it it might be the only one I
can think of that probably comes uh
close to it is uh
1999 um with you know 9999 oh you okay
Dreamcast La all that okay yeah because
you had a console and you had 20 new
games uh all in one shot like all in one
week was King the only thing really
missing from this crazy year is like a
console release well you did have a
console release that's what I'm saying
this year well yeah this year you you
did you had uh The Meta quest uh you
met psvr2 the rag the quest but you know
what adct really means I know what he
means he means stuff that's not uh
passion projects oh my Lord Jes I mean
you will have a you're going to have a
new PlayStation next month yeah dude
there you go there new system yeah this
is true so I this
year ah it's just so many good games and
then when you're trying to catch up yeah
there's games that they drop inside Game
Pass or PlayStation Plus y like or it's
indie games that you see that you want
and that you like yo let me get them now
and um and I'mma catch up to him it just
it just never really works out like uh
like I said wizard with with a gun I was
just like oh snap it's out let me let me
jump in it's out the same time as Mario
and Spider-Man bro like bro it's crazy
I'm with you yeah I jump in I think it
is one of the the greatest [__] because
I it's the pure depth of quality and
then it's like like you said there's so
many in the cut games that I played
that's amazing like planet atana
cocon um from space bro we forgetting
about highi Rush already highi Rush was
this year like it it's crazy Z
final F 16 there's so many games
Starfield there's so many games that
like it's just people are right now
going crazy to me about lies of P madd's
going hard for it you know a lot of
people like yo that's my game Jee Parker
like that's my game of the year I'm like
it's insane pure volume you know what
I'm saying kind of thing so but to J's
point it it's crazy because you got the
games are like all the way up here but
the industry is kind of weird on some
level with the layoff well the industry
is going through a huge transition yeah
right but between
consolidation uh the fact that we in a
recession um and the move from physical
to
digital people don't
realize some companies aren't ready for
the move from physical to digital and
those people that were in charge of
doing uh physical stuff you you're not
necessary anymore right so if you're
your part was you dealing with Logistics
and stuff like that you became
irrelevant once they made an AI and then
made um in inhouse store yeah right so a
lot of times you start to see your
volume decrease and it's it it sucks but
the AI the invention of the AI has taken
a lot of these guys jobs so a lot of I'm
talking about other um right Developer
jobs too like they're using AI for to do
some sort of code on some parts of games
yes right so let's say you was in charge
of of uh I don't know uh section b or
whatever with with the enemies that is n
and void now because AI has taken over
that spot so we no longer need you we
can save money here and it sucks because
now your job is not there anymore where
in the industry can you go you know fix
that it it sucks really bad because
we're making more money as a as a
industry whole M but we're seeing the
most layoffs at the same time facts and
some stuff came out on Lord's game I
think uh some layoffs with PlayStation
arst something it's gaming now right
now.net shout out to to Nick he put that
out there it's it's all over the place
man yeah I agree so it's it's that weird
dichotomy we got to get through these we
got a couple more um patreon question I
do want to get through oh dip down dip
down no not your fault you you spitting
dip down games and Anime here comes the
trouble all right you fell into the
dimensional dragon's trap he is now
summoned Wesker Ganon and kefa to Aid in
the world's destruction unless all of
you can agree on which game is winning
game of the year if so the dragon agrees
to summon three gaming protagonist not
anime to um pick to to fight off these
the evil Wesker gon and kefka that's
going to destroy the world so if we
don't agree we all die the world is
destroyed we have to agree on the game
of the year I know this ain't gonna
happen but let's start with my brother
adct first because I already know he oh
ca you quick to blow up the world he
said he said he said Boulders gate he
already said it he said Boulders gate
right you standing on it oh that's his
game of the year but we
all why you got see I'm say because he's
asking we all agree on what to get see
you can have your passion and what you
want to win or what what you personally
feel now as someone who constantly wins
I'm telling you leave your leave your
emotions out of it well let's see he he
didn't say anything yet he didn't say he
said he said let everybody else go solve
back to
you all right let me start K guys camera
let me start with uh yeah s what what
what are we going to do what what are
you doing for the game of the year it's
zela it'sa oh you going with Zelda okay
chance to the kingdom okay so I
definitely we definitely going to die
for
me but right I got you um King so far I
know
Starfield we and you can't say Zelda cuz
that's uh nuts and bolts and uh DLC from
uh here we
go here we go with thinking again don't
think the numbers okay first first first
first he said we got to come up with a
consensus we got to come up with a
consensus not not what's going to be
game of the year he tried to get his
Video Game Awards yeah we I don't I
don't care about the only way to come up
with a consensus is to think objectively
no no well it's for us to come together
to say that we're dead we're not going
to come together on this cuz I'm I'm
damn sure not going with Zelda and I'm
damn sure not going with Boulders games
I I really enjoy Starfield but I
wouldn't say it's my game of the year so
we we definitely not winning this yeah I
think we got to die a horrible you're
going to die a horrible death I think oh
yeah cuz B this game man there's no
there's no debate game I I vote to
replace jez's opinion with King I love
bold is gay you you can say bold is gay
all you like don't dictate stuff so
sorry if y'all would have went all UniFi
Boulders gate I would have ConEd to save
the world but the most hour was the most
inment I had I know sorry to say it's
Starfield for me it's me and this gu
together even like I said even I know
it's not perfect what do you saying
s so s you wouldn't even go to Boulders
gate to save the world or you don't even
care about Baler SC he said he don't
care about the
world you know what it is it's just is
one of those things where there was
there's a lot of critical a great
critical reception right yeah and we
start looking at them numbers remember
seeing all the you know all that ah uh
PlayStation exclusive balers Gate 3 and
then and then the sales don't reflect
that and then because they don't buy
games so it's just
like I just think when I just look at
the number right and I never look at
Metacritic but at the end of the year
it's it's a good thing to look at this
is you forget to them and iind you I
have not played either one of them
really I hav played either one of them
and and je my feeling is that Zelda is
going to be voted game of the year no
but it's not about what it's going to be
voted it's what your personal video game
of the year my personal game so far so
far whatever for you whatever it is I'm
just curious what it is I haven't
finished to me it's Street Fighter six
to be honest then oh we definitely going
to die ad adct confirmed we are dead so
adct just confirmed just want to make
sure it was balers gate three you died
on that right all right see I I would
have been nice I would have conceited
and we'd have saved the world but it
blames off it BL
I wasn't I wasn't going to concede at
all like I it's it's one game there that
is generational okay and and these other
games they are just there sir you you
don't you a play W gate three no no I
didn't I didn't and but I was going to
okay but when it come out on Xbox I do
it I mean King in your mind and I I
respect that that's your but that gener
generational game you're talking about
is not even going to get nominated for
best game
of it's let me ask let me ask je let me
ask je this is a good question though
real quick I got you K jez do you think
there is some controversy that Starfield
might not make because it's such an
intense year do you think Starfield gets
nominated at the
keys not for game of the year I'm GNA
pour another drink then he then he needs
a package I think then he needs to
package show up there's a chance well if
it don't get nominated he need to
package show up
pack it up you need to pack it up
because you know what it's going to be a
point in time right now you going you
can't deny Us boy like is it's going to
be a point in time where every game that
comes out has a Microsoft Tag on it and
you g to put one of those games up and
it's going to win bya why is it by
default by
default consolidation going flood the
market the market you go you going to
recognize us we going to have we going
to buy your favorite developer and we
going to make those games and you going
to have to bend the knee so if you don't
give it up this year you already see
what DOL Phil is about do Phil is about
taking things and doing what he want
y'all in trouble keep playing around
withfield happen don't put Starfield up
there you gonna buy game the Year
sorry I personally think that Starfield
does and should be nominated okay okay
uh the only will
it if it's not I don't ever want to hear
about him again all right let's move we
got we got more pict I'm sorry sorry the
okay so everyone yeah SM said he would
he he's rioting boy he boy so the only
way I would join the
line is if I see that bad that annoying
looking Final Fantasy 16 there in I
Starfield oh so if Final Fantasy 16 get
that game don't even be talked about you
you going to get your your Ticky to is
your picking fan to you outside look
look look I know people love 16 and
that's cool but I don't love
16 16 I he nobody talk about 16 after
that week person would feel
betrayed if that game was up there and
not starfi all right we see let's move
we got move we got we got got a bunch of
patrion still um all right so dip down
we died I'm sorry every time dip down we
die we always die I think one year we we
saved ourselves snail killer Hello Lord
sorry to write this here but because you
or your community may miss it please if
you are playing Spider-Man 2 even if you
don't like doing side quests please do
the side quest the map that has
absolutely
enough the map that has a flame on it
contains information for the next game
that is massive okay to bring the energy
to the chat okay right Spider-Man is
buggy back to you sol so I guess it was
just a statement I guess it was a
statement addict says do not do he's not
doing any ain't doing no you know what's
funny in in that game like well we'll
talk about we'll talk about we talk
about we'll talk about do a lot of sad
stuff at all all fair enough fair enough
all right now these two may be old adct
correct me if they are hello Lords after
the leak of the new Xbox controller and
the push towards a cloud platform I
started to think about the control and
what it might mean going forward with
the event we did that okay I just want
to we did kurova hey I am new to the
patreon but a long time watching I've
been trying to buy a t-shirt but when I
check it out it says stays on loading
stream anyone with the same problem um
it's up today and um just so you know
you know Lord beef is available you can
go get that
little so if you have trouble you put
the link and help you out right there me
direct you to direct working yeah let's
direct you to what what's open right now
Advance line and this is the last week
for Hold the Line yeah Advance the line
beefy's up there cor Cog is up there
King Kings last week means two yeah two
week Go Get It Go Get It Get on his
nerves you you know Teespring is slow
with these things yeah no doubt so we
got that and then all right last week's
po results end the people spoken when
Microsoft finally um closing the deal
and acquiring ABK into Xbox game studios
and the rumors that they are not done
acquiring Studios what do you think Xbox
should acquire next the winner of the
four-way poll at 51% of the vote was
Sega 51% of the vote coming in at second
at 22% of the vote no one ask Xbox has
enough Studios a lot of PlayStation Duds
voted in third place at 177% of the vote
was Square Enix and in last
place with only 9% of the vote third
times the charm baby Nintendo we want
you and we going to have you shout out
to all the Lords who participated anyone
wants to call let's get jez uh Sega the
realm one Sega how do you feel about
that
jez all can you PA that last bit my boss
ask me too no you're good you're good so
basically with the you know ABK closing
everybody's uh the question was what's
next for Xbox to acquire and the realm
51% of the vote was Sega over a Square
Enix no over no one else Square Enix and
third time to char let's get back in the
room with Nintendo but Sega
one I kind of feel like that's hilarious
honestly let's go I'm half half of me
thinks like Microsoft probably won't
rush into a new acquisition at the
moment because they're probably like
from a managerial perspective I would
imagine they're going to have their
hands full with integrating ABK MH but
once they do have bandwidth to start
that train up again I kind of Wonder
like do they do they really have the the
will to go through all this regulatory
stuff again because I think like a big
name like Sega like he probably the kind
of publisher where you're going to see a
lot of regulators like oh my God it's
Sega they still make consoles right
let's block
this sega's like I don't know sega's
more of a household name so for me if it
was and and just to be clear I'm not an
acquisition lawyer and I'm not a
Microsoft guy and they they're probably
way more ambitious than me but if it was
me I would totally go more cautious and
be like let's go for square in because
they have a similar they have a similar
kind of they have the mobile games that
we want the Final Fantasy brand could be
way bigger and it needs more investment
I think because that I think they're
trying to do too much with I mean well
they're not trying they're not doing
enough I think like with with Final
Fantasy it'd be like the ideal scenario
would be you have like sorry what no I
said what you think what you think
you're cooking right now you got be you
go be excited I want to hear
my my my think my thought presence was
like because they should have like a
line of Final Fantasy games for the the
classic fans of the classic games and
then a line of Final Fantasy games that
sort of are action based and appeal to
the newcomers and then mobile games like
it blows my mind that scronic has not
just ripped off genin impact and put a f
of hansy skin on it yes you know like
adct played that PA West it was it
looked pretty good yeah so you know uh I
think
but Sega I think would be a regulatory
uphill battle and also I
think Sega probably needs some more
restructuring more so than scare Enix I
think okay so I think I think Sega might
be a little bit more of a challenge of a
challenge I think in in a lot of ways so
I think if it was if if I was Microsoft
I'd go for something a little bit easier
gotcha so basically I don't even know
the finances but we assume that the
evaluation for square would be higher
than Sega or Sega would be higher than
Square thus you know Microsoft might not
want that heat and the regulatory
attention and then go for I don't know
whose evaluation is bigger just uh just
for the record I don't know but we can
have a quick look shall we yeah if you
can square Square Enix market cap yeah
we know who had a folder yeah we know
both both of them were on the m&a list
that leaked in these in the ABK
situation so um it was one
folder well we got Jess so Square Enix
actually has a bigger market cap than
Sega slightly so sega's is 3.5 billion
and and Square Enix is is four billion I
did not know that I would have thought
Square Enix is spoiler but I would I
would agree with you though I do think
that because of the word Sega people
still you know kind of relate that to
like a console manufacturer in a way
even though they have been doing this in
a long time it I do think there would be
some like an Optics issue there I I I do
think there would be people especially
in our political Spectrum in America's
political spect that would assume
they're still making consoles like yeah
no this is this a good question I'm glad
you know we we we talked about how to
get jez's input on that while we got we
gonna get into these topics um Lord
addict there's a game that came out
Spiderman 2 dropped a lot of Impressions
I know you are probably one of the few
people that that I seen besides bit
Cloud after you that beat the game
already so um yeah give us your thoughts
where do you where does it land for you
you know talk talk to us you know
Spider-Man 2 is out here in these
streets uh let me uhoh oh oh chill CH
y you you scar me bro what's going on
why we got the chill why you looking at
the camera uhoh what's going on like a
like a manscape addendum coming yeah
like only addicts go yeah so I did beat
the game I don't know if you have like a
list of questions that you want to ask
me I mean for me my whole thing is I
probably got the least hour out of
everybody here you know what I'm saying
but you know I I'll just jump in with my
Impressions and then ask you a few
questions to build off that um you know
the game looked gorgeous um you know for
me it was uh 4K HDR I able to turn on
the vrr that 120 Herz is moving he's
zipping around this the city I felt the
combat was fast-paced um as far as one
of my favorite skills like the momentum
swinging when you got that for both they
got the skill tree for both and then um
the gadgets with do you know I can never
get the loop-de-loop thing to work oh
you can't get looop I tried so many
times that maybe I'm doing something
wrong or maybe it's bugged because at
this point I don't know what is what but
I would try because it it literally just
says hold R2 when you're when when yeah
when you're when you're going down and
every time he just strings up like it
just he never does the full loopd loop
yeah for me it was acrobatic the Rhythm
the parrying the special moves it was a
nice flow to it Kings killing me with
that with that Spiderman we gonna get to
you King but um the thing I do want to
ask also because so far I probably got
like five six hours I was playing Tekken
this weekend I'm just G to be honest but
um the thing I will say to solve still
don't like his voice miles's voice I
hate miles's voice but I got to be
honest at first I didn't know how to
take the bug situation you know what I'm
saying and that's why I would to ask you
adct it's like did you come across any
bugs bro all right I'm not oh you didn't
even play that long you bro that's yeah
all right I can't so I can't spoil the I
shouldn't spoil the name of the first
boss no don't SPO any of it say so I
won't all I will say the first boss
encounter that you
encounter it was a lot of swinging
involved just to clarify we're talking
about the tutorial boss right no I
believe so yeah I believe the start of
the game whatever the start of the game
whatever the first major boss that you
fight it there's a sequence of swinging
and then you have to press an input like
a a triangle or whatever whatever and
then that proceedes and then you knock
things down as it was going it stopped
recognizing the triangle input and the
boss had this much energy left and I'm
like I'm doing it multiple time like
what is going on it was so bad The Game
Wouldn't progress I had to die and then
reload the save and then it worked and
I'm just like the game progression I'm
like yo what what's up with that of
course there's going to be little
glitches here and there and the last
point I saying I'll give it to you adct
because I'm curious about your
experience is the there was a I'm trying
not to spoil there's a stealth section
in a
school and I was in this
section and yeah you gotta you got to
string somebody up and I had to get to
this point and the game is telling me L2
string up or whatever right wouldn't
string up right yeah and I'm like bro
I'm I'm sitting there like what is going
on again I have to pause the gate kill
myself get spotted or whatever and
actually load the last checkpoint and
then it worked so my issue this is so
early I am surprised that it I would I I
thought it was going to be graphical
bugs or something that that's my like
that comes in the game but game prog
aggression bugs really bother me I was
getting frustrated I was surprised to
see that happen and I do want to shout
out um ACG who put out a statement in
reference to the bugs he's encountered
it feels it seems like there's a there
was a day one patch that may have made
things worse I don't know if there was
different from the reviewers and shout
out to John lindman who um jez Cordon
had on the Xbox 2 recently with with ran
you know he confirmed it he was like it
he wonder if the patch messes up cuz now
he's in encountering all these bugs so
ad I'm going to give it to you will give
it to y'all who ever played I definitely
experienced it yeah it's a very buggy
game um my PlayStation soft crash three
times oh where it it would do that it
would do that like a little loading
thing you we want to tell PlayStation is
that okay with you like I had that
happened three times you said it crashed
three times yeah well it didn't like the
whole PlayStation crash you just booted
back to the menu three times oh it just
kicked you out just I had multiple
uh multiple menu cues where like Cog was
saying you click something and it I head
to the point where I was fighting in a
certain Coliseum thing and it was like
yo push this button and this button and
and I had to keep it felt like to me if
I didn't pre and I kept dying so I had
to like I I would sit there I I would
fight these
individuals and then if I died and I
went back to it it might it glitched
again so I was literally C the
restart the restart um Che Cheo yeah
four or five times to get one run
through and then if I died I'd have to
reset it another four or five times to
get another run through uh because what
was going on is it was like glitching it
wasn't
registering that the buttons worked yes
and and it's just like then I had a time
uh there's like a like and P people said
I did the side mission I didn't do the
activities like the uh you know the pr
the prowler stuff I didn't do none of
that stuff like the little I call it
their version of book
bags um and the funny thing is they they
you don't need none of that to be honest
with you because okay maybe in
spectacular I see like Persona playing
on spectacular even smooth for some
reason plan on spacular with
so they they kind of like put a lot of
that with like the hero points and stuff
where you can actually add on to your
stuff tell me how I upgraded two natural
stats
too and tell me
how I didn't have much issues in this
game like like I would say the
difficulty of this game
is yeah it's difficulty with them dogs
yeah I I would say that um the game the
game difficulty is very low it is it's
very low uh I was very I was a little
bit disappointed with that I personally
felt like cuz they took away like the
little Gadget well now everything's like
uh it's like L1 L1 R1 which is a way
better system I like it yeah I like it
way better system and but the problem is
when you make stuff simpler it's easier
in the actual game like I I was getting
to the point where nothing was touching
me nothing nothing and then there's
stuff that go on in the future that
nothing really ain't touching me like
and you know because I I talked to King
I was like King I thought I knew a
little bit about
Spiderman stuff was happening and that's
like did Insomniac do this or is this a
real person I was Googling them go get a
contact King for the Lord one thing I
want to really you know I want to really
give a shout out to them they really
captured Peter with the simu suit on
because you you know obviously we've
seen him in in the trailers where you he
he his personality changes like like
it's just how you would expect it to be
and they did a really good job right it
it um I beat it in like probably 12 13
hours like I said I didn't do none of
the you know uh I didn't do most of the
activity stuff I didn't care to be
honest with you they they tied it to
it's like I said they tied it to Stats
you can get your HP up your focus I I
focused all on the focus thing cuz to me
I can help myself with Focus why why
anything else so you did but did you as
far as did you level up because you know
you got miles and skill tree then you
got Peter and then you got the
combination of both I loved how they did
that I like how they did that that was
dope I'm gonna be real with you you
don't need none of that either really
like for the most part now all that
makes the game significantly easier but
just how they they do the you know the
the countering system the new Parry
system that's all you really need that
Parry is crazy you could probably beat
this game now obviously I did update all
that stuff I updated all the skills but
you could realistically easily beat this
game with just the parry and the and the
dodging what about what about the the um
the fly with the suit with the Glide now
how you like like 100%
better I think I'd have collected book
bags if it was in
this you wasn't taking photos you for
the D you wasn't run speaking of the
photos the very first time you did the
photo
thing I like cuz they're like get on top
of a building and take a picture I'm
sure you guys know it's at the very
beginning of the game tell me how I I
lag through the building oh and I was in
the building on the bottom of the
building and I can still bring up the
picture but when I'm supposed to be
taking the picture is above me so I had
to reload the checkpoint that was the
first issue I had I it's like I said I
had a multiple audio in uh in glitches
yeah it it wasn't bad audio it was just
like buzzing like like certain like key
effects like a
bug no it it would be like let's say
let's say the the electricity sound
sometimes that would stay a little
longer than it should have yeah and then
I had um Electro
here I I I had a lot of like clipping in
certain areas there uh now obviously
people say well addict you know they
they
were you know there's a lot of people
you can actually go in the mode and look
like there's clipping but no there's
actual clipping in the game like there's
no denying that apparently if you take I
saw someone on Twitter and you can't
Photoshop this this was live they were
they were on the bike and they were
clipping through the every AB every NPC
on the sidewalk so it's like the game
was like take this area this middle area
but if you go on the left or right none
of the NPCs are registering you're on a
bicycle oh you talking about yeah I know
which part you're talking about okay
okay okay yeah I did I didn't challenge
the game that way but I heard people did
yeah here's the thing besides the photo
mode thing because that's you you should
be ashamed of yourself besides that
people are say well adct some of these
Xbox or are they're they're they're
trying to break the
game okay they paid x amount of dollars
to try to break the game you know what
shouldn't happen the game should
break you in a little stuff like falling
through the map I don't care what people
try you shouldn't fall through the
map and then people are sitting there
and they're like they're like oh these
are just small no the there is multiple
anytime you have to reload a checkpoint
that's a game breaking that's what I was
about to ask you because that's what
surprised me I didn't I was explicit
clipping happens you know your feet is
UN on a Sur no not you not you no no no
I I was say that's what I say I didn't
say nothing about that in the funny
thing is just like none of that bothered
me you know you know why I I think that
they got a huge pass on this because
their checkpoint system is
extremely easy they have check for
everything so realistically if you have
a glitch that happens you have to uh
reload the last checkpoint it's probably
gonna be two minutes back yeah no
absolutely but I'm glad you said I I'm
glad you mentioned that I you had the
tapable which was a game progression bug
where you literally cannot go for it
because of whatever is not registering
or whatever but I'm glad but I know we
talked about Buzz last thing I want to
say before we move on is just that you
beat it bro like you beat it right so
like game playay exper like is it one of
the top joints ever is this
PlayStation's best exclusive me to me
it's the best PlayStation 5
game that's even even though the bugs
and stuff annoyed me I there was a one
time even even when I was in that part
where I had to probably spent an hour
reloading checkpoints just to fight this
one particular fight I was like let's do
it I really enjoyed it and you know I'm
a huge person on boss fights I was very
critical of the boss fights and and
Spiderman one it's like they listened to
exactly what I thought like cuz the the
boss fights in this game completely on a
different level multiple areas sometimes
you chasing them sometimes you not Chas
them they're changing the the the the
ways you fight them they're changing the
conditions you fight them like
phenomenal boss fights and especially
the last boss fight I'm not going to say
what it is who it is or anything that is
some of the best like what's the the
word you use when you when you determine
how a fight is done uh mechanics or um
no uh people do it in like actual fights
like fight scen choreography
choreography of that fight is intense it
kept me all my the the edge of my seat
the whole time I I love like the the
Bantry between people is just insane in
this game I give that and then when you
add like
I didn't I knew here's the thing I
didn't know because obviously it's not a
spoiler Venom in the game right I didn't
know that when you put that suit on it
changed you to that degree I just
thought it made you more aggressive I
didn't know it changes your personality
pretty much simbi baby yeah symbiot
takes over you and that that is the
single Handa the best narrative thing
when you add that CA in this giant
mixing pool known as Spider-Man
mhm I feel like the relationship between
Peter and miles is
phenomenal you know this this is so what
would you give it though yeah what's the
score I I want to give it a nine but
those glitches man I got to give it a
eight and and it's just like the game's
that good it really is it's you know
even all these issues I would even say
wait for a day one patch just hit that
re restart checkpoint over
and it's just like it's a good game it
really is it's fun so the person that
advocates for people taking time with
broken games don't put them games out uh
bugs and stuff like that you said just
buy the game and if you counter the bug
just go back to the checkpoint okay I
get it I get it I have an issue with how
the developers and stuff are handling it
uh apparently they they they put the
wrong flag in the game as well oh sof we
get the resid the the developers are are
taking ownership they're taking
accountability that's my issue talking
about the Cuban flag yeah they had the
Cuban flag that's the Lord Lord Puerto
Rico do we see cuz I what I I initially
I looked at it quickly and I just wanted
to make sure that they they hadn't put
the old Puerto Rican flag which uh the
blue part of the flag is lighter than
what it is now they changed it to make
it more more akin to the the the colors
of the United States flag but no this is
this is the Cuban
flag this is the Cuban flag yeah that
that is egregious that is egregious
quality control is key over there
something that is egregious something's
going on and it's just like yeah yeah
room is burning now sonc has responded
and said that they're going to fix it
but yeah that that especially with
miles's background from Puerto Ric and
them not having made that type of
mistake in his game um and then being so
good about you know authenticity when it
came to especially Christmas time like
Christmas time you get Christmas time
Puerto Rican stuff wrong they're going
riots in the street and they they kind
of got it right so um yeah I mean I
gu but we don't we don't got the flag
right they got Bastas they got P they
got it all you know uh they had whole
conversations in Spanish but couldn't
get the flag right yeah hold now we
going open it up to to Sol it King but I
got it cuz I know jez you know resident
Xbox but uh is is play Spider-Man 2
something you would be interested in
it's something that you got your eye I
know you love the MCU you love Mar Lord
these are your favorite type of
games no I'm I'm just not a superhero
guy man like I I I sort of have some
passing interest in Batman and and DC
but like Marvel's just it's way too
colorful
and I love his disc I want to SP I want
I want a spawn game or a Judge Dread
game on on that sort of quality yeah I
don't know I don't know I'm kind of emo
I guess but um I but like looking at it
from the outside um you know and someone
who Rel you know I Sunset Overdrive was
the first ever tripa game that I
reviewed the first ever one that I had a
review code for like God God knows how
long ago this was now like this is this
is before I was like professional or
whatever like reviewed on my own blog M
um so Insomniac is kind of special to me
in this sort of weird way yes um but um
so like looking at it from the outside
and seeing like the technical the
technical capability of the studio and
how they've sort of
um I people say they car they've been
carrying Sony right and they're kind of
like they've been so consistent with
their delivery of games and and high
quality games and critically acclaimed
games it's kind of impressive looking
for the outside doesn't appeal to me
personally I'm not going to run out and
buy a PS5 for it um but uh yeah glad
that people are enjoying that I guess I
do have one more question for you
specifically I know you know this is not
your your style of game but I guess the
question since we're on the subject of
bugs and you know I see where King is
about to go I think but I want to ask
you this just like what do you feel
about you know some some Xbox fans felt
upset that uh Starfield was uh really
penalized for their bugs at launch and
now with affecting the Metacritic store
whereas you know Spider-Man it's coming
out now that there are you know a lot of
technical issues and bugs with it you
know I'm not going to go down the media
bias path but what do you think about
I'm not going to go down the media bi
path but but I have to ask you what do
you think about bugs affecting review
score in general you know work you
Windows Central you you you cover a lot
of games like how much does that factor
into for your reviews you're talking to
a guy guy Sy Punk 10 out of 10 at launch
so you know
wow you were play the p you was good
yeah I was definitely on the PC version
but even the PC version had like some
bugs and quirks like I remember when I
was reviewing it there was there was a
sequence where like a pretty emotional
sequence where the the character model
had come out of sync with the camera so
like the the character model was sort of
like the camera was moving but the
charact the character kept sliding out
of shot and I was like man that really
sucks because it's like you know it's
it's emotional impact moment but like
that's the only bug that I can remember
from reviewing sober Punk on on my PC
you know but like there was a there was
a naivity with me where I was kind of
like man it's so weird they wouldn't
give us an Xbox review code I'm sure
it's fine
though and now I've now I've learned my
lesson you know so it's like when when
the devs insist on a PC version and they
they like the the Xbox codes will come
at launch then he's kind of like okay
there's something wrong with the console
version so there was a teachable there
was a teachable moment for me but some
reviewers are more sensitive to that
thing than others I personally don't
really care that much about bugs you
know unless it's something like constant
crashing or you know um just glitches
that constantly interfere with with game
playay and stuff the problem like I
think it was it was Paul tassy from
Forbes put out an article recently where
it was like social media really blows
bugs out of proportion because people
people take the little clips and um and
they're just like and it it presents the
whole game in that frame of
you know that frame and it could be like
there it could be like that you've had a
20 20 30 hour long experience and maybe
maybe experienced two two bugs that were
worth clipping to put on Twitter or
something and that was my experience
with cyber Punk on PC like I played the
game for 30 hours through to review and
I maybe had like two major issues with
the game and I I remember this other
issue where like sometimes cars would
clip through the floor and there was
another issue where sometimes uh guns
would float in the air after you'd
killed an enemy like the gun hadn't
properly Reg to the fact that it was no
longer being held by an NPC and it
wouldn't hit the ground right so like
and it was just like those things didn't
bother me that much and maybe they
bother some reviews more than others or
some Gamers more than others but I don't
really care about bugs you know and
things can be fixed and Polished and
patched and stuff and it's like is the
underlying is the underlying ISS is the
underlying um is the underlying game you
know does it work is it playable is it
functional you know and definitely it's
obvious viously preferable if you know
the the game you're paying $70 for is
completely 10 out of 10 polish true MIM
but his game's get increasingly more
complex and our expectations grow in
terms of you know complexity and and
overlapping systems and that kind of
thing bugs and [__] happens occasionally
like fair enough I just think I just
think it's like you
know I've got bigger problems I I got
I've got bigger problems to worry about
than like a floating gun or or NPC
getting stuck in a lamp post or
something get get some real problems get
some real problems fair enough that's
where you at that's where you at Lord
solve your experience in Spider-Man 2
how we feeling Impressions where you
at um yeah so I I have maybe like five
or six hours in um and I downloaded it
right at midnight um and I didn't play I
I got up early to play a little bit
right so uh different to uh Spider-Man
remastered and Miles Morales I played
those those two on my previous
television so I played them in R tracing
uh performance mode gotcha so here I was
like you know what got the new TV let me
try out the Fidelity mode in conjunction
with vrr and the 120 HZ mode on at the
same time and from the OD the onset of
the game like at the outset it was it
was clippy it was weird it was bugging
out so I was like all right let me turn
off this vrr and just leave it 120 and
see if that runs fine and that fixed it
so at I fixed it and I did like the that
first boss battle I actually left it in
the middle of the first boss battle and
I didn't come back to it until last
night when I come back to it last night
I had to go do a restart because
apparently something was some kind of
patch or something was downloaded and
now the vrr was fixed and I had I could
run it in Fidelity mode with vrr full on
on vrr I think on automatic or something
like that or smooth or something yeah
smooth automatic with the 120 yeah right
and I had the 120 on as well and it was
smooth as butter wo it was so beautiful
um so I'm gonna be frank I didn't have a
lot of the glitches that people are
talking about only played like five or
six hours but I haven't had those issues
the only thing that I that for me
happened was I had one or two little um
audio glitches where where the like
background music was garbled a little
bit then it fixed itself and then
another thing that I had was when I like
to run up the buildings run up the
buildings and at the top of the building
at the top of the building hit X and
shoot myself off and my momentum so for
a little while there the X prompt wasn't
coming up and it wasn't well when I got
to the top of the building he would just
run up to the top of the building and
just not and not sling himself over had
um and I was like wow why is it not is
not reacting but then after a while that
also sort of fixed itself it happened a
couple of times and it fixed itself and
then since then haven't really had
anything major in terms of glitches just
the idea that sometimes when I you know
when you hit the two um trigger buttons
to try to uh ZIP to a point every now
and again he won't zip he won't land on
the point per se he'll get there and do
that same thing where he's kind of
floating in place and just drops down
right um and then when you compare that
to the to remastered remastered off the
bat to me was like this this perfect
feeling sort of like none of that none
of that was broken really um so that
honestly the only thing in terms of bugs
and glitches that has affected me so far
um in terms of what I feel about the
game gorgeous game is beautiful the game
is beautiful aesthetically playing it on
that Fidelity mode um seeing you know
the the the added sort of you know we
pay attention to those little things so
like the added Fidelity to the raay
trace uh sort of Reflections and shadows
uh really makes a difference although I
haven't I like I said I played R tracing
performance before and before that
difference wasn't Stark I haven't even
gone to it yet I'm going to try it but I
haven't gone to it because the Fidelity
mode has been so good um the the density
of just the people in the city walking
down um just going down one thing that
that was weird to me is that he doesn't
have a walk animation now it's like a
creep animation
he it's is weird I'm like where's the
walk animation he's just creeping around
like the people on the ground it was
very weird little things like that um
but overall the game is just gorgeous um
the addition of Brooklyn and Queens
Queens in the building the addition of
the wings like the the city feels so
much more alive they they really did a
great job with that um let me address
something real quick in the chat so
people sitting there saying what where
was this energy with cyber punk where
was this energy with with Lords of the
Fallen those games were genuinely broken
there's difference between a game having
bugs and being an inconvenience and a
game not functioning correctly yeah
acting like they're the same cuz you
guys were willing to be oh where was
that energy for Starfield
cuz there were bugs in Starfield but I
told you guys I educated and said these
are the issues I had but there has been
patches that is put out but I would
still recommend star where was that
energy Chad yeah where was that energy
saying where's that energy I love y'all
but if y'all here just to the just to
hate for the sake of hating go go go
play a game just wait for K just wait
for I give opportunity to do
your for he got this don't wor the devil
going to get his
d continue so
um so yeah so the game is a gorgeous
game and I to me the things that they've
done to to sort of elevate the city and
make it feel more alive is great the um
I found that I love miles as a character
I've said it before I'm not a fan of his
voice me too he he doesn't sound like a
New Yorker he sounds like a Cali kid
like K and and and I I love the I love
the per apart from How The Voice Sounds
the performance is good I just don't
like the tone he does not sound like a
New Yorker that's just my beef with him
um but overall like move set uh the
things he can do in conjunction with
Peter I think is very cool although for
me it's like I get it putting them
together in one game but I it feels like
to me this is a Peter story right I want
I want to see how they incorporate miles
into the story right it's very
interesting to me but at the same time
the Symbiote story whatever that's a
Peter story to me so I'm like I'm kind
of sticking to to Peter in that regard
um but miles's move set is super you
know it's it's super fun and interesting
his you know his his athleticism and how
acrobatic he is in conjunction with like
the the Venom powers super fun to use um
the things that they've done to combat
to simplify to adct point to me I really
enjoy that the fact that everything is
on Face buttons now you just press R1 to
L1 and it happens very quickly um yeah I
mean everything they've done to combat
just beautiful like the the the
additional sort of finishing moves and
things like that um the way that they
kind of you know how these games the
sequels will tell you like oh you lost
all your powers you got to start all
over again it's kind of like that but it
doesn't feel that way like you the in
the joint Powers you see that there's
certain powers that were in the skill
tree beforehand that it's like oh okay I
did this before whatever but they've
added stuff as well so it kind of feels
like at the end of it if once you get
everything out it might be a little
overwhelming to pick certain things that
you like and dislike but again the first
one was real good at kind of picking the
way you play as Spider-Man right your
your different moves and stuff like that
the different gadgets that you employ
makes each person's gameplay style a
little bit different so I enjoyed that
um in terms of story so far I think
it's what they try to do and I I don't
know that I dislike it at all like there
there are quiet moments that they create
in there that uh they cinematic moments
that have gameplay interpers in them
whether like flashback moments or stuff
like that that what they're trying to do
is just give you a sort of backstory on
these characters their relationships and
things like that and I think for the
most part it works because the thing
about it like for me like in comics like
you read a comic Comics are these
ongoing stories have been going on
forever right but at the same time
they're not a novel right a novel is is
is meant to give you every little detail
in something and and then you know when
you when you take that novelization and
turn it into a game or a movie you have
to kind of Whittle that down a little
bit so here they're like okay we're
going to fill in these blanks in a way
it's kind of my criticism of the first
uh games with the you know like the
stealth part portions with like MJ or
stuff that I didn't like those things I
didn't like but these particular
instances that I'm talking about where
it's more narrative driven and trying to
show you relationships to me I thought
they worked I thought the little
gameplay stuff interspersed within them
worked just to give context for where
these characters have been together
where they're going um kind of who they
are as people and how they are you know
if you're a fan of these characters in
different iterations how they're
different in this Insomniac version so I
thought that was cool there's some weird
little gameplay things that they
Implement that kind of feel like
one-offs like there's like a a a
basketball shooting mechanic did you
make your shot did you did you beat your
Miss see at first I was like do I even
try to and I didn't realize I can
control it and then I was like wait a
minute I can control it so I I only hit
one
basket yeah I was like
now I'm like damn I want to know if I
made it and beat him if I get a trophy
for that yeah good so right and that
might be a trophy or something that you
go back to I beat them you don't get no
trophy you don't get no trophy thank you
King for for clarifying very quickly but
it just cool stuff like uh the the fall
damage I don't know if any of yall got
the Splat um the Splat Trophy and
because I went to the highest building I
could find and just jumped off and then
did the dive right down and uh yeah it
was it was funny because you just kind
of crash um but I enjoyed it I'm
enjoying it so far uh I'm excited to see
where they go with with you know with
Craven and with Venom and and that
um I I I think it's a great game I think
it's a great game and I haven't had the
issues that other people have had so and
that happens right sometimes people's uh
you know uh experiences with the game
just differ so much and it's like what
the heck happened you know people talk
about crashing to desktop you know
crashing to the the home screen and
stuff like that so I'm enjoying what
I've seen so far
uh I'm interested to you know H shout
out to hog hog I put out you know kind
of a little statement on Twitter talking
about how he feels like the storytelling
and and how Sony games uh approach to
narrative is sort of overindulgent and
Bloated and it it instead of it it shows
you instead of just having you infer
things you know it kind of treats the
audience maybe like they're a little
dumb that have they have to they have to
expound on every single little emotional
beat
and I get it at the same time this isn't
like it does the storytelling I don't
think is as refined as maybe a Last of
Us or that because it is Spider-Man it
is it does have to be more broadly
appealing I think so I get it when they
sort of maybe treat you like you're a
little dumb or you're a little you know
immature and and kind of explain
something that's maybe obvious just ping
to Their audience yeah so I don't I
don't necessarily mind that so much but
maybe it'll it'll be more grading on me
uh as I go along the game but so far
five or six hours in I am thoroughly
enjoying Spider-Man 2o I really am no
doubt Lord King this is the one I've
been waiting for because obviously you
are a huge Spider-Man fan you you are
our resident lore when it comes down to
the comics on what's authentic what's
accurate you know Spider-Man 2018 you I
believe you had his game of the year you
you dressed up you called your shot you
said it was going to do whatever it it
did it
so I got to know I am very I know you
are passionate about this
game hold let me put the camera you I'm
still here so I don't think I'm gone
I'll still check
you well well first first Go kid uh adct
uh this is for you oh we bended the knee
oh the knee has been bent y'all I can't
remember what the B was oh because it
didn't come out on PlayStation 4 right
he's a man of his word he's a man of his
word there you go um you got your knees
no doubt salute all right so um that's
the second pair of knees oh well you
know um next year it'll come out on
PlayStation 4 so
I King is Right 88% of the time 88 went
88 it's 98% 98 right Spidey yes 98
um for all you frauds out there day one
I got this not the
remaster day one PlayStation
4 by the way this Peter Parker is the
better Peter Parker that other
dude throw that guy away you mean about
the you mean you mean the actor the the
the face model model with what happened
the face the face his neck is stiff his
face is ugly I don't like this dude I
don't like him this is this is Peter
Parker he's here he's there in in this
version do not get the remaster that
other dude is an impostor he look like
he he up to no good his neck is wrong
everything's wrong with that dude think
they I think they updated it like if you
if you haven't connected to the internet
you might be able to play it like that
but I think they just updated if you
update and play without the patches
you're what you're what Toby Maguire I
don't want I don't want that dude that's
Tom that's straight Tom Holland right
there Tom holl excuse me Tom holl he's
not even Tom Holland he's mm he's in
between yeah yeah he's somebody else uh
this one
dope dope um day one soon as it came out
I was there miles let's
go same thing with this one day one soon
as it came out I'm there uh I saw the
the the the bugs and the glitches and
the stuff online and I was like I was
just like I hope it's not that hope it's
not that I I don't care so when I was
going to work got up like around 2:00 in
the morning put my joint to download
left my my PlayStation on left MH came
back home started playing at like around
11:00 that day everybody's asking me did
you play or whatever and I had like put
out a little uh
PSA on Twitter about um just keep the
same energy you know with Starfield I
see I see all these people talking about
uh you know um oh he got got little bugs
here or there it's not a big thing it's
it's 10 uh you know hey every game has
bugs okay M when it was
Starfield it was Microsoft needs to
worry about quality control Microsoft
needs that mismanaging everything Todd
Howard needed to hold this game back um
and I played Starfield and I came across
one bug that was the bug where uh the
girl I was with I think was sah yeah she
was on the table she was floating
yeah and I was like
yo how how the hell do I get had to stop
floating and and I and I just um I had
went up to space and came back down she
was still
floating and I just kicked off my team
and then when I got it back she was she
was no more float you said it back to
Constellation continue right yeah so um
all right all right cool that was the
one bu and I and I play that game you
know I play it at my Pace yeah I'm not
playing it at you know some comp a lot
of hours of in Starfield yeah but it's
just you know I'm I'm loving every bit
of I didn't even finish the game yet M
uh so but I'm doing things in it every
every day I try to do something all
right so Spider-Man let's go get to
Spider-Man as soon I'm I'm playing I'm
super happy about it because I'm a
Marvel head and I I take these games
evil
JZ n okay
um what he eat don't make me blank um so
I I take these games as comic books
right so each comic book is a new
chapter into something else the DLC for
Spider-Man 1 was the best the story was
the best the game was I didn't I I can't
even say I I ran into any bugs in the
first one can't even say I ran any bugs
in in
Miles quality Top Notch I'm talking
about Triple A this this is when they
talk about bangers when when you have
these dudes talking about bangers not
the dudes that's trying to land on gas
planets and talk about why can't I land
on a gas
planet you messing like how stupid can
you be like how
bro anyway all right yeah right yeah we
know who you talk about right um land on
a gas planet dummy um stop shooting on a
Sunday continue pow pow pow pow he's
down so I play uh Spider-Man 2 and I'm
so happy first it's like this first
mission after we do this the big thing
with miles but I was noticing little
things prompts yeah right I go to hit
the prompt it ain't hitting it ain't
doing nothing I'm like y I'll press the
button though I'm like okay uh do this
bring up your camera to take pictures uh
I have to manually go into my menu to
pull up the camera because my swipe
wasn't working yeah so I'm like okay
that's that's a little bit of an
inconvenience right all right okay
cool um
then it was this this point where I was
trying to fight somebody he was stuck in
the floor oh and I can hear him I mean
he's shooting at me he's shooting at me
but I can't shoot at him and I can throw
boxes but it ain't going to get him and
he down there talking mad crap yeah
Spider-Man I'll kill you like if you
don't get out that
dirt so I had to re go back reload the
checkpoint come back in and my son was
with me my son said Daddy get him first
because he like to hide in the dir yo
your your son trying to help you avoid
glitch yo he's like yeah cuz he was
sitting there cuz he you know he heard
about the glitches all day um so I got
the guy and that that that saved it
right yeah it's you trying to act like
he's the one the start of the glitch
he's the king of glitches he's the guy
that's the
culprit so I I have encountered four
glitches and four glitches that were and
I'm not talking about clipping I'm not
talking about uh some other stuff that
goes on like running through car or
running through people I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about stuff that
make me say damn I was on a good rooll
now I got to reset or I got to die to
start this over game progression I agree
and and I'm
like how come none of these reviewers
talking about
this I don't want none of y'all talking
that ACG
talk he the only one that got the pass
he put it out first
he who who who who smelt it dealt it
he's he's the one who put it out first
he get the pass you other dudes trying
to jump on the bottom of that tweet talk
about yeah um yeah you know I heard
about that too and I I didn't no no no
okay you not getting the pass bro like
your fandom is at an alltime
high you trying to save these dudes from
burning you trying to run in the burn up
building and trying to save them I got
to save my baby I want to know how like
a game gets worse after the day one pass
like I know how that's when your
company's in turmoil when they on fire
oh my Lord when they on fire we G I've
been yelling this forever when are we
going to look over at them and say
they're not the same guys I will give
you that this is very surprising as the
cops go by I agree with you um that is
very surprising that they're known for
polish and to your point the pre yeah I
know you're holding up the old
Spider-Man these two games ain't got
these issues I agree I agree I I I am
surprised now In fairness I know yall
hate when I do corporate C In
fairness it seemed that that the the
reviewers may have played the pre-day
one patch I don't care about that I
don't care about you saw I don't believe
you right because especially when
somebody says if it get anything less
than a
nine well holy hell oh man well holy
here you my friend are complicit are you
implying media I'm implying D already
had their score written down before they
even took the
test they didn't play the game had they
score already I'm before they even
booted it up I heard I heard people say
it's so amazing I'm at the loading
screen I mean I mean I'm at I'm at the
start screen and there's no
loading oh my God it the first to do
this what's up with you man like this is
what you this is what we capping for
this is what we hear this is what this
is what it's about now all
right y'all trying to say these dudes
y'all trying to give them mouth to mouth
y'all this is King Kong versus Godzilla
okay you remember when Godzilla took
King Kong under the
ocean and he was drowning
them and and and the humans had to save
him are you applyed it the media is
trying to save Sony from drowning and to
to force the battle yo right now
Godzilla's Xbox taking him on
the here come y'all little
reviewers y'all try to save them we got
to save
Kong he when he landed on that boat
he did you see what he was trying to do
to
me yo listen you stupid you are stupid
Y no longer gorilla Y no longer the 800B
gorilla y'all are looked at with the
Quine now the qu oh man all right so
this is not a 10 out of 10 this ain't a
banger this ain't a banger when you
confuse Cuba with Puerto
Rico it was funny man I disagree but I
can't say nothing cuz he right he
cooking he cooking how many how many how
many Puerto Ricans was on set that
looked over and S the flag and they say
he
hey yo how many yo y I'm sitting here
I'm like okay all right you already got
Peter with the weird neck and face and
you got Mary Jane looking like she's on
Aurora we we ain't even gonna get here
why do she look like she 20 years older
than this kid I'm just like are you
trying to imply cougar syndrome what are
you saying who's he dating a
May yeah I'm like all right all
right this can we hear about the game
please no no no no n n n clear get this
off you know why we ain't gonna just
hear about the game first because we had
so many reviewers mislead people I had
to listen to so much crap when Starfield
came out and when other games came out
that have glitches and have bugs and
this and that and they were getting hit
for it this game ain't get hit for it if
you really hit this game for the bugs
that was said nobody can give it higher
than the seven if you hit it with the
bug he out of pocket if you hit it with
theck if you count I count the bugs that
I encountered that's four
like no but you know what and and this
is where my hypocrisy comes in all right
listen let's get to your let's get to
your hypocrisy now let's get to my
hypocrisy me me as a comic book head yes
I'm there for the story MH story when I
saw a certain villains yes yes I almost
did a backflip they did that I'm like
they did they did right I got Craven
statue inside my room
facts I never like how they depicted
Craven throughout Spidey in as amazing
friends throughout Spider-Man books I I
recommended to one of our uh um friends
in the realm a comic book because he
asked me what's a good Spider-Man comic
book this is was way before this came
out and I said Craven's last hunt I
thought that was the greatest depiction
of craving the hunter in comic books he
was not a buffoon he was not this dude
in spandex that go around grabbing
tigers by the neck he he he did
something to Spider-Man that traumatized
him for a long time for probably since
that point he shout out to as king he
said yeah it was him King told me about
it yeah so yeah he he made Peter Parker
claustrophobic
um so this this game puts
craving in that craving the
hunter right he's he's really the hunter
he's not craving he's craving the he's
craving the hunter yeah because you know
when Mary Jane said it she said who
craving the
hunter cuz he was like y y'all heard a
dude named Craven she's like who craving
Hunter like when when y'all play it
y'all see sound like the white boy
Hatchet but I'm going move on continue
the way you did the way you did that
sounded like Mark for death
we move
on
continue yo so I'mma say this Fidelity
on the game is second to n
woo Fidelity on the
game the fluidity of the characters
someone said craving and
friends the the fluidity of the
characters in the world the buddy cop
field of miles and Spider-Man yeah when
they together that is fantastic um the
wings they they finally addressed uh
Steve dick Cole's Spider-Man wings that
he always put under his Spider-Man so
they made it into something that
actually worked right they they paid
homas to Steve dicko question how the
hell there's no Iron Man but he has iron
spider uh oh uh yeah they explain that
with his ability let's let's not let's
not let's not go there let's not say
gkey made this let's not do this let's
not do this he used his a 3D printer to
make in in a suit that's made out of
fabric but we it's a video we G suspend
disbelief let's dis yeah suspend
disbelief let's do that this I'm I'm
down for the story yes now is this game
perfect hell no Hell by no means my no
stretch of imagination will it be my
game of the year in my heart this is
what you
yes okay all that it will be you know
why it will be
because superhero games that are good
listen up chz pay
attention come very I'm being bad I'm
instigating I apologize they they they
come very few and far between right we
got a long burial ground of bad
superhero games yes oh God right so when
Insomniac is on and I don't care if it's
the same formula that they've been doing
every game is the same but in every
comic book is the same right y'all
Winters go see the Miles Morales movie
Into The Spidey verse and they told you
that there's certain things that has to
happen right right so every comic book
is pretty much follows the same formula
the hero will win in the end they will
face some form of adversity they will go
through trials and tribulations and you
will have fun I want to do every little
bit of things in the game I'm not addict
I want to get every book bag I want to
get every uh stat case the problems is
God bless soul but some sometimes when
you go up to these cases and stuff like
that there's no prompt The Prompt
doesn't come up yeah now when I was
doing some missions you have to uh do
plants and stuff like that on the
rooftops you don't see certain plants in
certain areas right so then you sitting
there longer than you have to because
the game needed more time
m i I believe Sony proper needed this on
their
financials right and uh Sony PlayStation
PlayStation Branch couldn't afford
another L they needed to have these
numbers so Sony proper looks
better this is a board move this is what
I've been talking about for a long
period of time Insomniac know these
reviewers new
don't sit there don't be
disingenuous you're a Sony stand and you
gave it that boost because you if if you
come out and say yo is mad glitch is
this the third let's see if you can get
a review copy next time oh are you wait
are you implying Sony has that much
influence that if you negatively say
anything against a Sony game are you
implying that they will not get codes
for their
Outlet going to cherry pick are you
saying they going to cherry pick King
King I have to push back on this one man
push it push back as much as you want
cuz I get a review code and you know I'm
the biggest Sony hater let's go so yeah
this is me we're talking about Sony
sends me codes man oh they send you Cod
but you Jaz though but you Jaz though
they said but you Jaz though now je God
check this out check this out jez what
did you give
Spider-Man I I didn't get they send PC
codes right so like if it's if it's like
a get you don't get PlayStation 5 Co no
we we don't we don't cover PlayStation
on Windows Central okay it runs it runs
on it runs on some weird operating
system called Linux no one use
it okay see see my question to you would
have been something totally different
because you can't answer the question
and I'm talking about to the reviewers
that did get it that if they say
something bad about Sony they won't get
that review code because you get a PC
code so you get you get a code for a
game that was out three years ago so ad
let me let me be clear is is he implying
that there there's some cherry picking
going on like is that's what that's what
I'm hearing adct well this the thing is
Xbox does the same thing man we saw this
with I'm playing Devil's Advocate right
now but same thing with Starfield
Starfield uh they didn't give review
cards to outlets that they knew would be
less than favorable right and and and
and to your point I know there was a big
you know controversy can you say
controver I like cont controversy how do
you say I love what J TR say there we go
there we go so so so you you're you're
saying that Starfield did that now
fair that was a big there's always
there's always management there's always
there's always micromanagement PR
micromanagement on who gets codes when
where and why you know they'll they'll
look at my Twitter right and if I if
I've been on Twitter saying this game
looks amazing or whatever they're more
likely to give me a code probably I
would imagine that's just that's just PR
people doing their job okay so in you
think that's more watch this question
watch this question going to break his
back like B no no but I'm just saying so
do you feel it do you feel this is
something that all do or do you feel cuz
some people adct could back me up on it
you know told us that you know Bethesda
is cherry picking that only that no one
else is doing this so based on I don't
want to get you in trouble just but
based on what you see like is this
consistent throughout the industry based
on your
experience well I
mean it's weird man because some some
Outlets that I wouldn't have expected to
get a code did get a code and some
Outlets that did get a code I wouldn't
have expected to get a code and and vice
versa right um so you can never you can
never sort of predict or never know what
kind of conversations are happening
Beyond closed doors with regards to code
distribution I think like if if we lived
in a completely fair and unbiased World
everyone who you know whose Outlet CS
Games should get a code all at the same
time but at the end of the day you got
to remember reviews reviews are not but
for a publisher reviews are not about
you know art criticism ISM and and
scientific analysis it's about marketing
you know so they're kind of like who got
the biggest yeah so then what you're
saying to myself is that if they're not
favorable you're not going to get
it he's talking yeah I mean okay but it
works both ways you know okay so no no
no no I pretty much see I pretty much
see Microsoft throw their game out there
to get destroyed by
everybody I pretty much pretty much see
them like here they give it to people
that I don't even like they get the game
like why the hell you got the game you
don't even like
Microsoft right but I hear dudes oh I
got that so it's like they got the
golden ticket to Willie Wonka oh my God
and they don't want to lose that golden
ticket they're not gonna say nothing bad
and I see you dudes and I'm just like
you know what I'm tired of you go to
Lords gaming.net
um because they're gonna give you a fair
and unbiased uh review of a game here's
the thing I don't like certain people JZ
I'm not gonna lie I I don't like dudes
that lie just to save their Cod for the
next game that's coming
out here's the thing I think we need to
Define what cherry picking is because
people get that like weird like to me
cherry picking is going doing research
and sending codes to people you think is
going to give you a good review that's
cherry pick add it you you did you apply
for a code for Spider-Man yes didn't
even get an email back
oh didn't even get oh why don't they
mess with you I don't know cuz you might
keep it real oh that's a loose cannon
that's a loose cannon I can't trust this
dude are you flying the adct go he can't
be controlled and especially he's with
that dude right
there definitely can't trust him we
can't trust you we can't trust you for
sure don't send him anything you stupid
we don't even they they left you on
red was like
adct iron Lord's
podcast okay let's take the Starfield
situation let let go you know for those
of you that watched I actually
interviewed Travis yeah shout to TA
Travis ta Travis and one of the
conversations was about cherry picking
for Starfield to me cherry picking isn't
sitting
it to you know because they they go to a
broader Spectre people that have
hundreds of thousands of
Subs they don't the destiny Community
entirely
bontis um Ash Ash cross Ester cross
these people don't talk about other
games besides Destiny good point so if
you were cherry picking wild yeah you
would give it to people who you
definitely know going to give you a good
and guess what
the majority of these Cherry pickings
said the game AST cross literally say
the worst game he's played this year
look at that so how is that cherry
picking look at that to to me that
cherry picking is looking at someone
like like PlayStation looking at at King
it's like I ain't giving my dude a copy
oh they they looked at us and said they
weren't giving it to
us what's funny is like people sitting
there they talking about Xbox cherry
picking and literally we've had we've
had Publishers uh we've had websites
come out that says that after they gave
the previous PlayStation a bad uh review
they stopped giving them codes with a
content creator said that I I saw a tell
the Shan the devil today at it chat
could tell me who it was I don't know
who it was but I saw it on Tik Tok and
it was a content creator and he said I
used to be really cool with PlayStation
but they they invited me to this PR
event and after I went went to it they
said there would be uh you know lots of
stuff I can uh cover there would be lots
of access he said it was pretty much
just a just an after party there was
nothing there I wasted a whole afternoon
and I was I was upset about it so I I
emailed the P representation he said I
wasn't rude I just said I don't
appreciate you not being transparent
what actually is going down at this
event and I took the time and I feel
like you wasted your time and my time he
said that's the last time he ever talked
to that place oh wow that's what he said
he said oh you don't want to you don't
want to experience
greatness oh we got enough people that
will be appreciative to be getting the
golden Willy Walker ticket do do you
guys remember Last of Us Part Two had
like two three embargos yes like oh you
can talk about time then you could take
xn this time like like look like you
could say but that's the Cherry Picked
and I'm not going to sit there and argue
with you but to
me Bethesda didn't reward bad behavior
with from what I can speak personally to
the Bethesda
situation multiple sources have told me
the people who were
excluded had prior comments that were
outside of gaming it's one thing to say
like you know Starfield or Fallout 76
let's let's say Fallout 76 was like a
horrible game it's terrible it's
functionally bad it's another thing to
say these developers should be shot what
the hell would they think
you know I mean when you go into that
bag and for what I understand but the
proper in the past really took light
took didn't take light to those type of
attacks on a personal level and a team
and from my understanding those people
were kind of you are on timeout when it
comes to getting you should be on time
out say stuff like that I agree but
I was G to say even with JZ here I'm
going say this some of the most entitled
people I say in the industry is the
media well look I I feel like like
sometimes some of these media per
personalities don't get a code for their
media site they are some of the most
inti and these are the same people a
week later be telling me I should I
should stay quiet about me being upset
over a code not getting uh access to but
the moment they don't get it they on
Twitter crying upet about it well I mean
to close off my my my part put your part
I want to ask I'm I'm just going to say
this all right so I rank uh SP Man
3 uh last in in in out of the three
right and and that's out of quality but
I'm going to
say as far as Innovation
goes I think to come up to the party
last out of the other two and to be able
to put mil story Peter's story and all
the other characters into the world and
we them together and as as far as the
interface goes you have Spiderman and
you have miles and Spiderman and you
have them together uh their move sets
and stuff like that the way they wo the
world together and the story together I
think it's head and shoulders above the
other two other two okay but because of
the Polish I got to rank it last because
they didn't have the bugs that this had
one had no I feel I feel you I I just
want to and it gets it gets a eight for
me okay I want to say real quick I
wasn't I I was inferring to jez being
here because he's the media I wasn't
saying jez is the
one I was just saying that there's
there's media in this industry that will
sit here and go on Twitter on their High
full Towers because it's easy to tell
people at the bottom you shouldn't feel
entitled but the moment they don't get
something they the first one on Twitter
trying to bully people to get in a code
right no and that's what I wanted to to
finish my point what you were saying is
such the media is really it's
gatekeeping man gatekeeping like I say
it all the time like even now like I'm
so I'm so called Big you know 100,000 on
Twitter or whatever but like the the
media is still the the establish G
establishment game media is super gayy
and and all that kind of stuff I've seen
it like from when I was you know when I
had 50 followers 100 followers and like
you know when I had a Blog that was up
and coming you know like iron lordge you
know Iron L is still growing stuff
appreciate you and uh the it's it's hard
man it's hard to get noes but you just
keep pushing and keep telling the truth
eventually people just you know notice
and I suppose like there is it's a
King's Point about engineering the
review outcomes and stuff like that
that's why like you can only really take
meta critic of face value right you you
got to find the reviewers that you reson
resonate with and the you drive with and
the you know the reviewers that oh this
reviewers put out these reviews and I
agree with them you know and then follow
them for who they are absolutely met
critics The Meta critics score is is it
it's you it's a tool for Publishers at
the end of the day it shouldn't
necessarily be a tool for you
individually I think but like Xbox uses
Metacritic score as a as a predictor for
how well a game's going to do in sales
how well a game's going to do in um uh
Game Pass engagement and stuff like that
I know they do I know they I know they
take met Creek as that indicator because
from thatp perspective scientifically
metac does seem to be a good predictor
of a game success you know but that
doesn't necessarily mean you as an
individual and you guys watching this
that the MET score is necessarily going
to be reflective of whether you're going
to love a game or not you know like
Zelda Zelda's probably going to be Zelda
it's the objectively speaking zel the
game of the year is a a tossup between
Zelda and bu's going through this [__] I
know no
oh what then what it ain't be that you
you gonna be shocked but it ain't gonna
be that all right all right all right
well personally I think it's a tossup
between just looking at who the panel is
game journalists run the the game the
game awards panel and I I think it's a
tossup between Boulders gay and Zelda
you know personally well irw is doing
their own shows yeah we're doing our own
show too man but but I like but my point
was I don't give a [__] about
Zelda
language for the Lord's day for the for
for the Little Lords for the Little
Lords come on now my grandmother's
listening to this in
heaven Grandma's listening J she's dead
she's listening to it in
heaven he had to clarify what listening
to heaven with that was hilarious finish
J I'm sorry I'll jump in you don't care
about Zelda
Nea look I'll jump in I was just going
to add you know we were talking about
the Cherry we were talking about um you
know but that's a thing that I I was
going to speak to specifically in
reference to you know that from what I
heard and sources you know what was
going on and again when when the reviews
go beyond the game and into a personal
attack on the studio or individuals is
where I hear you know but that's the
prior to acquisition they put their foot
in the sand now what I did hear is that
now acquired by Microsoft and I can
confirm for multiple sources that um
Microsoft has made a road to try to
Redemption Road there you go good thank
you for saving me because I didn't know
what word to use yeah so a road for
Redemption for certain individuals who
fell in that category because like jez
is saying you know we have to be honest
right first of all I want to get this
out and I totally agree with jez with
the entitlement and and on both sides or
whether it be a content creator or an
outlet at the end of the day you are not
old a code I don't care who you are
Outlet whoever it's up to the publisher
that's their decision if they would to
give it to someone because they have a
million subscribers or their Outlet gets
whatever SEO that's on them but what I
will say you know in reference to this
you know the whole situation Microsoft
did make inroads there I think to to
jez's point most companies are going to
look at those things if you talk about
stuff favorably and what your engagement
is that that I think is kind of industry
standard so to speak kind of thing and
to King's Point you know what I'm saying
we have heard heard Outlets say that hey
if they spoke negatively about Sony on
certain things all of a sudden
correspondence stop we have heard that
we're not going to act like that has not
existed so I'm not going to sit there
and say my brother is lying because I
I've heard stories like that no but yeah
but I I just the bigger just I just want
to say one thing yes the bigger problem
is when reviewers come out before the
game is even in hand and says if this
game get less than a nine well that's
that's different that's that's that's
that's that's a different thing that's
what I'm talking about no I I get what
you the only thing I had an issue with
and me and adct really bonded with this
is that with the Starfield and bethza
situation you know it was made to seem
like only they do that and this doesn't
happen in the industry and we have
tangible evidence that others do that
Sony does it everyone and the thing that
I I felt and I really agree with addict
is that they try to make it cuz I think
this is the first time major games media
was some of them were deny a Cod and we
saw some of the push back the anger and
the entire I thought that was an
inflection point with the Starfield situ
I would be honest you know what's funny
Co yeah Nintendo even gives us codes
facts that's a fact so it it that's all
I'm saying and I just want it to be fair
because what's fair it's fair Sony does
it others do it and and to sit there and
isolate but doesn't to make it seem
Starfield success was not warranted and
that that people are ly and now why to
King's Point why he's so animate is
because he's seeing all the bugs that
Spider-Man has and he's like yo where's
the same energy he's not saying the game
is bad he's just saying where's the same
energy that certain people gave towards
Starfield and again all I can say is in
in their defense maybe or maybe I don't
know I'm not these people they got a day
zero patch and they didn't have that and
it was fine and and that's all I can say
I don't know but I do understand the
sentiment is what I'm I've got a really
weird perspective on this man because go
I I have never really experienced the
bug in Starfield man I I'm G be honest
my experience was pretty much I never
had a game game progression bug where I
won the whole the only person I know
that had that and I got a shout my
brother was ebontis but it was on PC but
when I spoke to everybody that on a
console J you know we were playing it
Maddie were playing it r you know we're
playing and we're all trying to like
[__] this is the most
Pol no I I AG
like the the only bug that I had in the
review period was this issue with NPCs
not having any hair but they the ball
bug the ball I had the the B bug the B
bug yeah I had the B bug I had the B bug
I had the eyeball bug a couple times
where the only thing there was eyeballs
yeah I had but to be to be like that and
when Spider-Man Clips in the floor or
something that that's minor stuff but
when I can't move the game forward yeah
like then then it's like okay that this
is something different and I that is
definitely in Spider-Man 2 there's no I
I had it from the first two three hours
in the game I'm like damn what's going
on you can argue whether here's the
thing like we can make a discussion on
the the process needs to change that's a
that's a valid criticism I'm 100% for
having a concuss uh cons uh a discussion
that may be the process to how review
codes and review process and Generals
handle the industry but what we not
going to do is act like one company only
does it and the rest the industry
doesn't preach brother I'm with you I'm
with you on it so look we went long this
went longer than I thought let's go
what's the next topic we have we got to
get off field it's you okay okay so cuz
we you know the order is messed up okay
yeah yeah I know it's always a little
little different my fault so um yeah
we're going to get you I mean Super Chat
solve if we can and then get into the
star field you muted
sorry there you go uh let me see let run
back let's play with each other's
joysticks $5 Super Chat two heads are
better than one excuse
me oh yeah's he's a big fan of the
realm and
solve two heads are better than one I
only need one head and that's s whoa
addict that never
happened wow which K was it there was
some cheating going on there was
cheating going on yeah definitely
cheating that shirt that heard coming
off let's play your joystick just just
mad cuz I didn't leave my door
open all righty then moving on then we
have sagging nut sack 10 pound super
chat it's been a while fellas finally
catching you guys live I just want to
show some love I have a 4-Hour drive
back home so I'll be listening have a
good one take care you as well get home
safe salute
salute then we have H La Shimmer Zaki
with the 500 sorry I don't don't know
what that is but I will look it up um I
really don't think they missed all of
these issues when they were reviewing
the
game but a lot of people saying right it
was the day one back 500 yen of course
it's 500 y thank you um everybody said
that day one patch broke a lot of stuff
so yeah that's what the only only one
person said it and then everybody like
yeah yeah yeah that that happened to me
too acg's reputation you you only one
dude gets the chance to use that hall
pass the rest of you dudes get blocked
at the
gate it's it's it you know I don't
obviously I don't know the mental
capacity on some of it's like they saw
ACG say and how big ACG was like oh if
we don't say nothing we're going to look
like you know we like listen L you
careful that man is is a kind of sore
viewing game his reputations I was
skeptical because I saw I saw people say
it in in the industry but when I saw ACG
said I was okay you know ACG would be
honest oh offici was like then there
probably wasn't too many bugs that day
one patch probably did break stuff but
then we got to have the conversation you
know um normally it's the other way
around but it's like if a game is broken
now was broken is a harsh term but if a
game has a lot of bugs now then like are
we have what kind of conversation do we
have now like what did they add to it
spy we I don't know oh you're ridiculous
movie go all we never we go get St then
we have uh Wonder hos with the $10 Super
Chat uh quote unquote you have to follow
the script for No
Bugs don't don't explore in this open
world just follow the the golden P then
we got red and black dog met for three
months Lord bronze G with the dog
listening to you guys talk I realize I'm
not willing to pay $70 for anybody's
first party games anymore when I get it
all in game pass on the Xbox oh oh
you've been trained not to buy games
that's what happened oh that that appar
rule that rule ain't real apparently
that rule ain't real ridiculous then we
have nend taku $5 Super Chat Nintendo
would never misrepresent a country's
flag like that imagine if they Mok
pizza's Mushroom Kingdom flag for
daisies for Daisy szal land flag chaos
obviously we're gonna talk about you
know Mario here in a minute but you Shad
Nintendo because for the most part they
games might not run the greatest because
of the switch Hardware but for the most
most part almost all of their first
party runs really good no doubt 12200 in
the chat real hit that like up don't
play that they got quality control over
there then we have Lord Metro $2 for
chat miles don't like Don anymore
apparently he's all about that Havana
Club that CL he we he wears a tank top
and a fedora in the he's in the club
Babaloo he's in babal
there he's also Ricky Ricardo he's a
Ricky Ricardo right there
Lucy to you yes got some explaining to
you CH we hear you I got I got
disconnected I I saw him he he he jumped
out and jumped yeah you back I I didn't
swear for you guys I appreciate you we
appreciate you R out a whiskey this is
this is a travesty
whiskey well that means we got to start
drinking the Vodka let's go my God this
is the
show didn't he say it's 8 a. wait didn't
he say it's 8:00 a.m. over there or is
it 800 p.m it's it's uh it's halfast N9
we're actually going to be drinking some
bre Brenan from we do not SP to
this back to you
s is that IOP
approved that was great I love
that here have Joe Repco AKA play best
Lord
Bron well well well Spider-Man 2 seems
to be very buggy right now does anyone
remember an uproar over very minor
glitches in another big game
recently yeah we talk about it we
addressed it we crazy Horizon had
glitches returnal has glitches tell the
truth Shane the devil these a the same
man they different boy oh there we have
there we have you give King even a
little you give King in itchy oh my Lord
he go that's why Jim is out Jim did his
job here we go it's my
guy Jimmy
boy act like he your old mob him out
from the inside Jimmy po Jimmy po don't
be using no old mob references boy Jimmy
fingers whoa whoa
whoa
continue we pix b g $2 Super Chat they
lack Integrity they need escape goat
blame the
patch yep wow no no not not ACG though
ACG is cool he the first one that said
it he dealt it the rest of Y guys not
the rest of your guys smelt it he
does continue There we got nice Robbie
$5 stupid chat nice Robbie get Caso I'm
bothered by I'm bothered by the Cuban
flag at miles's house worst game bug for
me that's the bug that's the
bug we have was Easter
egg
I'm why game buug
show shout out to Doc dog how they mess
up the Puerto Rican flag boy L
disrespectful we are not all the same
they were like they the
same at least it wasn't a swasa you
know now you guys defitely demonetized
now we're definitely demonetized now
going on it
on I kind of feel bad for Sol because
like his people been getting attacked
left and right first Bungie now oh yeah
with the leg ain't this ain't this
Hispanic month or something like that
yeah the and they got it wrong in
Hispanic
month King with that laugh continue yeah
inclusion
you're ridiculous
continue then we have let me see Ultra
msv $5 Super Chat just wanted to stop by
and say hello to the realm I don't keep
up much with gaming but y'all are always
entertaining to watch blessings
blessings what's love 1200 in here hit
that like button y'all we have a fun we
got we got drunk Jazz we got all type of
stuff going
on Michael boy 5 pound Super Chat
Spider-Man 2 or Ragnarok which is more
like DLC oh my
God at least at least God of War
Ragnarok didn't have bugs I actually
would say God of War is more like a DLC
than Spider-Man I I do feel like
Spider-Man 3 does not feel DLC is like
at all they've rebuilt
[Music]
systems fair enough but we got I still
think it could be done on a PlayStation
4 yeah but it wasn't so I he said but it
wasn't but we got your KN we got your kn
into Next fisal Period cuz if those
numbers don't come up and Mario did the
Oozy Bop on your boy PlayStation 4 will
have a game look man th this is we we do
things the old ways okay you already you
already gave me your needs you can't
take them
back I just want to laugh at
you they G to laugh at you continue then
we have SP difference $2 Super Chat Lord
Cog don't say no about no Steven S
oh Mark for death baby Mark for
death man face is SC school face we
don't know no school face get him your
damn all I want is your damn Soul all I
want is your
soul split difference get to Super Chat
that name forbidden to Yard Man F
Sten all right cool long as they Bunty
with them Pon
them conso Warr in Jama long as they we
good then we have Spectre Spectre bull
$5 Super Chat we have big PlayStation
fans at Mojo plays I am one of them we
don't ever get codes from Sony we tried
working them with them one time didn't
end well wow okay
something first off shout out to Mojo
plays Mojo plays actually watch your
guys' vide they want y'all to show filty
and you didn't show
FY you got send in your first
Bor then we have nerds and other Legends
$5 Super Chat I think when something is
free quote unquote such as a review code
it tastes sweeter and stimulates an
opinion that what that was already hyped
uh I don't I mean I think you think that
but at the same time you start getting
cold you I mean there's a there's this
little thing in the back of your mind
that says Integrity that maybe you know
kind of it should say right I this is
your job yeah I don't know if you
getting a
check it's it's weird that someone in
this position would feel that way
because it's like you kind of just
destroying your platform by doing that I
mean like Jen said then people are going
to go to the people that they trust
anyway yeah so that's right don't trust
him
continue got to [__] it then we have the
homie lock Mt with the 10 10 yearo super
chat G 3 is not only game of the year
but game of the generation it comes to
Xbox at some point so you guys can also
experience a real RPG it it is coming it
is coming to Xbox and we got one of your
developers be quiet I don't know if
smooth wants me to say this but I'm gon
say it anyway yes last night I was after
we recorded Planet
Xbox was like is it sad that I just want
like if B gate wins game of the year the
only thing I asked for is that game is
on Xbox before that happens he's like CU
because I don't want people run to
Twitter and say a PlayStation game how G
well lar larion has been clear that they
saying it's not an exclusive what they
say between octob September and November
never an exclusive never it's coming
it's coming out to Xbox do we have those
numbers though I really want that's they
didn't sell anything they didn't sell
anything is not true that not
PlayStation it hit wood that is not true
that is not true wait till these numbers
come up for this MPD and we going to see
what y'all really did they were not on
the list but we've clarified that they
have they are not part of that cirana
yeah they don't want to be part of
it you don't don't just because you
didn't participate doesn't mean that you
don't get
judged you're ridiculous s you got to go
he's out of control then we have sagging
nut
sack five Super Chat honestly with all
these bugs I'm seeing from Spider-Man if
it was Starfield oh boy the game would
have been destroyed on
Metacritic okay I mean
it was so you know I that's my biggest
thing is like you know if if the if the
if everyone generally had a pretty
bug-free you know experience before the
game happened then I guess that's one
thing but it's just like like to me it's
like man what are they doing like what
what is PlayStation doing that an update
made it worse than before like I mean
but I mean to be fair like Starfield is
an 83 of Metacritic like I don't know
that constitutes destruction yeah it's
not a bad score that's not a bad at
Twitter oh Lord what happened they did
you in Alex in a picture on Twitter
right
God I I wanted to say congratulations
that you made it to all nois Alex video
actually I I made that video just for
that video that was your they got oh man
yo young young dread you got to chill I
see what you do they got me out of
pocket right now they got they taking L
beefy too far right now like okay okay
what I want you guys to do is go over
here to this Twitter post and I want you
to like that thing that Masterpiece that
Lord beefy and Lord Shredder oh man this
is out of pocket right now
continue okay let me see that's it we
caught up let's move on before it gets
crazy all right this is a king's topic
and um yeah he wants be this I'll set
him up oh set it up please yes Starfield
y'all Starfield um huge huge uh debut
huge numbers coming back wins MPD I got
I gotta stop saying MPD sirana right
that's the the new the worst I hate s
mama my name him MPD I'mma call him
MPD it's still MPD to me it's it's like
Twitter and X to me it's still Twitter
exactly so shout out Twitter X baby
shout out to Matt piscatella from the
real we've had him in Imagine hit
someone up and like yo you got that X
subscription yo
whoa but uh yeah Starfield was the best
selling game of September instantly
becoming the seventh best selling game
of 2023 year to date starf seventh yeah
from the whole year Starfield for that
crazy yeah that is crazy Starfield Zelda
came out right yes Zelda came out a lot
of games came out this the ton this you
we're saying that this is the best year
in gaming and this made it to the
seventh and it just came out came out
yes than sofield ranked as the
bestselling title of the month across
Xbox and PC PC being it leag sales
platform um I want to get how much it
sold on
Playstation it did not sell on
Playstation it won't ever sell over
there this is this is this is why we'll
never this is why if you wonder why we
don't get codes
codes this could be a factor some of us
are trying to be journalists here
whereas some of us are trying to be
provoc so y'all are saying they're
picking and choosing I for one not being
a journalist I I've accepted our role in
the industry at this point yes accepted
I am a villain you created the role I've
accepted it like it fell in your lap
like you didn't do nothing
for you deserve it I resent
that so please let Cog finish again
again just want to go over September is
again top top 20 games for the September
this is based on dollar sales excludes
add all content new W Starfield number
one from Microsoft number two Mortal
Kombat 1 which was also new EA Sports FC
formerly known as FIFA
number number three number four Madden
and is still in football season y'all
NFL 24 payday three number five broken
for a month broken for a month payday
three was up there it's networking was
was I talked to someone behind the
scenes they said that the reason it
worked so well for the game pass
literally like destroyed their Network
like they didn't expect the amount they
they expect us to show up cuz we play
games oh no they showed up they showed
up so much that every they would
stabilize the
network crash again cuz we play games
let's go f83 was number five number six
the new to the list and The Perennial
favorite usually all the time NBA K 2K
24 oh you said Starfield 2K Starfield B
2K now in defense in 2K digital sales
they didn't have their v-bucks up they
digital the only thing is that's all
physical for 2K um no digital sales was
included for 2K too bad you get judged
okay number seven which we all reviewed
and played the crew motest makes his
debut because I actually felt like that
was a drastic improvement from previous
uh I didn't think the crew was going to
be big old starfi though yeah let's go
then number eight rounding out the uh we
got armor core 6 it was number eight
this month number two that game just
recently came out like last month yeah
yeah it was number two last month look
it's still strong Hogwarts Legacy at
number nine number one overall yeah we
going to get I'm going to get to that
list I'm going get to that list yep
you're right and it was number five last
month and riding out the top 10 was Call
of Duty Modern Warfare 2 the 2022
version and uh wait so it was no
PlayStation games and no Nintendo games
in there well
um yeah nintend they not top 10 if we're
talking top 10 no I'm talking top 10 bro
yeah top 10 no it's it's Starfield
number one Mortal Kombat EC yeah and
then I want to round out the the well
where you going to be next month when
Spider-Man's at the top listen listen
listen listen let's let's cross that
bridge when we get to it but I I know I
know Spider-Man won't be there he won't
be number one but I know who still be in
the top
10 wants to do a bend the knee on this
but you don't want your knees going stop
it you do safe stuff you do safe stuff
oh my God you do safe stuff this is
dangerous for you stay away yeah it is a
little dangerous I feel I am shaking a
little my boots final stat and then I'll
give it over to King again year to date
ending in 2023 and again top 10
bestselling premium games dollar sales
excluding add-on content for the year
now for the entire year from now to
September um Hogwarts Legacy like s said
number one Hogwarts Legacy wow Legend
canel game the cancel oh yeah the canel
legy number two Legend is Elder taser
Kingdom but I got to give the Nintendo
base this does not include digital sales
Dam so there's a strong chance that zeld
tears of the Kingdom could be number one
I I have to give Zelda they flowers on
that number three Madden already NFL 24
number you know how Madden D yeah Madden
number four for JZ Cordon Diablo 4 oh
can I get a Diablo 4 pronunciation from
everyone everyone hides on blizzard
right but everyone secretly plays
blizzard games fact where are all my
blizzard F hey no we asked for a Diablo
we I need a Dia ask for that we need
Diablo yes there we go no you got to say
you have to say beta with it you have to
say beta with it always
beta dude like for for the last like
37 years I've been calling Diablo that's
right that it sound it sounds refined
when you say that Diablo for
beta gorgeous it's gorgeous I just see
that that mean where
said finish please okay he's ready to
cook um Call of Duty something's going
on yeah something's going on Call of
Duty another Activision Blizzard game at
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2 on the
2022 version number uh number five
rounding out number six Star Wars Jedi
Survivor at number six and and new to
the list in one month for the whole year
to date is Starfield debuting at number
seven in one month number eight notice
how they have the they have the
publisher Microsoft and not not yeah not
yeah cuz we own they own now
baby no no we paid money for you sit
up pay like she wa and then number eight
Mortal Kombat one for the years so
Mortal Kombat still did well but
consider debuted as well number nine
Resident Evil 4 from Capcom and rounding
out which is very interesting s m i be
the show 23 wait so there's no
PlayStation games how many times we have
to say no yo wait wait this is the
second list buddy there is there is
technically a PlayStation game there
let's not I me which one which one
though he I'm trying to G the game would
not yes MLB the show is multiplatform
it's on switch it's on switch G
is developed by PlayStation y on the
list it says publish your multiple video
game manufacturing right I'm just what
tell us it's not Sony that's not Sony
that's us it goes in G that's our first
listen that's a first party studio for
it is not you know what king yes I I
approve that message that was messy day
and date for
us so K this is your topic I know you've
been chopping at the bit what is your
thought Starfield has done
it what is going on starfi has done it I
told y'all I told yall y talking about
glitching and moving and Starfield they
don't buy no games Starfield won't sell
Starfield won't be this so you tried to
you Tred to sabotage
us like Prince
Planet he look like a bootle
man that rocket still lifted off that
rock is still with in his face ah we
hold up hold up the dude that does the
fan art I want King on a rocket with
that don't put him on like a rocket like
a witch room we not doing that that's
disrespectful say this right I say this
y'all say that uh want captions with his
hands up
say I want I want to see him taking that
off that's what yeah that's going to be
interesed so so so you dudes you dud
said game pass with caliz games oh Game
Pass uh will incite people not to buy
games Game Pass Game Pass is the problem
Microsoft is devaluing their first party
games by putting it over there cuz
nobody's going to buy
them seventh and sales and it just came
out number one in
MPD Boy watch your
mouth watch your mouth now a lot of you
dudes like to say oh they won't even
nominate Starfield for Game of the Year
first month it came out bro NPD beat
Madden beat all these dudes beat big 2K
what's up
man sales it's sold what's up man yeah
that's huge who we talking about we we
in space or what or we going to space or
what what we doing here what we doing
here there ain't nothing I can say to
top this he h his bag he his bag I'm I'm
I'm I'm sick and tired of you guys
trying to sit there and poke holes in us
talking about y'all won't do this and we
keep proving every month we
will yo big star fiing is
outside and y'all are terrified could
you imagine once it gets nominated for
Game of the Year all y'all going to
start crying oh how they get nominated
with all those bug shut up Spider-Man
got bugs
too shut
up we're at the point now we at the
precipice we have to change into the
guard oh look at look oh JZ is hating
from the side Diablo better oh with this
F that's that's nice we own them
too they they in Pocket too that was a
perfect clapback that was a perfect
clapback I even go for what's funny man
like J sitting there trying to get that
Spirit Bing and and King's like we on
that to yeah that's right diffuse that
right put that over there when that
being Game Pass it'll probably really do
some numbers anyway oh my Lord let's go
we own them to I told dudes what
Starfield was going to do you laughed at
me I am 98% right all the
time y'all in trouble this is the time
where trouble is happening Phil Dominus
Maximus a really expens has turned into
Sith Lord field it's over just said
Starfield wasn't going to do what it's
going to do and I said I can't wait for
mpds and he was like yo King are you
sure you want to hear that when it comes
out yo Matt you my man love you to death
you about mat bis can tell her now okay
okay I got you I been about Matt I been
about Matt but see I listen it's gonna
be a point in time cuz Microsoft gonna
own everything
soon it's see y'all Y talk about y'all
mad at us they said what they going to
quiet
next we literally was just talking about
it earlier they were saying well
strategically we said this strategically
we should go get square square will burn
your life to the ground y all y' dudes
that heard Square was like no no no get
Sega
please please please oh God no get Sega
please cuz you know if they go get
square what happens to you
next y'all are ready in disarray this is
I will say that if they ever bought
Square Enix it would be really bad for
PlayStation really fast it'd be
curtains
curtains c but listen Spaceman King
signing
off we're number one in npds number
seven in seals that means it's sold that
means we buy
stuff and don't tell me the PC sold the
most because there's PC game pass over
there too so could have just said nah I
don't even want to buy it shut up
there's no excuses for you dudes no more
well for for three Spiderman better come
in it better beat Mario for for three
weeks King it was the number one most
sold thing on on on Xbox and it was over
Madden all that stuff like three expect
most play right but who who thought it
would come in number one in NPD no I
didn't think I didn't think that I mean
I mean we'll talk I'll get to my turn
but I got to get jez you know what I'm
saying I guess um go ahead then jez man
this is this is who that guy yeah who's
that guy you know say Lord space man
king baby I don't remember drinking this
popular
cure so Lord jez what do you make of
this Starfield you know winning MPD
excuse me Orana you know seventh you
know overall year to date you know how
do you extrapolate the data what what's
your thoughts on this because there was
a lot of narratives coming in to this
about you know Game Pass and its effect
on titles man what do you I can't really
follow it from King man king king in
NASA NASA uniform bro so it's kind of
like King said it all man it destroys
the narratives of Game Pass impac
themselves and it kind of it dovetails
back into what I said earlier that
Microsoft uses
Metacritic as or the industry uses
Metacritic as an indicator of what'll do
well what'll do well in Game Pass
what'll do well in retail sales what'll
do well on social media and all that
kind of stuff you know and um Bethesda
has a legacy a fan base that's
established dating back decades man and
it's the kind of it's the I remember
when I first started in this business
and the the blogging business or
whatever and the first event I ever went
to was uh Gamescom
2015 2016 I can't remember off the top
of my head but I met Aaron Greenberg at
that show and he was like what feedback
do you have for us and I was like Bro
you've got to you've got to lean into
Nostalgia more man you've got to lean
into into Nostalgia more cuz you know
PlayStation's out here with Nostalgia
Nintendo's out here Nostalgia and you
know you you sort of Xbox doesn't really
have that s besides like Halo edge of
Empires flight simulator and to a lesser
extent Gears of War which is more more
recent really Gears of War is more
recent um they don't really have that
sort of Legacy that some of the studios
enjoy but that's what they've purchased
with zenimax and that's what they
purchased with blizzard is that sort of
Legacy that Legacy fan base people who
are sort of our age were all getting old
all of us getting old but we've got a
lot of money to spend you know more so
than a than a kid or a teenager or some
of us anyway like I remember when I was
in my early 20s and I'd have to be I be
kind of like [__] should I buy this
should I buy that but you know as you
get older you get raises and you get
more money and people in their 30s and
40s generally have higher purchasing
power at least in yes you know Western
economies or whatever so like it's that
kind of that fan base you need to Target
and that's kind of what they bought with
Zen and Beth blizzard right they've
bought a legacy they've bought a fan
base uh they've bought people who are
our age with purchasing power
potentially and that is heavily
reflected in franchises like Diablo
heavily reflected in franchises like
Starfield because even though Starfield
is a new IP it's still a Bethesda game
absolutely at its core it's a pure p as
gold Bethesda yes experience you know so
yeah it's pretty exciting to think like
what will happen when they actually it's
a Bethesda game but it's not an new what
will happen when it's Elder Scrolls what
happen when it's Fallout five you know
good point it's going to be really
exciting to see that blow up because a
lot a lot of normies normies they don't
know what Starfield is but tell them
like the the next Skyrim's coming out or
tell them the next for's coming out then
it's going to have it's going to have an
even bigger impact so I think it's it's
exciting for the future of Xbox
particularly when you consider the AL
Scrolls in Fallout 5 will be exclusive
to the brand
and it's seems to have been reflected in
console sales too right yeah yeah yeah
number seven it's exciting man it's
exciting but Diablo is still
better there no problem I mean I want
them to sell too no salute to to jez and
what he's saying and I didn't even think
about I didn't even think about that you
know from the you know was they number
one in their month they came out who
Diablo yeah I don't remember I don't
remember the last couple nobody heard it
doesn't matter man it's still B what I
wanted to say was that I do want double
up on with chess made a fantastic point
in reference to that this is a new IP
from Bethesda but like you said that
Bethesda Legacy that Heritage it being
you know a western RPG and people still
showed out so it it really bodess well
for the established franchises right the
the fallouts the Elder Scrolls that
people will will more likely maybe even
flock more because they really familiar
with those TI but I wanted to ask just
this before we move on what do you think
about the you know obviously we heard
about the narrative with the you know
cannibalizing sales kind of thing but I
wanted to ask you about day and date PC
and in the PC portion of this like what
do you get from that data you know with
that PC also helped drive this this all
this month well I was actually thinking
about this today like because because I
have no life and I'm constantly thinking
about what can I what can I what can I
create content out of and you know one
of the things I was thinking about was
like what would it look like what would
what would it look like in a world where
Starfield was a timed a timed exclusive
to Xbox console
right where where they do the
PlayStation model where it's like the
the game launches best and first on the
console and then it rolls out to PC many
years after the fact and me and ran
talked about this on the show the other
day where it was like we we in the
context of Final Fantasy 16 where it was
like um in Final Fantasy 16 is kind of
like um if Final Fantasy 16 had launched
on PC and Xbox at the same time I feel
like it would have had a much stronger
presence on social media it would have
had a much stronger marketing viral
viral marketing push and Word of Mouth
push it would have been stronger on
Twitch as well because most twitch
streamers are on PC right at the end of
the day um
so but then for Starfield it's kind of
like it's it's a different model because
Square enx doesn't care about pushing
console sales but Xbox Xbox should care
about pushing console sales because they
they are been hammered by Sony and to a
lesser and well not to a lesser extent
at all like Nintendo as well and you
know even though people have this debate
about whether Xbox is in competition
with Nintendo and it I'm sorry but
unless you've got like four arms you
can't hold two controllers at the same
time either you're playing on Nintendo
system or you're playing on PlayStation
or you're playing on PC or playing on
Xbox at the same time there's there's
only so much attention you can give to a
specific platform at any one time right
so of course they're in competition so
it's kind of like what is the V is there
sort of like is there value for Xbox to
have made that console exclusive to push
console sales and of course like the raw
monetization suggests that yeah it's
better on PC because they get the
software sales and the business is
selling software it's not necessarily
selling consoles but from like uh
looking more further into the
future having more developers in your
ecosystem is is going to be more
sustainable for the Xbox platform and
you know if if a game like Starfield
could have drove more Xbox sales um B
potential
arm to the Xbox platform the fact that
that that it is simultaneously launching
on PC yeah that being said I think
there's there's the real the real real
the real situation is the fact that not
everyone can afford a high NPC and
starfields system starfields minimum
recommended specs was were not exactly
um should we say I don't know friendly
yeah yeah and you look at look at the
look at the minimum requirements for
Alan Wick like my my laptop is uh it's a
few years old now I've got an RTX 27 e
TI in this thing and I am just within
the minimum the minimum specs for Alan W
2 wow you know so like I'm kind of like
I now I need to upgrade my laptop I
spent three grand on this goddamn laptop
when it launched you know abely and um
so now it's like you know now I need to
consider upgrading my laptop if I want
to keep keep up the PC game gaming
sphere or I can buy a PS5 or an Xbox
series X which is vastly orders of
magnitude cheaper or even a series s you
know because Alan W to has to run on
that as well although it'll be
interesting to see see how it goes right
yeah yeah so there's Arguments for both
right um but yeah I I don't know we'll
see we'll see I I hear where you're
coming from brother and I totally hear
what you're saying in terms of the bet
that they they took and you know the
decision as far as people were saying
like how are they going to survive with
Starfield not being on a PlayStation
platform so I think it is a significant
you know deal for them their analytic
teams and and the metrics to see how
this thing perform I want to get I know
add jumped away for a little bit but we
get solved you know once that comes back
you know sofield being number one like
did you see this coming you know how do
you feel about it you know where do you
sit with Starfield winning
MPD I mean kind of new was coming man
like
it's it it's the followup to Skyrim from
Todd Howard it's gonna sell it's going
to sell it's that type of game that
people could say what they want to say
online people could say oh whatever Game
Pass I don't want to know gave I don't
want to get in the subscription servers
I don't want this they gave you all
types of options to purchase this game
the game is available on Steam which is
where I played it um Game Pass if you
want to wait and if you don't want to
wait it's still available on Game Pass
five days early just give me $35 that
was a huge the constellation Edition
before the pay people PID for that
that's huge that and that's going to be
huge moving forward for all for party
games oh you want Early Access give us
$30 give it 30 give us $40 season pass
give us something give the Early Access
there you go there you go and that
money's going to come in that way but
it's the follow it's a new IP from the
team that gave you Oblivion Fallout and
Skyrim people are gonna buy people are G
to buy I don't know if this metric holds
true for other first party stuff coming
down the line maybe something like a if
a fable blows the doors off you know off
the house or something like that or
but yeah I just knew I just it was
anything to me it's because it's it's
it's too big you be listen people could
say whatever they want you know that the
game is it's a different type of Todd
Howard game right doesn't have the same
feeling of a Skyrim that whole idea of
oh I I look over there I can go over
there and it's going to be right you
know I agree with the criticisms about
the game in that jumping from planet to
planet makes it feel a little more
disjointed and not like this whole this
entire world right I get that I get that
and I and I agree with it also at the
same time like again it was as long as
this game was good and it functioned and
it wasn't this this this train wreck and
trash fire at launch that people could
hold on to you know you couldn't it was
going to do well cuz even the people
that are online hating were going to get
this game because they wanted it to be
good they like you know what I mean like
it's or they wanted it to be bad so bad
that they were going to get the game
anyway to try to purch the exactly you
know exactly this is content so it's and
the fact of the matter is like this is
kind of only the start because I think
when it comes to these types of games
from from from Todd's team these games
have a long tail like you know when you
start thinking about what the mod
Community is going to do with this and
what they're going to turn this game
into that's a fact like you're going to
see this game on this list probably for
a while you know it'll it it'll taper
off then it'll come back it'll tap her
off it'll come
back so you're saying so he make
generational games yeah this is a game
this is a game that you still be talking
about if they do the right thing with it
right because to me it's all about the
community right and if the community
that has followed Fallout Oblivion and
and Skyrim it continues to follow this
game then yeah it's going to be there
it's going to it's absolutely going to
be there there and we may have a
situation where it's like oh they you
know you're you're playing Starfield on
your refrigerator on your sto or
whatever you know was was those games
you mentioned game of the year when they
came out I don't recall Skyrim I'm
assuming was I don't maybe fall I don't
remember what about Oblivion I don't
recall oh I don't recall this guy right
here man now now everybody now now
everybody's Andy pendent but all right
no I mean we know I Mis I misremember
okay no no I love Starfield I love
Starfield in a game of the year it's
it's going to be Game of the Year this
year we we paid the right people we paid
the right people oh the iron Lords does
not endorse this message the rest of the
Lords do not the words agree all with
the words of King David but those
opinions you you want information on
your show you know what you got to do
all right fair enough fair enough
continue I'm sorry yeah but that's it to
me when you look at
you know how long people been waiting
for the next game from from Todd's team
and it's a brand new IP the curiosity is
going to get you right even if you have
a disdain for Game Pass and Xbox or
whatever you as the moment they offered
on other platforms you GNA you to get
this game so um yeah it doesn't really
surprise me a whole lot um I expected it
unless the again unless the game was a
trash fire and maybe even then like I
said the the content draws people to try
to you know to make videos about
negative stuff right so
hey even even then it might have sold
super well so yeah I'm not surprised at
all I'll jump in until I gets back um
look I gotta be real I ain't expected to
win not that I didn't was going to do
well I knew it was going to do well but
I was thinking top five to me that would
have been a victory because I'm looking
at the competition and look I've been
watching Field's not going to win man no
not Game of the Year not game of the
year I'm talking about MPD I I knew jzz
like I was like in my mind I'm like look
it's on Game Pass yes it's exclusive
it's Todd's biggest IP you know from the
main team in a long time it's going to
do well it's going to be in that top
three to five right but I'm looking at
the month and I am a Mortal Kombat guy
and this Mortal Kombat one is phenomenal
and Mortal Kombat I know it's a fighting
game I heard you JZ like it's a fighting
I know but historically they've done
pretty well for themselves and I always
looked at it as you got that and then
you know in America you know we're
football guys Madden but we are not
going to disrespect the artist formerly
known as as FIFA right like we are not
well FIFA I already pronounced it see
you you can tell I'm American
F Michelle Fifer Michelle
Fifer we go we Adidas Adidas or Fifer
you go Adidas
and Adas man exactly excuse my American
call we we say Adidas
Adidas Adidas you got to buy some Adidas
from the
store don't American clown me but um
that was funny but yeah like I'm looking
at that I'm like that is an absolute
beast and we're still in football season
for Madden like this is Madden y'all
like we're not going to act like like
these are not Juggernauts and here's the
main indictment to me of how impressive
this is Starfield all these other games
are Co-op multiplayer
microtransaction Starfield is single
player Western RPG to its core no microt
no transaction none of that Co-op that
can boost engagements for free right
tell them tell so the fact that this
showed me that there is a desire for the
traditional Western RPG talking go ahead
I just want to say one thing please
please do none of those games launched
the Game Pass where you was able to get
it for free without purchasing so what
it showed me go what it showed me is
people wanted Starfield and they CED it
diffused all these narratives about Game
Pass catabolizing sales um supporting
the devs uh launching on PC devaluing
your launch it did not so we got to give
flowers where it is that that's my only
thing it's like at the end of the day
when this is the thing I will say about
bias you know when PlayStation does this
thing and God of War and it like bro we
give it up yo bro that is tremendous
what I I I'm not seeing the love for
Starfield on how amazing this
accomplishment is in my opinion maybe
you know I'm in the wrong circles I'm
not on social media enough for whatever
but I will say and y'all goingon to like
the poll is that an addict might
appreciate this what this showed me
though in regards to social media it it
is an echo chamber because the people
spoke the people said no no no the
people with the wallets the people like
Jess whoever they said we are buying but
that's this game we're buying stuff
we're excited this is a good game and
we're enjoying it and we want it that's
what this showed me that is a huge deal
and here's the other thing about Mortal
Kombat where people are sleeping Mortal
Kombat launched on almost all platforms
and was on switch so Starfield still had
a disadvantage versus Mortal Kombat and
in Game Pass if you call that switch
all right we ain't going to talk
about it did launch on Playstation well
well what they don't buy games over and
and the talk was if Starfield how is
Starfield going to make up for the sales
without having PlayStation that was the
talk look at them they they did it
without you without you baby we a need
this is huge I can't I got to give K
flowers on this this is a huge internal
data point for Microsoft to prove their
Vision as far as now the key thing I'm
curious jez is Game Pass subscriptions
did that increase you know the UK I'm
not sure about you know also the console
stuff like that it also showed me what
Sol saying the constellation Edition
people are willing to pay early people
on PC willing to play on Steam like and
the last thing I'll say and this is the
thing to me when people always clown
Xbox they say remember when Xbox was
popping over they was like yo 1 million
then they were like uh 6 million playing
Starfield and let's be honest a lot of
people and pundants rolled their eyes
yeah six million people played whatever
whatever you know what I'm saying and
remember we used to roll our eyes
sometimes when they used should say that
about Starfield I mean um about see a
thief did you see where SE of thieves
was on the Year date did you did you C
of SE of Thieves is on the year toate
sales for the year a game that people po
I didn't know that bro I C SE thieves is
in the top 20 of two of year to date
hold on one second that is I'm sorry
excuse me actually no no no no let me
let me correct that hold on on one
second that is no I'm sorry I apologize
that is we're looking at September
2023 top 20 best selling premium game
for the month of September SC I could be
correct that cfd is in that category so
cfd still made this in top 20 and that
that's an older game I think this is
impressive y'all I I think that was a
broken game in lunch right well it
didn't have a kraken Kraken didn't have
a body right it it still doesn't have a
body it's it wasn't a broken game it
just had it was anic it was
millions of people love it right and
what I will say is to addict's point you
know Final Fantasy and now we talk about
for the whole year right Starfield
debuting in one month is over Final
Fantasy 16 over Resident Evil 4 over
Street Fighter 6 an amazing Street
Fighter yes yeah did Final Fantasy 16
went MPD that month that they came out I
don't remember the old mpds bro I got I
don't know I
I know I know but I'm going to find out
this information because I got a lot
more bars no I feel listen this my last
bar I move in the chat look that up for
us thank you this is the thing and I
tell people all the time when people
laugh at Microsoft I know listen
Microsoft needs to be more transparent
with the numbers I'm not saying they are
no okay fair enough so um Microsoft
needs more more transparent with their
numbers we're always on them with that
but I remember saw people would always
roll their eyes at Microsoft whenever
they say we've got 3 million active
users and people like what does that
mean right and then they popping off
with 6 million for starfi people like
well it doesn't we shouldn't be popping
bottles yet we need to see to me a key
metric what I'm noticing with them and
what I look personally is daily active
users monthly active users go to Xbox
most played and adct remember these days
cuz we're Destiny guys and people were
clown and say oh Destiny it's it's
terrible game but you would look in the
top 10 of Xbox most play look at that
category when I used to see Starfield in
the top two to top three with the likes
next to call Call of Duty next to
fortnite these Mega engagement games
that mostly are free to play and a
single player game is right there going
head-to head that is tremendous as of
right now it still hasn't fallen out of
the top 10 it's in top it's like number
six I believe most played right now
people are playing this game this is
tremendous and again I have to State it
again single player no Co-op no
multiplayer no freeo play no
microtransaction no PlayStation
you're
ridiculous but we don't need
y'all that's all I got to say I mean
it's impressive it's impressive and we
we have to regardless of what side of
the fence you're on you have to give it
up the narratives this has Kilt a lot of
narratives and people we got to be fair
as fair when people used to say yo we
care about numbers we care about this is
the metri here we go can you care about
these numbers and for the people that
hate all I do like I do on theing Duke
is I I just hum at
you that's what I will say that's all I
got anybody I'm sorry ad I cut yeah adct
didn't get his I'm sorry you didn't get
your balls off they're saying that uh it
lost to Diablo which one lost to Diablo
oh you lost to another Microsoft
Game
Jesus yo still it's still sinking in for
me bro you're still s sinking in for me
I am like people always call me a Xbox
Fanboy I'm a blizzard blizzard Fanboy I
will I will completely and openly admit
that I'm a blizzard Fanboy like World
War completely changed my life man now
you're an changed my [__] life
language what the language
please it's the whiskey it's the vodka I
know no no no it's not the whiskey bar
it's just how British people speak man
yeah this is
true americ you guys are so sensitive
with no no no it's just it's just Sunday
and we got kids and stuff like that but
it's I I'm happy that you're with us now
kids hear that stuff at high school man
I you you telling me he that stuff at
high school no no well you know they do
but they can't say it around their
parents and stuff like that their
parents care you know I personally think
when it like it was hilarious how the
the gold moving was being made with this
like people are like oh it's cuz
PlayStation it's PC bought all the the
copies of star I was like Oh you mean
the same people you said were pirates
last week that don't buy games and and
you know they they they they go to
websites and torrent that stuff they
they never purchase games you mean them
people okay okay so now now you're
admitting the PC people play games so
like why because they would say the
reason that PlayStation games didn't e
Come of PCS because PC games didn't they
don't buy them like okay so they do buy
games now which one yeah people look
crazy right now with the excuses
it's hilarious I'm with you ad it's
hilarious with the gopost moving on this
in the metric that they themselves said
is the defining metric now it wins and
now we hear all these other excuses the
funny thing is this was never a
conversation on whether or not it was s
an Xbox uh the narrative people are
trying to spend was uh you know
Starfield was a bad game right it's like
but but more people bought and played
Starfield then 2K then Madden then
payday three m
like these are some of the
biggest known entities which obviously
Madden came out last year so month so
we'll have to see like those updated
numbers but it's just like look
Microsoft can easily exist on
both and be fine you know when you look
at the the store it was number two more
people on Xbox was playing
Starfield than war zone Call of Duty 2
for like weeks this was the cas month
and people was like oh what's dropping
yeah cuz it is a single player game
sooner or later people are going to
finish it and move on but guess what we
are still we are about to go into
November yeah and I stuck us still in
the top 10 on X still top 10 currently
number six ad you smell that you feel
that I smell fear that's the wind to
change change is happening I told you
dudes it's going to be a drop off and
y'all not going to see it coming it's
just going to hit you in the back of the
head you gonna wake up like what
happened Microsoft did what not again
Yes yes again
again at the end of the day you know
people can say what they want you know
Starfield it it's a very successful game
you know it did what it was It was
supposed to it came out there it it set
internet TNT all everywhere on Twitter
on YouTube on Tik Tok like you know
people would sit there like there's not
few games that get that kind of coverage
at it I'm kind of like the thing about
the the promise of Starfield and what
I'm personally really excited for is
what does Starfield look like in in in a
year in two years three years there is
so if you are like if you were down with
Starfield law and you've been exploring
the game beyond the surface level there
so much so much they can do with that
game house room and like a bunch of like
there's a quest where you go to like uh
the a battlefield where it's like all
the mechs and and like there was this
huge on a rocket yeah wow yeah there was
an Intergalactic war between like mechs
and bioweapons and and that that's why
the the the galaxies in the state it's
in and everyone's sort of like in this
sort of recession is because there was
this Galactic there this this Galactic
Wide War where where like giant mechs
were battling giant bio weapons and
we're sort of we're sort of it's almost
post-apocalyptic we're sort of we're in
the recovery period from this Galactic
War there's so much they could there's
so much they could do with this game I I
was thinking like man I would love a 4X
strategy game where like the I could
play like one of the three factions oh
that would be crazy and and B and battle
each other like one as Mech one as biow
weapons and one is house forun whatever
I don't know what they've got a giant
serpent the serpent the Great Serpent
yeah they worship a Great Serpent yeah I
have to I have to wonder is that serpent
a real thing in the game is that is that
is there some kind of giant space
squiding around in space you don't know
there's so many places they could take
this game like there where the ground
vehicles at they could add those quite
easily I feel like with and then the mod
Community Jazz you know what they could
do with this game is going to be
tremendous with there's an expansion
coming up there's so much potential that
people don't realize the tale of these
Bethesda games we we look at Skyrim
right and how much people like yo you
still making another addition of Skyrim
and Todd be like yeah cuz I keep buying
it you know I'm saying like you're not
going to stop but to your point I agree
I think there's still more to come for
Starfield and and it's it's really
impressive to see what they done what
you're saying is there's still more to
come for this game that is a potentially
game of the year that won npds in the
month that it was launched and it came
up number seven have long legs yeah for
sure for sure but it had all these BS
that's the the that's how Bethesda games
operate they're like they're single
player service games and there is no
other [__] I'm sorry Dam you're good
there is no of the company um I need I
need one of those buttons where yeah you
need the
button like
G but it's like yeah but I'm I'm so
sorry you good brother it needs like
there there is so much they can add to
that game and you know I really do feel
like it's a single player service game
you know it's the Bethesda are the only
company that really make these single
player service games where they have
these really long legs really long tails
and like it fall out for and Skyrim and
even Oblivion like has a strong
concurrent player counts even like
decades after the fact you know but
there's just the only company or one of
the very few companies that can really
achieve that and that's one of the
reasons why Microsoft bought them and
they kind of they freed them from this
weird they were doing this weird pivot
to mo mobile um not they were doing this
weird pivot to multiplayer you know and
we had like Wolfenstein young blood
which was awful awful game disgusting
I've still got a sour taste in my mouth
from that horrible game and um and then
fall out of 76 which
was you know it's it's PIV it's pivoted
now and it's actually fairly decent but
it was like at the time it was like
desperate and rushed yeah like godamn
you could feel you could feel the
desperation sweat well you desperation
when they told you that you had to buy
what was that you had to buy like the
package or something but they didn't
tell you what was inside the package you
talk about the Fallout 4 DLC um yeah I
remember that yeah it was It was kind of
crazy yeah they didn't give the specific
but all that's behind us now because
Game Pass Game Pass is liberators
liberated zenimax from having to uh sort
of adhere to these of like everything
has to be a service game like every
major publisher is like oh my God
everything has to be a service game we
need every game to have 50,000
microtransactions and gambling mechanics
and and and re recurring engagement
systems and you're going to see this
you're going to see this effect hit
blizzard as well ABS Game Pass Game Pass
is a liberator from that business model
it's a liberator it's a liberating
preach brother I gotta interrupt because
you cook me and you on the same weight
length here and this is what I try to
tell people who get mad when I you know
I there's a lot of fear mongering I feel
sometimes some is legitimate some people
do have concerns in the industry about
consolidation but I do feel that there's
a lot of fear mongering particularly
with Microsoft based on the platform it
is but what you're saying is what I try
to tell people all the time when I speak
to the developers and I speak to you
know the obsidians and they talk about
look you know we before we signed with
Microsoft we wanted to know that we
could do the things that we were able to
do again that stuff what you're talking
about from a liberator standpoint and
you talk about um you know like a Josh
Sawyer and him talking about you know
wouldn't being able to do a pent now
he's even trying to push for a pillars
of fraternity game and things that let's
be honest prior to acquisition these
companies are trying to catch a wave to
stay alive whether it be cooperative
remember pzza used to be the home of
remember we're a single player and to
jez's point you started to see the wave
catching which was the you know full off
76 and let's add Co-op to to Wolfenstein
and even death Loop to some extension is
them jumping outside of their box you
know when let say you know um dishonor
didn't do well a lot of stuff wasn't
doing well because it was yeah yeah
that's a good point ref was made back
then right so it it it shows you a lot
of companies trying to catch the live
service wave when they were faltering
and now that they have this security
from Microsoft and game pass to your
point jez right it allows more creative
risk and now you can be liberated I like
that word you that I I completely agree
I always feel that is the counter off
off argument to people who worry about
that and also let's be honest if you
make you keep bombing with a couple of
games let's just say red 4 and all that
stuff came out and there was no
Microsoft involved they came on Fallout
76 Wolfenstein Fallout 76 and redf what
you think's happening in the B is the
long term you feel what I'm saying
people people don't think about that
part when they talk about oh I don't
like C you want the studio to go away
you want the publisher to go away you
know what I'm saying that it it doesn't
take that long for you to be up out of
here Gamers will move on and that's the
part people are not talking about and
I'm glad you mentioned that and I'm on
my Soap Box a little bit because I I do
feel that I rather to me it's a better
alternative I I rather that then 10 cent
or someone else get it that's just where
I'm at with it but I'm
done people hire on 10 cent but like is
10 cent really that bad yeah my issue
with them Jaz is that you know how much
we love Mass Effect a game like Mass
Effect couldn't exist under 10 tent
based on aies their feelings on Choice
their feeling on sexuality their feeling
on you wouldn't be able to make a game
like that that's my my issue with with
with them you know what I'm saying now
look a bag is a bag you mean you mean
because of the because that
they to the Chinese Communist part right
and that part again I'm not I'm just me
as a person who loves I Am pro developer
and pro creative expression and if you
want to make the game you want to make
you should and you shouldn't have any
restrictions from a publisher telling
you you got to take this out you got to
take that out I am not with that so
that's my only issue yeah I understand
if people take a I don't judge someone
that takes a 10cent bag cuz hey you got
to keep the lights on you got to do what
you got to do but just understand the
risks or the things that come with it is
what we we kind of promote and that's
where I'm at with it I I am not 100%
familiar with with whether or not
tensent creates uh an atmosphere of
censorship for its Western developers
honestly don't I don't think necessarily
that they do because you tent owns
League of Legends right and they also on
fortnite and stuff like that well 50% of
fortnite I don't think I think we we
with regards to Western devel devs I
don't think 10cent has as much
censorship chops as you might expect in
China sure yes because if you don't do
what China says they will bleep kill you
yes abely you will be you will be
disappeared you know in in the Chinese
the it's just the way it is over there
you know um but I don't know if they
have the same impact on the western
developers you know they own Path of
Exile they own um they own a a bunch of
games in the west and stuff and I do
think Riot has like Riot who owns like
League of Legends and team fight tactics
and a bunch of those games I think they
do I think 10cent does have the give
them the freedom and I don't think
10cent is necessarily bad um in the west
but i c i could still kind of appreciate
that it's still icky right because
they're still they're still owned by the
Chinese Communist party which they're
icky man they're icky to say the least
they give me the ick bro is an
interesting
word no I feel you I feel you and I
guess like I said we'll talk off I don't
want to divert this conversation cuz we
are going along but um yeah it's
definitely a factor you know that a lot
of people have brought we've had some
discussion I've had a great discussion
with this with Colin as well but I do
want to move onless everybody got their
bars off on the Starfield situation
everybody's good and uh super chats
didn't kind of all combine we can
combine to where we
at okay we got black Ronin 357 $5 Super
Chat King is a superhero to Xbox and a
super villain genius to Sony 2024 is
going to be crazy for Xbox lies of PE
should be nominated Game of the Year
along with Starfield and bers Gate 3 oh
no it is a powerful time then we have
chill
carlos5 yo chill Carlos chill
car the Xbox podcast Community is full
of pony Bots thank God for dirt and king
oh my oh my Lord
blessings back to you s there we have
splendiferous $5 Super Chat King what
Phil say what did Phil say to SAA he
said we get them teting them out a luck
now we squeeze seven and de hold a dam
duck
down oh
man do stop changing up the
team shoot that's that Bunty that's the
homie Bunty no that's split difference
oh that's split difference all right
salute still different salute salute you
going to change up the
t h sagging sack 10 pound chat come toic
Microsoft might win the publisher of the
year for 2023 they have released more
highly rated games than any other
publisher I believe what do you think
fellas yeah call um Call of
Duty there you
go win PD I wonder when I wonder if
because the deal wasn't finalized if
they'll count like Diablo and stuffff
cuz Diablo Technically when it released
wasn't an Xbox game at the time right
correct no but Call of Duty will be yeah
we'll
see then we have Spartan 661 $5 Super
Chat shout out to je drinking and
hanging out with the realm he is Awesome
by being with IOP from the arrival to
finish this is an awesome show thank you
bro chilling SP beverages this this this
Bren Brenan
Icelandic did you get that from my man
jovar did you get that from my man's
it's from from H I can't remember his
name
yeah I met I met up with a with an Xbox
2 fan Xbox 2 podcast fan in Iceland and
bought me he bought me this yeah he's
official he's official I can't remember
his name because it's it's Icelandic and
my my English brain is sort of
like what how jovar
inar yes something like that I met him
and he was he was super kind and he
bought me this amazing lure and it's
super nice with a bit of color in I got
some some inside Intel Jo was a homie he
told me that you were in like I want
meet up with jazz I was like jazz is
awesome I met him in person as well so
that's dope he he told me he like I hope
he he likes some some Irish I mean
Iceland yeah Icelandic B I said if it's
alcohol J's going to like
it good continue what else we got then
we have Craig hul again shout out to
Craig H put the Crush in the chat gifted
one I members salute salute bless bless
thank you shout out to the hoolan then
we got Lord rfess member for 26 month
Lord bronze I give because I'm still
playing it Starfield a nine out of 10
absolutely loving it shout out to the
ambulance something's going wild today
yeah New York new jerseyy is going crazy
V there um absolutely loving it a uh a
some nine days 22 hours play time so far
wow easily my game of the year game of
the generation tell the truth Shane
salute then we have Spartan 661 $10
Super Chat the creation engine is a
different kind of engine you can't do
things in their you can do the you can't
or you can't do things in their games in
other engines Bethesda is a game
developer that does more in their games
that others would wish they could do
salute people love those games and it's
MPD proved it then we have Nintendo onu
$2 Super Chat Cog where is Final Fantasy
16 on that list yeah I know you Messi
yes Starfield had more year-to dat sales
than what's up we got breaking news
what's the breaking news what going on
news what's going on people can fly
confirms project Maverick an Xbox
project this is from clob on Twitter
project Maverick is a yet unannounced
Triple A of game developed with
Microsoft Tria the game development
involves our European North American
teams or are for open positions people
can fly people can fly made um what's it
they made out Riders gears judgment and
out Riders right Jud
there are 40 open positions of people
can fly for the
project position buor bullet
stor really good I really like
B it's likely mean production on the
project still in the early stages Creer
descriptions for the team mentions
knowledge and pass for RPG games under
Unreal Engine what oh wait Triple A
Unreal Engine wait hold on hold let me
let me ask you this so this is people
can fly is making is it a XBox exclusive
though yeah it sounds like it is yeah
oh I told
you smell like the Wind of Change is
changing dude there too many games bro
that too many gam I don't I don't have
time for all this did did they say did
they say what genre it might be they say
RPG RPG they said we want people with
RPG
experience I wonder if it's a just
worm because it is Triple-A I mean
people can fly TS to beat third person
over the shoulder
out rers too man maybe it's out rers too
hey I hope it's I will hope it's to
Human
[Music]
Too
Human cuz Phil said he do uh want to
revisit old stuff so please revisit to
human because I finished that story and
I want to
continue okay listen we got to see
that's breaking news shout out to jez on
that one and clob bro salute no doubt
what else we got uh Tom
video we got deino $5 Super Chat they
also didn't use the $30 add-on for Game
Pass for
Starfield
interesting interesting then we have
called weeb $10 Super Chat let's do some
math Phil said game passes 15% of their
software/services revenue 10 million
people played Starfield 75% of sales are
on PC that means
2.125 million bought it on Xbox not far
off from Final Fantasy 16 on
PS5 okay what else we got red and black
dog just a dog y'all just a dog what's
up just to clarify my earlier chat stop
said I've been trained out to buy games
I buy a lot of games on Xbox you can't
you guys can't take everything literally
man they coming for you you know was bad
every time like most of the time I buy
four copies of stuff
yeah oh let me I buy a lot of games on
Xbox and steam shout out rock Ally I
don't want to buy first party I don't
want to buy first party games for $70
specifically specifically Ally
baby was it you who told me to go get
this it was I it was yeah you hit me um
what's up I pre-ordered the um the
legion
the the lovo the legion go but I didn't
I ended up canceling because I was like
[__] I can't afford
this it's
expensive I'm poor man I'm poor bro
you're big time journalist man you're
big time
journalist I actually I actually earn
more from the podcast than writing these
days increasingly I'm like dude I should
just go into YouTube and just quit
writing you go full there so there's so
much more money to be made on YouTube
than is on in writing giving real I'm
managing editor man I'm a managing
editor and there's more money to be made
podcasting on YouTube than writing it's
crazy it's crazy dude that's the world
we live in that's the world we live in
right now G and Jean Park said it seems
to be a chei going on he back to you so
back to
[Laughter]
you there we have KJ Wars
85 gifted five I members membersip
that's put the Crush in the chat for C
85 then we have Cory Tidwell $5 Super
Chat J du and Chris Hart played
Spider-Man while laying on their
stomachs the whole time wow wow with the
door open come on
Wow Wow a come on that's too much time
time that's crazy that was wild continue
There we have John Wolf I can't even
John Wolf $5 Super Chat shout out toia
for sh love to my Cuban people looks
like the Insomniac staff was drinking
too much
Cafe they call me Cuban
pself and then finally we have jar Ingy
y the iron Lords plus Jazz equals
perfect podcast for me shout out to you
so yo that's the homie right there with
that Icelandic beverages to my man
salute are we caught up now got vodka
and I've got Bavarian beer and dude we
just how many how many more how many
hours we going we got like one more
please let me know all oh you was ready
bro oh you was ready today we got we
we're not done we're not done more hours
bro let's go by
yourself Yo King jez is advancing the
line with this liquor yeah yo he he's
out of control he's out of control
advaning the live baby it's no doubt we
love it drug ja is the best I'm going to
like it's it's it's uh 11:00 p.m here
not to the show I'm going to go and cook
spaghetti I like that we like spaghetti
what do you do you one of those dudes
that put the sauce in the spaghetti or
you put the sauce on the top I'm GNA
blow you K mind right now dude you eat
it with no sauce you put it with
butter olive oil oil I knew I knew you
was going to say that I knew you was
going to say that
iook I cooked the spaghetti and then
just put some olive oil on put some
cheese and tun tuna tuna fish on oh my
Lord European um to you European taste
is is usually like that God long as you
don't Tuna on everything here man what I
put there tuna pizzza is really popular
in Europe oh my god I've discovered that
tuna pizzza is yeah cogn is upset right
now
is in America is it albore is it uh tuna
that you just don't care if you you
catch
Dolphins Tuna from a can
bro you thought it was like tuna steak
though this
is and D he didn't even get to the beans
yet that he always do I'm I'm I'm I'm
[Laughter]
nervous beans and spaghetti what's the
confession what's the confession let's
go said he eating beans and spaghetti
that's a beans man that's Lord beans
what's the confession Lord J beans and
spaghetti I actually don't need that
many beans
man it makes me ill it makes me ill man
like since makes everybody around you
ill with what happens
afterwards I turned I turned 35 and I
had a stomach infection and since then I
can't eat beans man yeah same with me it
feel it feels like it feels like I'm
only living half of a
life you're not a proper Englishman
without the B the big beans man they
they shut his beans career down
I I I still eat them but it's like I
have to it's like I'm going to eat beans
today and I know I'm going to suffer I
know I'm going to suffer I love it shout
out to I've never had beans on um
spaghetti though yeah got my mom's GW
has anyone in chat tried beans on
Spaghetti not on SPH you should try
tonight take pictures and post them on
Twitter no let's not see the beans let's
not see beans spaghetti let's not see
try that I'm going to try that tonight
yes put put beans in alive
o no
bangers isn't that Irish though is
it I feel like anything with bangers is
Irish Five Guys all right come on true
we got to move on we got to move on we
have is like K Sante is in the chat
saying as a man born and raised in
different European CS you need to stop
Mis representing European food bro that
that is
cap cap bro like we we put tuna on
everything in this in this in this
region bro like when I when I when I go
to a German Place tuna Pizza is an
option here man it's option and tuna
pasta tuna pasta you can buy tuna pasta
salad in every goddamn
Supermarket stop with the cap bro stop
with the cap drun Jaz is the best jazz
we move on so [__] bangers and mash are
is the affectionate British slang for
sausages and creamy mashed potato okay I
correct I stand I stand corrected all
right we are aggressive all right we
going to move
uh Phil Spencer Phil dominous Maximus a
really Spencer oh man we got more
topics we H behind aall um we'll combine
we'll combine um yes God he's behind I
mean he's not behind A4 F he was outside
talking shut up K oh this this episode
is messy so we speaking on the future of
ABK it was an interview shout out to uh
lady Tina shout out to the homies uh
Lord Malik and Lord Jeff Rubenstein they
were out side interviewing Phil this is
right after the deal and um just want to
get a chance if anybody caught this
interview he's kind of talking about the
future of ABK you know what what to
expect moving forward so I want to get
jez in you know what were your thoughts
on this interview if you caught it and
how do you think they're going to
maneuver with um ABK moving
forward I think like in the short term
we probably won't see a huge amount of
movement but one thing I do want to say
is like you guys saw that Phil went
straight to King right yes they went
they went to King first and publicized
that very first that tells you what
their priorities are and that is bleep
mobile bleep mobile bro so like that's
kind of like where you're going to see a
lot of the the the sort of I think a lot
of the effort is going to go towards
mobile one of the things I've heard from
speaking to people at Microsoft is they
want to get Xbox achievements in games
like Candy caga and Diablo Immortal and
like let you sign in with Xbox and
because right now when you sign into
some of these games it's Google Google
[__] you know langu
sorry kill us it's it's damn it's damn
is a swear word in in America no no you
can say damn damn is lit I can say can I
say can I say that never no you
can't but um it sort of tells you where
the pros are and the thing is Microsoft
was 100% transparent with this they were
like Regulators this is not not about
Cloud this is about mobile this is about
giving some legit competition to Google
and apple which have a Dooly here you
know Google and Google and apple take
30% 30% of developer revenues on these
platforms which stifles innovation G's
G's consumers and it's just general
General BS you know and Apple and Google
are these sort of gatekeeper gatekeep
gayek keeper companies as designated by
the European Union which is why like
they're they're they're forcing Apple to
allow Microsoft to create this steam of
mobile which is what this deal was all
about it was creating a
steam allegory for mobile devices and
that's what you're going to see in 2024
initially um but nobody on this podcast
none of you guys care that much about
Mobile gaming none of the people
watching this show in the chat you guys
hello none of you guys care that much
about Mobile gaming I I would I would I
would surmise as a result like this
stuff doesn't really fact us and for
Xbox game and PC Gamers and whoever else
Gamers I don't think you're going to see
a vast amount of upheaval as a result of
this deal in the near term in the long
term we probably will see games like
Guitar Hero and Skylanders and Starcraft
see spin-offs and games that wouldn't
have existed under the Activision
regime potentially but in the near term
most of what you're going to see is
mobile you're going to see Xbox do a
mobile store in 2024 you're going to see
Xbox integration in Candy Crush and
Diablo Immortal and and and like fallout
shelter and and um and Minecraft and and
the new Elder Scrolls oh yeah Scrolls
Fallout shter kind of game El Scrolls
castles or whatever it's called you know
you're going to see a lot of Microsoft
Microsoft's going to be like pushing way
harder into Mobile than they have and
Microsoft's internal efforts at mobile
have been piss poor man abysmal po piece
of swear word in America no you're good
no you lit you good you
kill what what is what is
diao what is Diablo's mobile game
diao Casino a horrible Casino hellscape
GTA game where it's like Microsoft had a
name on that
too let's go yeah it's yeah it makes a
hell of a lot of money it's a gambling
game it's it's a casino with a Diablo
skin attached to it man I play mobile
games all day I play mobile games more
than I play uh my Whatchamacallit my
consoles because I'm out of the house
the majority of the time so to be honest
with you I was upset when they got rid
of uh gear gears gears Pop Pop I was
really upset because I was playing if
somebody goes and look at my timeline
gears pop is crazy on my timeline hard
so this is the thing man like like a lot
of these games the Microsoft tried to
make we just they're not they weren't
successful even if like if you if you
like gear pop or for street or whatever
they were just not success successful
hello hello Spartan Assault which I
thought was quite good it just wasn't
successful but Microsoft now has
internal expertise to build these kind
of games that people kind of want people
want the gambling they want the pay to
win they want that they want that stuff
and I don't know why like it's alien to
me and it's probably alien to you guys
but people want that stuff mob there
it's instant gratification
jez gambling I got I got I got friends
who bet on horses and stuff like that
it's it's fun and there's nothing wrong
with it there's nothing wrong with it if
that's what you enjoy fine it's
everything wrong with gambling but
gambling is everything wrong with
gambling but at the same time if if
somebody wants to do that to fill some
some endorphin release as far as instant
gratification goes this is the reason
why we play video games because of
instant
gratification um I just feel that it
should be limits and barriers uh so that
it's not predatory that's
all no I hear you I hear you um I hear
what you sorry adct I think he jumped
out for a second but I was going to um
get Sol in as well you know I don't know
if you got a chance you got a chance to
see the interview from Phil in reference
to kind of like a round table in
reference to the ABK what happens next
and his thoughts what was your your
opinion of
that um yeah I mean I think you know
anytime you have an inhouse sort of it
you know you're not going to get the
hardest questions necessarily but you
know at the same time it is it is Phil
sort of dictating what he wants to say
and being clear about a lot of things
that you know he knows people are asking
about like are we going to get this
massive game drop or whatever uh is
there any surprise sort of drop that's
going to happen before the end of the
year and I like the fact that he was
very honest and saying no it's like
there's work to be done there because
because of the fact that the that this
deal took so long you know there wasn't
this push back like you know when you
when you think about the zenx deal or
whatever there wasn't this level of push
back where the conversations behind the
scenes that would be able to bring these
games to Game Pass very quickly weren't
allowed to happen in this case it was
still kind of up in the air like I don't
know man something bad can happen it
could go left and then we're going to
get in trouble for having conversations
we should not be having before the time
so so at the end of the day they really
did have to sort of wait much later than
they probably would have to try to have
these conversations about putting these
things onto Game Pass uh in a quick
fashion so I mean I I like the fact that
he talked about that but to Jess's point
I think it was very telling that it was
he's going to go see King first king
first yes yeah I mean it is yeah they go
see King first they gonna see the king
they going to see the king verse um
because the fact of the matter is they
these are the games that's going all the
hot stuff you're talking about all that
great all those single player games and
whatnot that you want to see down the
pipeline a lot of it is contingent on
and I'm not gonna say contingent like it
won't happen otherwise but a lot of them
they want this this this passive latent
money that comes in from from the people
that are however many millions are
playing Candy Crush and whatever and
mind you they have it's Candy Crush and
maybe one or two other games that have
and you know that have a fraction of the
popularity that Candy Crush has mhm
imagine developing another game one
other game that gives you something of
that ilk that takes it to that level and
is really this this sort of crazy sort
of cash cow that's what they're looking
for and that's what they're looking when
you think about them creating a mobile
store next year and expanding upon that
and perhaps making it this additive
thing to to what core Game Pass is now
um you know you know where their mindset
is at um I also like the fact that he
says I'm going to all of these places is
to listen
yes uh the fact of the matter is that
now they've taken on all of this extra
staff all of these Dev teams they have
to really figure out how this is going
to operate and for a company that's been
criticized in the past about not being
able to sort of control their teams and
have and have their their finger on the
pulse of what's happening at these teams
and then you have situations like you
know the red fall situation where they
admitted like we we kind of left them
alone did think about it or whatever or
something that was more Hands-On with
the with Starfield where they gave them
all the time that they needed for that
product to come out and not be under
this immense scrutiny because it's
broken right so I think they learned a
lot from that and he realizes that hey
this is a big undertaking and I have to
be sure that I go in here obviously
we're going to do what we going we want
to do right you know go back to the
whole conversation about hey does Bobby
ktic you know is he happy about these
games going into Game Pass he's like
well he it's not his decision to make um
so obviously they're coming in and
they're going to to project their sort
of their goals and their ideologies onto
these teams but at the same time you got
to go in and see what people are happy
with already and What needs to change
and and the things that they sort of
bring up so I really do hope that these
teams are taking the opportunity to say
hey we like this we don't like this you
know and and and as fans we've talked
about the possibility of some of these
teams that are working on COD be like
hey is there a possibility that we can
you know whatever bulk up a little bit
and maybe get a team working on
something smaller new some passion
project or something like that or maybe
go back to an old IP so uh I I just
think the fact that he's there willing
to listen and first and foremost is
super important right but for Optics
obviously but at the end of the day this
is what you need to do in order to
ensure these the health of these teams
as they transition into being part of
Microsoft so I thought it was a good
interview it's one of those where it's
like again you look at it a little bit
Qui eye because it's the home team it's
inside baseball whatever but at the same
time I thought the things he said were
were were were very good and and telling
about where they're going without
feeling like he was holding too much
back necessarily yeah fair enough fair
enough Lord King the focus seemed to be
on King on you what did you think of uh
Phil Spencer Phil Dominus Maximus will
Spencer Talking Now post deal conclusion
what was your thoughts on the future of
ABK well the fact that he went on
inhouse that's telling okay what's
what's that is telling you is they no
longer need anybody else's platform to
push their
story right so from that point I was
just like wow you didn't pick anybody
else to go
to you did what addict told you to do
facts from the beginning yeah adct
wanted that from the beginning go to
your platform push it there make people
come to you to see what you're talking
about now everybody's talking about this
interview and what he said uh the fact
that uh you know the fact that first of
all they go to King all right you are
the priority they've been saying that
from the beginning all y'all thought it
was Call of Duty you
idiots you idiots y fell for the banana
and the tail
he he didn't go over to the Call of Duty
team and say hi
guys no he went over to
King so what's going on what we got
going on over here cuz I heard y'all
making buckets of bread facts buckets of
breath yeah he said he wanted to learn I
need to learn from king that's what he
said I need to see what y'all doing so I
can replicate this and take this back
over that all right we ain't gonna mess
up nothing we want to know your concerns
cuz we heard you make buckets of
bread and and we just spend 70 billion
and we need our bread
back you m so the fact of the matter is
King makes a bucket of bread yeah Call
of Duty war zone makes bucket bre love
bread I'm sorry I'm so sorry I swore
again I'm so sorry we didn't hear it no
we didn't hear it so you're lucky you're
lucky we didn't hear it we just heard
Brad you're good
but Diablo makes butter um all
right just keep messing with you um the
fact of the matter is this has been one
of their best
investments going forward because it
lines up with their whole plan once that
star front is up and running once
everything is in line and these games
start to churn out and they'll be
everywhere they want to be everywhere
and I heard jez said earlier that they
were worrying about selling cont
that no that that's an old metrics that
doesn't even matter in this digital
world anymore I don't think they're
worried about selling consoles but it's
I'm worried you said you're worried
worried about them selling consoles
because I I don't want to see the
console go away I think Microsoft
personally it will no I don't care but I
I spoke to someone at Microsoft recently
and they were like do you know how much
it C like there people say like stuff
like um uh Microsoft needs its own Stu
front because PlayStation Apple and
Google they take 30% but they were like
when someone in Microsoft told me like
when you factor in the cost their costs
they still they're still paying 20%
they're still paying 20% to run their
own store so when you factor in their
overheads their support teams their
Cloud their bandwidth and the the stuff
that they have to pay for for the
margins are only 10% better than putting
on third party stores I don't want to
see Xbox go away because I've got one
over a thousand digital games attached
to Xbox so it's kind of selfish when I'm
talking about like I want to see Xbox do
well because I don't want to see Xbox go
away because I own thousand games on the
Xbox store I don't think you see Xbox go
away that's not going to happen I don't
think so either all right they just
spent $100 billion in a couple years St
to PlayStation somehow some no no
actually I'm not I'm not I'm not but
consoles is going away all right
physical media is going to be a thing of
the past in the next two three years as
far as you know yeah because uh Walmart
uh Best Buy oh talking about yeah yeah
um and uh Target will no longer be
carrying things all right and there a
reason why these guys are having their
digital stores up and running and stuff
like that you'll be buying direct from
distributor you you will be buying
directly from Microsoft that's why when
you can go inside your app right now and
you can purchase a console and Microsoft
ships it to you you know this stuff will
be happening soon you know you just pick
up a controller and go to your TV we we
dread that world because we want to have
bobles around
us it's going to happen and it's going
to happen faster than you think because
the stuff that we're doing right now is
not sustainable all right
um I just feel that what he did right
now going over there speaking to King
tells you exactly where they road map
leads to the road map leads to digital
distribution in a mobile handheld front
what he said 8 billion and King was part
of that piece of that puzzle to get to
the 8 billion people and everybody
laughed and said how you going to reach
8 billion people I don't know how many
people Candy Crush reach right now but
Microsoft is reaching each and every
last one of them now and that's a whole
lot more than the install base on Xbox
yeah it's crazy the mobile scene is
crazy it just happens that way so I
thought I thought the the conversations
was good it leads to some of ips I I
told people to calm down I don't think
he's going to automatically sell uh you
know toys of Bob you will stop working
you know no it's it's we're gonna see
how the business Works he's going to go
to these places see how everything works
talk to people see their concerns and
stuff like that sort everything out put
people in place keep things moving as
normal and then you start to see things
start to change over a period of time
you know you start maybe getting one or
two IPS here and there to go inside the
catalog inside uh game pass that stuff
could happen you could get a spiral you
will get crash and stuff like that so
I'm I'm hopeful for the conversations
that he did have and and did he deserve
to to have uh home cooking he earned it
he earned a home cook meal and have
softball questions thrown at him and and
be in a comfort after having one of the
biggest uh purchas business out the
street with courts the lawyers these
these dudes was out there so he he he
earned one you know adct your thoughts
uh on Phil's comments the interview post
ABK future of
okay and mut he's muted I can't hear
him I think his thing messed up again oh
his thing's messing up yeah I can't hear
him at all nope still can't hear you
what about there you go there you go
you're back
baby you're B you're gone again and he G
again y he was back and then he was gone
you're back and then you're gone yeah
he's good oh you're back you're back
baby okay okay all right so I'm sorry
you guys are going in and out on my end
what was the question yeah ABK Phil's
interview you know did you get a chance
to see it and what I saw I made a video
about it um I think the biggest
highlight he made there was you know
they're going to revisit old games so
hopefully he even said this isn't just
Activision Blizzard King this is like
them as an entity and he did kind of say
that you know if a company wants to work
on
older Xbox and Microsoft IPS you know
he's not against that so it did feel
like some of these ABK studiio obviously
they're going I would say some of them
are going to be locked into making Call
of Duty for a little bit because they're
already currently making a Call of Duty
game so maybe he'll let like smaller you
know smaller teams span out and you know
work on smaller projects such as like
bringing some of these older games into
the modern day no well said I agree with
you there that was super exciting you
know to me um I think I think that's
cool there's a lot of potential there
with these Studios I'll jump in right
quick um yeah jez nailed it I thought
the very most interesting part was the
first team was King he's going to meet
out to and it goes to show you the
importance of why this deal is done and
I know Gamers don't want to hear it King
is preaching a lot of stuff that is true
that look they said it like je said to
The Regulators they have no foothold in
Mobile they wanted this part and then to
be honest this is going to be the
long-term sustaining of Xbox because
again if you look at the brass tax with
what actually makes money
it's not a lot of these hardcore Gamers
that we games that we love and we
associate with all the bangers that's
the quality it sometimes be those other
games like a Minecraft like a Age of
Empires that are supporting everything
else that they are doing and I don't
know if y'all saw did y'all see what
Minecraft just did right now it was like
300 million copies sold the best video
game sold of all time Minecraft best
selling video game of all time yeah
Minecraft they own that moyang remember
when people clowned and said yo why are
they getting acquir bro that's printing
money for them to allow to do stuff so
again I know as hardcore Gamers it's
hard for us because I'll be I'll be
honest I am not a mobile guy at all it
doesn't resonate with me at all but I
understand why they do you don't like
Candy Crush
Cognito I do not but I will say
this it does serve a
demographic was it female younger what
is it s you
said nor mom do and me I man there was a
minute when I said okay once once they
announced the purchase said let me see
what this Candy Crush is about because
my mother's obsessed with it I went
in yeah yeah I get it I didn't spend the
dime on it which she has she's like yeah
she's like can you can you show me how
to buy these cars do the
microtransactions oh no man bro it is
it's a p and what it is is that the
there there's certain sub as as jez
calls the normies that are sub that have
never going to buy a console they live
on their phone whether it's a younger
demographic whether it's a female I
don't know what the the actual hold on
I'm waitting oh you going you got me
okay oh no I'm talking to my dog okay by
I thought I was M it oh no no you're not
what talking to who the dog I was
talking to my dog come here Coco come
here come dad put the dog on stream
please
yes
yes what's the dog's name coko her name
is coko Chanel
Johnson shout out to Coco Chanel salute
I love the full name and last name has
anyone have any of you the guys got pets
not no long I used to I used to not
anymore ad adct has aome cats to the dog
ad so adct go and get your cats please I
am not going to get those kittens come
on come on do it for the people do it
for the people in chat come on come on
come on he's going to do it he's going
to do it go and get those cats right now
thank you get those cats right now so we
have going left but yeah yo the chat
just wrote in Coco Chanel yo the chat is
stupid anyway so yeah like I I think
that this was the side of the business
that is important to them they're going
to learn from them they want to learn
like King said how you whip up that whip
up over there how you how you making
that bread that is going to be huge from
they going they're going to be students
listening to King because that is
something that is important to them I
agree with addict I think that um I'm
really excited about the thing he said
in reference to the developers about
letting them creatively do what they
want to do that is huge in in game
development oh we got do we have a
kitten Titan is adct back I don't see a
kitten though but um I thought that is
very uh oh is he grabbing it is he ah we
got
kittens oh oh that's the homie oh I like
him oh that's adorable who that that's
Fred that's Fred that's B that's FR no I
couldn't find Fred Fred oh my God Fred
is probably sleeping somewhere oh man
that's what's up yeah he's a do so who
is that who is that so we know wait you
own a black cat
no I couldn't find it Grace is looking
for we got GL cat what's the name of the
cat what's the name of the cat bring him
to
me I just want him just bring don't ask
questions just bring woman don't ask
questions just bring my C
yo I like how he did that he's like
woman I done told you no told you the
hand the
cat they want to see Fred we want to see
Fred we went the realm
this want to see the pets where Fred at
though where Fred Big Fred that's what's
up that's what's up that's the homie
salute man Fred with the hat so cute
adorable oh we got the face D we got the
face
okay the literally dead
dead he's literally dead salute but
adorable here on I but um yeah that's
the they said drug Jazz favorite thing
is every two night is in a row that's
awesome oh my God lord
adex jealous yeah we got it's so cute is
willing I to look at the face yo the
face was hilarious just now just woke
him up he was sleeping under the couch
Fred like what the hell going on out
here I was do not put me on
TV I got I got warrants he got warrant
he got he got try to escape for the man
but look I'll finish up um look I get
allowing them to do what they want to do
um I thought that's very big um we
already see a little bit of the
marketing shout out to gabing Forte on
Twitter looks like maybe they'll start
to to ramp that that up he showed me
some stuff with uh Call of Duty and uh
and um XBox um Association I will be
honest though this is the real the real
work starts now clearly there have been
separate companies that have not been
integrated yet that's why we're not
seeing that same Round Table kind of
energy like they had with beza so you
know we didn't get the immediate drop I
I agree that this with King is going to
be probably like a a drip feed
throughout the next year whilea we'll
work with marketing on what's the
correct way to do it but I got to be
hard on them at this point this when you
when you acquire ABK this is a career
move this is Phil's Legacy on this so
this is about managing now there's
there's no more excuses as far as you
know we can't have a like 2022 right mhm
so you've got the product you've got the
studios you've got the resources you got
mobile go execute now right and I think
they will I honestly think they will I
think they're in position I think they
understand the importance of it but we
can have situations like red FL where oh
we didn't know what was going on and you
know the team wanted to internally
cancel it but it came out anyway and
like this is the time and I do think
this is going to Define his legacy this
is this is a big move y'all this is this
is huge and um almost like a home run
shot and and for the people this is what
I this is for Sol I think you appreciate
I know a lot of people you know don't
like consolidation and all that stuff
but to me this is their Yankees Bo this
is like the start remember when the
Yankees yeah I'm thinking Stein Brer
energy it's kind of like this is 96 they
just got Alex Rodriguez bab you know
what I'm saying jeta and whatever and
they like this is on that path and when
you have that many studios that you it's
no excuses now now you got to win a chip
you got to continue to to produce and
execute the future looks bright but you
got to execute we got to be on that and
last remember when I said that K
remember when I said the future look
bright at Xbox and dudes laughed at me
the difference the difference in that
analogy though is that this is this is
where the criticism comes in that the
vast majority of that success came
because of the
Homegrown well I mean they did the
organic Talent we say Gooding and D
strawberry wasn't organic and David Cole
wasn't organic on that team yes yeah you
there there are pieces there were pieces
pie they pieces right and it's uh you're
right listen now I will say this though
I I don't care I have no issues with
inorganic every everybody's for the
streets I love it but Halo gears and
Forza is going to pull us through yeah
good J I'm sorry what you almost it's
almost weird as an Xbox fan who's been
following Xbox like analytically since
12 for Xbox to be in such a strong
position it's almost like we we've not
we've not really had this experience as
Xbox
enthusiasts you know like there's so
much they can do you know like Rand was
talking about on Xbox 2 will they make
blizzard Survival game Odyssey will they
make that exclusive could that sell Xbox
console and they're talking like what
what kind of what kind of Integrations
will they have with Xbox game pass
ultimate I could do three months free
with Xbox plus ultimate they could do
like Diablo you get the season the
battle pass premium battle pass with the
Xbox G Plus ultimate there is like it's
like we've never had this kind of
scenario where it's like oh Xbox is
actually okay now and Xbox has a future
behind it it was always like for the
last 10 10 years plus it was always like
is Xbox going to die yes preach this is
conversations that serious outlets and
analysts and business business people
had is Xbox on the chopping block and
you'd be forgiven for for for for
agreeing with that because Microsoft
Microsoft is a cloud company first and
foremost and a lot of its external
extraneous business operations like
surface or or um you know Windows phone
for example I'm still traumatized by
Windows
phone and Skype and and all this kind of
stuff all this kind of stuff is
extraneous to what it does with the
cloud so it's like if if if like any one
of these businesses from LinkedIn to
Skype to Windows phone to surface any of
these business any of these businesses
could be shut down and it wouldn't
affect Xbox's bottom line but now
they've got IBK Xbox is going to be
bigger than Windows itself Xbox will be
bigger than Windows Windows has a
monopoly in PC and desktop operating
systems and Xbox is going to be bigger
than Windows for Microsoft and we've
never kind of had that stability xbx
fans and Xbox infus who did that for you
it's exciting man it's exciting bro I'm
excited excited King name give some
excitement he wants to know he wants to
know who did that at who did that for
you it was Phil Phil Dominus Maximus
really SP sir first of his name it was
Phil and that and that's that's really
the the the test to Phil is that he was
able to sell Xbox Satia Adella and sa
SAA is a cloud guy he's a business to
business guy he's not a consumer guy so
Phil had to say to Satia this is why
we're in gaming and this is the
opportunity in gaming and this is what
we can do if we take gaming seriously
yes and Phil has delivered that it was
the challenge was not PlayStation the
challenge was not Nintendo the challenge
was convincing Microsoft itself y gaming
was an investable opportunity and Phil
achieved that and no one can take that
away from Phil one can take that away
from Phil that is Phil's Legacy imagine
buying all those Studios and then going
back to to satio and be like yeah I want
to buy Bethesda how oh oh okay all right
we we'll do that then going back like a
year and a half two liters yeah I want
to buy ABK what but well how much could
would they be yeah they're they're
willing to sell how much 668 billion
doll okay that's cool this this is the
thing this proves saan Nadella and the
the executive leadership team is fully
behind Xbox and fully behind gaming and
they fully believe in what gaming will
represent in the next 10 years next 20
years and what it will mean to to cloud
and the the growth of cloud cuz all this
comes back to Cloud at the end of the
day and I'm not talking about cloud
gaming or streaming games I'm talking
about like server
infrastructure about I'm talking about
infrastructure I'm talking about
business business solutions I'm talking
about uh like artificial intelligence
developing games and stuff like that so
what you're saying is that them other
game companies weren't
competition there were the game
companies don't man oh they they they
yeah they didn't see them as comptition
now the Xbox has got ABK they
just n the rest doesn't matter it's like
this was I was I've been saying for
years that the the the competition for
Microsoft was Apple Google Google 10cent
it wasn't the rest of them it wasn't the
rest of them it was Apple Google and
10cent it was about it was about
competing with other tech companies
about what the next the next couple of
decades would look like for gaming
because the console industry has been
the same 300 million yeah same 300
million customers since forever for
whatever reason the the console the
console install base has been 300
million and it won't grow for whatever
reason I don't know why that is you said
they not
enough it's not enough for capitalism
baby it's not enough for capitalism I
love you jez I love the fact that jez is
on spitting them facts did y'all hear
that Sony and Nintendo wasn't
competition it was googleing other guys
like the paperwork said before remember
that ah this is a wonderful day you are
messy you're messy let's get on to Mario
pleas King King King King King can you
put can you put your Starfield hat on
again please oh man while King does that
I was just going to say jez yes I do
agree with you and I just wanted to say
the point that you that really resonated
that I always try to tell people where
they get upset with people being excited
that love the platform is we remember
the days when we were not sure that they
were not even committed to gaming so to
see this stability to see what's going
on is refreshing Harry Mar man Harry me
tell them about that name right people
don't know people didn't know if XBox
was even going to be serious about
gaming the Xbox One error exposed a lot
of things and that's why people are
excited about what's going on and future
looks bright they just got to execute
and manage your Studios you have to do
that you have to do that so that's what
I got what hello everybody in TV Land
he's back
JZ oh my Lord I can't with that hello J
for he's looking down at the screen just
it looks like a chicken head
does K oh you good over there JZ did you
get you get your request I got I got I
got something in my email inbox right
now and I can't tell you about it
exclusive exclusive going down there
stuff going down tomorrow oh it's going
down tomorrow exclusive let's talk about
it J you you heard first I said this was
going to be a horrible month for you
guys I told so jez so jez is said thing
going down tomorrow is it this this this
this exclusive news what what I didn't
say
anything all right all right we going to
Let It Rock we go get pause some more
liquor man you look like you need some
more trying to write an email right
now write your email write your email we
gonna get back we going to take a
station break write your email email and
we going to get back to you then make
sure you get more of that
Icelandic we going to get into that yeah
we going we going let let's just get a
shot oh it's so happening for
Tom I hate about Jason's
space I might I might have S sent me a
mask we we'll wear mask for the
Halloween uh I next let's just get his
email out we got exclusive news that
we're going to break next topic and then
we going to get him some more liquor and
then um what we're going to do is solve
can we is it a lot of super chats of
this I drank I drank half of this I
drank half of this and now I've drank
half of this yeah but let's do some
shots let's do some shots and then let's
just keep this going let's just keep
have have you not noticed I've been I've
been drinking this straight from the
ball you out of control I love it make
sure get the email get the email out and
then we going to break all the uh the
the rumors that you got going on for for
next we need to hurry up this o' okay
okay okay we go s get some ja we got uh
let me see John Wolf $2 Super Chat
bangers and mass sounds like a great
Saturday night
[Laughter]
yes sound like the bugs and Spiderman oh
man0 de taco5 Super Chat uh Cog put the
Nintendo topics last so he could rush
through them because everyone's tired I
see through your con I'm trying to help
jez we doing shots it's a fun day like
let let it let it develop we'll get to
Nintendo don't worry about then we have
Mr two append $5 Super Chat iMagic King
running with those rare p on mobile
money think Viva Pinata and Etc yes yes
yes yep no doubt no doubt then we have
dova tararan $5 Super Chat most
inaccurate part of Spider-Man 2 is not
once does miles drive a Honda Civic with
the boxing gloves in the rearview mirror
while playing Bad
Bunny that's very stereotypical
hilarious
continue There we have Cory Tidwell $2
Super Chat Cog has a pet salamander he
keeps it meaty wow
y'all really want that beefy Emoji today
get the beefy shirts they up there they
up there down the teeth Rak soore do
that I love beef so much man medum rare
steak let's go we got we got beef for
you we got beef for you continue and
then we have clutch B $2 Super Chat how
about those map boundaries and
Spider-Man I've encountered I've enced I
hav can't can't fly past that huh $10
taku $5 Super Chat all we need is a game
where master can smash Doom guy or banjo
can smash crash they should name the
game smash the Bros
wow we are not naming the game smash the
Bros can't name the game smash the Bros
hey hey
hey back you s i I hope you realize what
you wrote yeah he didn't realize he we
are not doing smash the
Bro not happening then we have THX 1138
$2 Super Chat Phil Spencer Microsoft
gaming CEO uh two CEO in Microsoft I
think he want what do you want to say
take two CEO Microsoft yeah could be
that's it we're C up all right final
topic and so we keep adding all right so
jez you know again we got we got more
looking for you anything you want to
break right now you we want to make sure
that you got your email out so breaking
news tomorrow can we at least talk about
what PL is is it for the Xbox platform
can we least I'm not saying the damn
think all trying to get me to violate
ndas okay I'm just saying you're a big
you you can survive you Sur I'm joking
I'm joking I'm joking this this yeah
keep an eye out keep an eye keep an eye
out keep an eye out okay tomorrow
tomorrow going Dam okay going hit you
right in the head head window y'all
heard it y'all Windows Central be on a
lookout something juicy about to happen
we going to see anyway DLC the
Starfield we going see King put the hat
back on I'm so happy right
now this this podcast is awesome because
a I got cats from addict and I got a hat
from King this is great and you got Coco
Chanel Johnson today
too so look final topic cuz adote before
he pass out um and King all right so we
got um Nintendo uh Super Mario Wonder
Impressions and then I want to combine
it sof because I know you're probably
you're the only one that played I mean
you and adct only two that played and
King played I think so King played okay
cool and I just also wanted to jump in
as far as Doug Bowser's comments and I I
I want to ask jez some questions there
about what he said in reference to
Microsoft but talk about Super Mario
Wonder was out in these streets
mushrooms all that let's go yeah Super
Mario Wonder came out the same day
Spider-Man 2 they said we're not
moving we're not budging we held the
line
um that was hilarious he almost made me
spit out he's stupid and yeah I mean it
is delightful from what I have played
which is not much um I have to say the
most striking thing about it is the art
style the art style I feel is really it
really when you go back to the old games
right you talk Super Mario 2 AKA doy DOI
Panic Super Mario Brothers 3 Super Mario
Brothers World Yoshi's Island those are
special games in terms of their art
design everything about them is special
but the art design is really special not
since then have I looked at a 2d Mario
game and felt that way where I'm like
wow this is a beautiful game because it
really is evoking those old school games
and taking it to the next level it isn't
you know what also reminded me of the
the first cover for Nintendo Power the
Mario that's in made in clay that very
first cover it reminded me of that so um
see because a lot of people the super
the new Super Mario Brothers games are
pretty good I enjoy them but at the end
of the day what they did is they took 3D
Mario oh
co somebody happy
whoa so what they did with those three
with those 3D Mario games they took that
they took that um they took the Mario
from those games and implanted them into
2D and it didn't really it didn't sit
well with a lot of people they a lot of
people did not like that art style
specifically in the 2D plane uh some
people felt it was limiting in terms of
animations and it was it felt like the
2D the 2D of the games was gone that is
all out the window they went back to the
drawing board in terms of that art style
that is so be it's so beautiful and
almost painly evocative of those old
games um gameplay-wise in terms of what
I've seen so far um The W seeds are are
special the wonders after we've talked
about you know mamoto and his pension
for you know drug use and not his P for
druggies
Mario up impli up implied druggies SP
Mario right and and I think uh you know
the whole thing about the wond seeds and
the mushrooms and stuff like that the
wond seed takes it kind of overtly there
where it's like you get this wond seed
and some wild things are gonna happen
man Wonder seed wow and when you in
order to come out of that seed oh using
the word come after W seed moov it
on in order to leave the wond seed State
you have to consume yet another wond
seed oh man when will it end now I will
say this uh the platforming what I've
seen so far is is what you expect from
Mario it is the best 2D platforming
you're going to find and I know you know
the there Sonic is out there running
around the
streets no Sonic Superstars sucks man
I'm sorry shout out to jez I Love You
jez TI Mario I've got it I've been
playing it it's just not good it's just
not good Mario is special this Mario is
really special I think this is what
happens when internally you think
Nintendo is they are this old
chat got to chill talking about they
spreading the Wonder seeds yo y'all got
to relax chat I see what y'all doing
with the Wonder SE y got to stop you
could be you guys you could be an
elephant in the new Mario game exactly
atically makes it game of the game of
the year materal when you look at when
you look at the the new sort of
Transformations and there's from what
I've seen so far it's like nothing kind
of overstays is welcome and when you go
from stage to Stage there always
something new to sort of Be Wild by um
yeah they they they've kind of knocked
it out of the park with this I and I
really do think in Nintendo when we talk
about Nintendo we talk about them being
like old man Nintendo right the the
messed up online and stuff like that but
I think
internally they've let the young boy the
young guys come in and sort of take the
Reigns on these games yes they have
because I if you if you have the Old
Guard straight up making this game
without any input from the new guard I
think you have kind of the same old
stuff yeah this game don't be made these
ideas feel so fresh but they do feel
like they're in form exactly like these
ideas feel so fresh but it does feel
like they have a guiding hand like okay
cool I like this let's make sure it's as
tight gameplay-wise and everything that
we that's expected from Nintendo and
they're kind of letting the the young
people take over these franchises and
we're starting to see which is why I
feel like Nintendo no matter how many
times they go to the same well they
still come up with something that people
are excited to play because it's never
quite the same thing you know story-wise
it's it's the same thing like you know
this isn't you aren't saving Peach here
but it is Bowser it is all the same
stuff winning narratives but momentto
moment gamepl and the sort of the
excitement of seeing what they do and
what they come up with from stage to
Stage is is so prominent in this game
and I it's it's a banger they they did
it they they went back to 2D Mario and
they and they made a banger so I'm very
happy so far no doubt um anyone adct did
you play did you get get your your
Wonder on yeah I definitely had me some
Wonder seeds
oh yeah it's it's it's an interesting
game you know I've always naturally went
towards um you know Platformers
especially like really fast-paced
Platformers yeah uh you know this game
is definitely uh very like iny face like
go move on like I like how you go from
like rank two difficulty stages and then
just the next one's are rank five or
four and it's just it's interesting I
really enjoyed it I enjoyed the you know
the the different types of gameplay I I
like I I played it with four people oh
okay and it was it was it was a
nightmare like oh wow like it it that's
because you know I feel like one of the
people that played wasn't like really up
to date with like platform and stuff
like that so we were always fighting on
where we should be you know what I'm
saying uh I you can play up to four
players but I recommend playing this
like either single player or two people
like anything more than that because
it's hard to keep up with four people on
the screen at the same
time and you can't go any further and if
someone drags too far o of the rest the
other ones can die yeah interesting all
right they must be nice to have friends
yeah they turn to little ghosts they
turn little ghosts and they fly around
you have to pop them out of is Mario
wonder the Dark Souls of Mario games
where you have shadows like so people
die right and it's a very weird thing
apparently people like people kind of
playing on the same server they they can
put up little go posts where oh I got to
this point or whatever and they can like
if you need help in a certain spot and
someone's put up one of those like
shadows in that area then you can ask
them to come in to your game and help it
it's it's kind of weird um but it is it
does has like it has a little bit of a
Dark Souls thing and and also what I
heard is that when it comes to when you
can actually play this is what I'm
confused about and see if tell me if you
if you understand this so there's only
true multiplayer locally yes I don't
know right because Donal Donald Tako was
like no that's not the case oh because I
didn't see any other way
yeah Don you have to explain you have to
explain yourself is that like a secret
button you have to press down right up
down red life up yeah let us know what's
what's the deal with this online is it
is it in there what what's going on you
got to eat the mushrooms that came with
the
uh and you think you playing with people
too you see gotat mushrooms for real one
thing I don't like is they put Yoshi
like apparently there's four characters
at the end of the character select that
make it really the game on easy mode
Yoshi's one shout out to Yoshi out I
think one one thing that I was a little
disappointed with but it's just the game
is that they didn't go to Super Mario 2
route and give uh all of the characters
sort of distinct characteristics yeah
they kind of all got s to play the same
that I mean that was like a missed
opportunity but either way but I would
have wish they would have done that I
think it would have did something
different to the dynamic of the game did
you play any interest oh yes of course
okay um so can I just can I just
oh Lord what happened how did R get
H I got a DM I got a DM saying here's
the link Cognito and King need you in
and I'm
like I was like all right like I don't
know what's going
on I was getting top your favorite topic
yeah favorite topic oh wait what's the
topic yeah Mario and the one well later
guys I I'll talk to you later no but
stay actually actually now that you're
here we're GNA wait wait did you guys
that actually want me because just says
it was important that I joined he's
definitely trolling you and it's great
you're trolling the hell out of you I
love it I'm just kind of ruining IP no
no stop it you are not ruining I will
you stop he says he says he says Please
join there's an interesting discussion
going on Co Cognito and King really need
you here like okay well coito and King
need me here guess drug Jaz is lit I'm
I'm I'm getting ready to go to bed um
but but um I played Mario Wonder uh it
was my son and I we did uh local Co-op
you know couch Co-op the game looks
phenomenal and like Sovereign was saying
I thought to me the animation looks
incredible like it felt new it felt old
it felt the same but new and I was just
like I was looking at the background I
was looking at the foreground I was
looking at the animation of the
characters when I picked Mario in the
beginning of course I picked Mario when
he did like you know this little
animation with his face I've never seen
him do that animation with his face I
was like oh that's cool so it's little
things that I'm finding out with the
world but what I love is voice yes you
walk past certain plants they talk hey
man what's going on just end I was like
what um and when you get a mushroom the
world gets
busy world gets busy boy they taking
this psychedelic thing to the next level
so that's how I know it's young dudes
that's working on this game the bosses
are pretty interesting too yes like when
Bowser did what he did and and I was
just like oh this is trippy trippy they
leaning heavily into the trippy right so
when when you did the elephant in the
roomy it's it's it's like it's it's
crazy when they did the elephant thing
because I was like oh and he gets water
he can um like blow his little trunk and
do stuff my son was loving it I feel
sorry for
Sonic I feel sorry for Sonic dude dude
dude dude which which Mario game let you
turn into a dinosaur man that was uhy
that was Odyssey yeah and you didn't
turn into a dinosaur you you put your
hat on it and you controlled it why
Sonic like you turn into a dinosaur man
that was that was when you was doing
possession that's that's when you you
you was about you know possession I
played Sonic I played Sonic I see what
you're doing but this not going to
happen it's not going to happen right
now I'm trying to get out of
here yeah yeah that's nice trying to
trash
Sonic it sucks all right Superstar sucks
all right so back to what w I'm
saying every having
a would be a bad investment it would be
a bad investment Square Nick I feel
sorry okay we did that earlier I feel
sorry for uh Sonic because Sonic should
have waited me too right it should have
waited it shouldn't have came out now
you know how confident Mario was yeah he
said this is our
birthday I don't care you coming outside
I don't care if you on a greater
Hardware I don't care if you got Ray
tracon ain't no Ray tracon to be found
over there but you know what else is not
found over there
bugs the game is solid from music to to
the jumping to the co-op to the
animations it just felt real Mar
like it felt I don't know it felt like
old home but new so I'm just like I love
the path that they on and then the
switch news the switch 2 News came out
where what Bowser was saying that the
the games would let me set it up that's
literally was going to set up that's all
I was going to say cuz that what I
wanted to get Rand and JZ on that part
cuz I know they have to Mario Wonder
people I just I'm just I'm so sorry cogn
I I just destroyed your whole podcast
I'm so sorry Jazz drunk jazz is the best
jazz we love you stop it yeah we love
drunk Jazz We Love Drunk Jazz so here's
the thing uh this is why I got both of
you here and I'm very curious of what
you think cuz uh Doug Bowser has some
interesting statements and reference I
believe it was an inside inverse article
let me just pull this up yes so he was
asked after the leaks from the uh FTC
with the Microsoft trial revealed that
Microsoft had discussed discussions
about acquiring Nintendo the the
interviewer says I'm not asking you
about why that would or wouldn't happen
but more broadly what you think about
the growing TR trend of Acquisitions and
its effect on the industry has been and
will continue to go forward so then
Bowser answered we have a great
relationship with Microsoft we consider
them to be partners in many many ways
use many twice which is interesting and
you only have to look at Nintendo switch
to see that partnership obviously mcraft
is on Nintendo switch and we brought
Banjo Kazooie to Super Mario Smash
Brother's ultimate so we look looking to
we're looking forward to that
partnership continuing then there was a
second statement that he made after
again shout out to haard who put this
tweet up I saw this article he said as
far as consolidation in the industry
goes I've been a part of this industry
for 16 plus years now one thing that's
been constant is the acquisition of
Studios but the other constant is the
fact that new studios are popping up
every single year incredibly creative
studios are making content from Indie
size to AAA size games so as
consolidation happens on an equal basis
we're seeing these new Studios which
really just speaks to the dynamic nature
of the industry overall in the end that
bolds well for the player so let me
start with you K I need to step in right
now let's go all right J you want it go
go for it what you got the whole the
whole industry consolidation narrative
is P
CAP it's cery bro I've invented be
careful they get mad get mad when I say
that they get mad too I I don't care bro
I don't care there is no such thing as
industry
consolidation because all the all the
people like Pete Hines and all the
executive the executive layer of ABK and
the executive layer of zenak they take
the money that they they make from the
investment of their their shares
maturing in zenx and their shares
maturing in ABK they take that money and
they create new Studios like the star
the Starfield um not Starfield Starcraft
team from blizzard doesn't exist anymore
there is no team at blizzard making
Starcraft anymore very very small team
maintaining the Starcraft 2 but a lot of
those developers they took the money
from the game they took venture capital
or something or or some of the
developers who had money from blizzard
sell because blizzard has sold itself
multiple times over the years they took
some of that money and they've made a
new studio that's making uh it's making
the Starcraft allegory there's so much
money in um indie games and and there's
so much accessibility it's not like
Hollywood where like like an indie an
indie movie can't really make it right
in Hollywood in the same way an indie
game can make it in gaming because steam
windows and other platforms are open and
you never know what game's going to go
viral and there's so many examples of
this Minecraft Among Us uh you know and
other games that have sort of like been
developed by small teams sometimes in
indviduals and they've absolutely blown
up look at Flappy Bird Man Flappy Bird
back in the day why do Microsoft acquire
Flappy Bird there could be a Flappy Bird
Cinematic Universe at this point
bro but my my point my point is
ultimately that the indivi the video
game industry is very Dynamic and it's
not it's not when people ascribe
consolidation to video games they're
doing it from a position of they're
imagining this sort of rigid
infrastructure and they're not familiar
with the industry at Large video games
is not as rigid as other Industries and
anyone I could start if I was like smart
if I was intelligent which I am not
which is why I'm a blogger I can make a
video game tomorrow and I could slap
that [__] on Steam I could slap it on
Xbox I could slap it on mobile and if it
was really good it could blow up you
know and um that's how I feel about that
kind of stuff I feel
differently a lot it's bad faith a lot
of the the traction about disingenuous
cuz I I I I ran I mean r jez I said this
on certain forums that I said there are
some people that I do feel have legit
concern for the industry but I said
there's others that they are
disingenuous and have selective outrage
when it comes to companies acquiring
companies I've heard all type of excuses
and I said I don't see the same I was
attacked I I was told that I am wrong
for that so I I'm with you I I totally
that's why these comments resonate with
me from a veteran in the industry listen
I was even told when Phil Spencer made
the comments that Nintendo would be a
career move how dare he and Cog you
should be appall that he said that and
then we hear these comments from
Nintendo but I'm going to let JZ finish
and I want to get ran on this and then
we got to get about it no dude that's
that's that's me man I just don't I
don't believe this consolidation
narrative if it was like if micos if
Windows was a closed platform and if
Microsoft was making games exclusive to
Windows store and all that kind of stuff
then maybe there there'd be an argument
to be made there but the fact of the
matter is Windows is an open platform
and it's it's other companies that are
gatekeeping you know and and apple
designates um the European Union
designates Apple and Google as sort of
these gatekeeper companies which do
restrict Innovation and do restrict
investment and and do control what
Publishers win and lose but the win the
fact of the matter is Windows is an open
platform and you know and anyone can
make a game in unity like Unity is a
free a free platform that sort of like
you know and and John you know without
getting into into into In Too Deep with
all the drama that's happened of unity
over the summer but historically
speaking the last couple of years anyone
can make a game in unity anyone can
publish that unity game to XBox and and
Android and Windows and that game can go
viral that game can blow up yeah you
know it's not like Hollywood where you
have to go through producers and you
have to like you know meet har Harvey
Weinstein in the hotel room to get you
all right J D we put you on T we GNA put
you on Tab out we will save you from
yourself and we GNA move on so that was
funny as hell but we got to move on Rand
out thor9 I have to I have to ask your
question wrap it up yeah yeah cuz he was
he was getting in the casting couch
we're not doing that here in the realm
but um but I was going to say red what
do you think about Doug Bowser's
comments in reference to um Microsoft
partnership with them them them being
told about Phil's comments and and and
how they wanted to acquire Nintendo and
Doug B's reactions and then obviously
consolidation on the industry as a your
thoughts on Doug Bow's comment I really
you really is this what you really need
me here for talk about Nintendo we it's
your favorite subject my Lord uh so
you're mean to tell me that they asked
him this and he didn't say it was
embarrassing that's what you
know because you know I heard it was
embarrassing heard uh I mean look
Nintendo's a company and Nintendo
doesn't acquire much but they do acquire
I think they've acquired a couple C
companies recently so I mean they're not
going to really come out and say oh man
Acquisitions are horrible we do it the
organic way like it should be done and
stuff right so they're not going to
really say anything about that and they
do have a fantastic relationship with
Microsoft you know Minecraft is one of
the biggest games on that platform yeah
so they're not going to really badmouth
Microsoft in any way shape or form
because they are pretty close so he sort
of just kind of avoided that question
about hey what what do you think about
Phil saying they would love to get
Nintendo and he he kind of just he did
he didn't really answer the question but
the the thing you take away is like hey
I've been in the industry for a long
time you know this is normal right
people get their uh checks for for
through these Acquisitions and then they
go create new Studios I mean you look at
like um maybe maybe s knows this but the
studio that um the name of the studio
eludes me right now but the team making
the
finals um that was an offshoot of the
people who worked at EA and Battlefield
right they went and they they you know
uh they went and they built a new studio
and they have a new scheme this happens
all the time in yeah respawn ENT Embark
Studios it's oh okay it's Embark I mean
even recently if I remember because this
was kind of used as a oh this is bad uh
I think it was like one of the leaders
of Forza Horizon 5 yes Matt Brown M and
he left and he went and he formed a new
studio with a bunch of people it's
constantly happening all the time like
money comes in and that money gets
redistributed and new Studios form in in
the wake of you know Acquisitions and
that's why the video game industry is as
dynamic as it is is there aren't really
a lot of Gatekeepers like they like
there are in a lot of under other
Industries um I mean I don't think any
of us think Microsoft is going to buy
Nintendo in any point in time uh that
ship is probably sailed Phil said it was
a career move though it would have been
a career move because when you look at
Phil as king would say Phil Dominus
Maximus aurelus Spencer first of his
name right first of his name uh Phil
because I people bring up this whole
like oh it should you mean his career
moves not making great games Phil
doesn't make the games ph's whole job as
Microsoft CEO of gaming is literally the
business how healthy is the business
what does the future projections look
like right it's not like oh the game's
90 plus meta that's Matt Booty's job
that's whoever's in charge of Bethesda
that's who's ever in charge of ABK
Phil's job is basically are we
profitable how's Game Pass doing are we
making money on that how does m SAA feel
about Xbox in general so yes getting
Nintendo and including that into Xbox
would be a goddamn career move for him
yeah because you're talking about one of
the probably like the one of the most
beloved entities in video game history
joining Xbox and talking about the
market leader well you you yeah I mean
you could make that you can make that
argument for sure that would be a career
move because that's about the business
that's about the bottom line that's
about the revenue that's about acquiring
new users so like I I sort of feel like
a lot of this discussion is rooted in
fear yes a lot of it is rooted in um you
know people people worrying uh about
their platform potentially not being on
top anymore because away you know as as
I think Tom wasn't Tom Warren said of
here but maybe said a different podcast
where he's like we ain't got the
resources for that big man you know like
some companies just don't have the
resources to do those sort of things and
Microsoft does you said
finances yeah the finances their pockets
looking kind of funny they it is looking
funny so there's a lot of
misinformation I I watched this podcast
yesterday I won't name who they are but
they're very big podcast within the
industry MH and they were talking about
the ABK stuff and the Acquisitions and
they were surprised that Phil's first VI
was the king really they like oh wow
they were like and this is a very very
big podcast very you know like people
have been in the industry for a while
very popular they're like wait it kind
of gives off the impression that this
was about King when we know it was about
Call of Duty I'm like oh you're out of
touch you completely out of touch and
that's what I think a lot of people in
the industry are is like they don't want
to cover Xbox they won't they don't want
to have to devote the resources to have
somebody understand the brand and all
the moves that they make and they view
Xbox through the lens of PlayStation
right so when you get these moves and
Phil goes on record for two years being
like Oh no we bought ABK for King and
then you get these industry podcasts
that are like mobile what mobile yeah
it's like but I thought it was about Cod
no it was about Cod because Sony said it
was about about Cod which convinced The
Regulators that maybe it was about Cod
but in reality it was about mobile the
entire time there's a lot of there's a
lot of
just people who you know Proclaim to be
smart and know everything and they
really don't I mean I I guess maybe I'm
one of them I don't know everything and
I won't say I will but there's
definitely a point here when talking
about Acquisitions where there is a
sense of fear yes there's a actually do
know everything no I don't so Rand
Randy's out here like yeah I don't know
everything I actually
do
continue so no I mean yeah y you good
I'm sorry please that's that's that's
all I got to say no I appreciate you
brother thank you for for joining I did
want your thoughts on that I I'll just
so I I just invited Randon because I
really wanted to hear about the books
he's reading
you let's
go we definitely want hear that and I
would just say thank you R for saying
that because we I really appreciate that
because what especially the Doug Bowser
comment about the cycle of Life what I
call a circle of life right
consolidation I've been in this thing
for 16 years new Studios pop up all the
time this is the circle this is what
happens right some people die every Dayo
bro you stole my notes I was about to
say that I was like yo consolidation
happened every day B stop stop worried
about like how dare you be upset about
this this is what goes on for years and
that's what I've been trying to tell
people and I get attacked for saying
that I'm like people act like I'm
supposed to be appalled that Microsoft
was trying to they had that as an
aspirational goal pre but there's the
preab now obviously we know how it
played out we know how it changed and
this that it is but look I know guys got
to go we got to um finish up we didn't
do yes we did do business um what I was
going to say what are you talking about
finish young yeah we defin is
Young for another three hours
bro how you doing out of control you out
contr want payday Nintendo you want
payday
ridiculous anything else from the
Nintendo uh soft addict King anything
else from the Nintendo the duck Bowser
comments regarding Microsoft I'll say
I'll go I'll go yes um Phil want you and
he G to have you like you can run but
you can't hide and he said is a career
move you are the pivot you are the one
he wants
he covered you so you know Doug knows he
in pocket I told you before Reggie
wasn't in pocket with none of Reggie was
like oh get the hell out of here
embarrassing you even asking me these
questions Doug was like you know we got
a good
relationship you know cuz Doug know you
know hey man never know sometimes the
lights don't come on you know Philly be
like hey man I heard you had a little
issue that's my guy he does stuff just
like that what happened to ABK oh they
had a little issue what happened pick
him up zamax what happened they had a
little issue pick them up H Square they
having issues pick them up Ubisoft you
having a little bit of issues we still
in the market of buying yo cash is King
bro cash is Cash is King and they went
over there not real money yes yes this
this is the money they gonna buy
Nintendo with that is not real money
it's not real
money and and I can't wait till it
happen cuz what it happens like like
show you some brid it's about fair right
I told you there's no PlayStation 6 I
told you and I'mma stand on that I ahead
I respect you standing on it though no
problem let's have fun with this because
I told y all what was gonna happen with
Starfield
ha keep watching the videotape it's
gonna happen so fast and so hard pause
it's it's crazy but Microsoft is still
in the acquisition position pH they're
still purchasing they're going to square
this away Square it
away that was that was good those are
bars those are bars and then they then
they're going to spin the block on your
favorite studio right they're going to
spin the block on your favorite studio
and when they do it you gonna be like
how they picked them up and nobody
stopping
them Yo when y'all brought fire Sprite
or whatever the hell your purchase and
your Winer brought Bungie but Bungie
said she for the streets and y'all got
problems with Bungie right now cuz she
about to
leave this the paperwork came out I'm
and y'all brought them with credit cards
you didn't even buy cash y'all went out
there y'all brought them on credit and
y'all owe some bills
bro the financials came out on you you
still got down payments on
bu you still got down payments on Buie
and you ain't finished paying you got to
find how you all go finance a studio yo
you ridiculous how your money a right
you got to find filling them went over
there with the bricks it was like yo
where ABK at put the bricks over there
all right we got them we ready to go
let's go paid in full cash on hand they
C that was a cash deal Millions y' dudes
did a finance Y and Y leas
them y dudes winning leas bung oh my God
y'all don't see it game's coming out
buggy game's coming out messed up and
stuff is
happening they gone bro and Phil is
still purchasing hey
Nintendo so on that note it's been a
great
show God bless U we do got to pay the
bills I do want to do just starting man
no we are not just starting it's like
the 6 hour we got to close up but I got
to do some out for yeah for the Xbox 2 I
mean love you guys one of my favorite
podcast good friends um the Legends jez
Cordon window Central where can the find
people find you what else you have going
on besides breaking that amazing story
that you could have broke right now but
we're going to let you save it for
tomorrow what else is going on for
you uh I don't know man I'm just just
drinking and eating Subway lying in bed
crying screaming into the into my pillow
oh my
God I'm on Twitter atj jzc and I'm on
YouTube too J.C I'm I'm strongly
considering getting more into YouTube
stuff because like I said this writing
stuff's just not doing it for me man
like the fact that Xbox 2 is making me
more money than my writing job is kind
of indicative of the way media is going
I kind of feel so um um so yeah I've got
that over there like everyone in chat
has been so kind and I'm sorry I've been
so chaotic I I'm I'm scared Cognito
you're going to be like oh
good you're definitely on your messy
meter was high but um no we love you
brother and thank you for for Mak I know
having fun man I'm just having fun I
love I love doing this show like you
guys are so fun and so awesome and thank
you you've got like thank you br you're
on this sort of you're on this sort of
traj trajectory you know Iron Lords is
is thank you brother so cool and it
reminds me of you know Xbox mad when I
was you know making Xbox mad back in the
day but I I I bailed man I was like man
this is too hard for me I'm out I'm
going to accept a job another Outlet you
guys like keep on this path and you will
build something that will like you know
you'll be proud of in the in the decades
to come I I didn't have the strength man
I didn't have the Constitution I was
just like screw this I'm out you know
running a website and running running my
own stuff is too hard I'll just accept a
job in the industry and I regret it I
regret the only reason why is because
we're family yeah we're and at the end
of the day ja it's still I still love
what you guys are doing with Xbox 2
obviously you guys had John linman on
you had Maddie on you know you guys are
still building too so don't
don't that's what I mean like don't
count out that second career oh yeah
well what we're building with Xbox mad
is kind of like the I mean Xbox 2 is is
like what we bu you had to drink oh he's
been drinking Dr a lot he drink straight
too yeah no Chas whole I'm Dr this half
of this you were drunk you were drunk
like all of yesterday we got to check
his liver you were drunk all of
yesterday my li is do my li is doing
some heavy lifting this weekend are you
sure I am 1 hour late an hour late I'm
so sorry go I'll wrap it up I'll wrap it
up wrap it up
me I don't drink I don't drink that
often but when I do drink I go hard
you're already an hour late what's two
bro respect J I haven't I haven't drunk
for like see y
later appreciate you thanks so much for
having me and yeah love everybody always
love and Rand the homie my men's one of
my favorites of the game good friend
where can find people find what you got
going you don't got to give me an outro
I was barely here things got to go yes
but we got to get you an outro it's only
right tradition what's going on we can
the five nothing I thought you needed me
today that's what just said we did we
did if you didn't show up I wouldn't
have remember that they brought him on a
credit
card for showing
up Xbox 2 we love you we got to pay some
bills so we got to got to let you go we
we do love you and uh again thank y'all
so much always for the support and I
want to tell you both because both of
you here you guys have always when IOP
was in the fledgling stages you guys
have always showed support and believed
in us and we thank you for that it meant
a lot cuz we have so much respect for
you too the legendary Xbox 2 J Gordon R
outoor enjoy your Sunday for jazz Monday
and get some water Jaz later gentlemen
peace peace get some water no doubt so
we got to pay
zills yeah so uh what are we doing we
just G to do let's do the super chats
first and get yes yes yes uh we got a
lord Metroid with the $2 Super Chat use
the drill cap on Peach she loves it
pause boy boy that was
messy there we have the $10 deal taku $5
Super Chat Mario wonder it feels good to
be on top Spider-Man 2 you know we
getting by
son Sonic Superstars hey we also came
out please don't forget about
us see Game
Pass then we got Lord Metroid again $2 J
pick the seeds up just don't swallow
them oh man oh man we got L Paris in the
chat he said oh my God yall still going
Paris I wanted to be out of here an hour
ago bro then we have theu $5 Super Chat
you know you know your wonderf flower
ain't good if you picking out them W
seeds don't bring that Reggie F around
here
wow that's different different that's
different different then we have NC
ghost of low road $5 Super Chat Mario is
a banger does Mario save the princess
with these W seeds while eating
mushrooms still riding on a dinosaur
could be could be it's a
possibility then we have gamer by choice
$5 Super Chat Nintendo was around during
cartridges games had to be right at
launch most of these companies now are
are used to releases uh with patches
great show thank you appreciate no doubt
then we have DJ Berto dos $2 Super Chat
Sony is defaulting on Bungie on the
Bungie loan that will be crazy Bessie
there we have THX 1138 $2 Super Chat
Sony buys Bungie on layway
plans said I'm going to get him out next
Tuesday here $10 today for hamburger
next
Tu you out of pocket then we have
nintend T2 Super Chat PlayStation bought
Bungie on affirm affirm the
yo yo that's disrespectful that's wild
disrespectful that's it we're caught up
all right cool um there is a little
business we got to do right
what's these cool little chairs K you
want Set It Off what's that what that
little chair you got going over there
want to see the back of that you want to
see the back of
it is that the whole worth budes what's
going on I'mma tell you right now there
nothing like this chair there's nothing
like this chair this chair feels so good
pause it's is a really good chair um I
was doing my research on uh the chairs
they're like top in the industry
and I I I really didn't know how
comfortable a chair could be until it
came when it's shipped the box is big
enough to to fit a whole person in yes
because that box that whole oh that
whole earth wo that firm Xbox
firm beautiful what chair is it the the
the hallworth firm um the the the thing
is it comes already assembled you just
have to put this the the the headrest
part in that's it that's the only thing
that comes separate it's not this it's
not
Ikea okay you don't have to build a beer
to to to to rock in this chair um it has
so many levels so many different
positions for your hands for your back
for your lumbar support we have the one
with the lumbar support um how many
different heights the chair slides up
forward if you need an extra room for
your back I'm a big guy all right um
adct and I are big men and these chairs
fit us comfortably I've been sitting in
this chair it feels like six hours and
you know your back ain't hurt you know
that ch's official yeah yo my butt don't
hurt my back don't hurt and I'm I'm feel
really good but I I leave it to the rest
of the guys but um uh I really
appreciate the fact that I'm able to do
a podcast in this chair if I was doing
this into my other chair I would have
had to get up y saw i' be like cutting
the camera off sometimes and getting up
and shaking my legs and stuff like that
and and walk into the bathroom back and
forth I haven't did that at all only
time I turned off the cam camera is when
I was putting on uh my mask no that's a
good point I had the same thing with
with normally the other chairs at some
point the pain kicks in something hurts
and you got to you know get up and move
around but adct you you've been rocking
for a while you're a person that doesn't
like to game necessarily on your PC or
where you kind of do a lot of your
podcast and your work what's your give
us some your your your op opinion of the
uh whole worth now that you got at the
Xbox
I could not have beat Spider-Man without
this chair man like because normally how
I I have on my processes I play like
three or four hours of a game record all
that game play and then I'll move my
Xbox into like my room or something and
you know finish the finish it there I
didn't have to do that this time you
know uh for the most part I played all
of Spider-Man two and keep in mind like
driving like seven eight hour sittings I
haven't done that in a while and this
chair like I didn't feel like the
fatigued on it like right now I got like
a headache that's why I keep turning my
camera off because the lights is just
getting to my eyes more and more lately
you got to wear some shades yeah we got
um so you know it used to be my back
would cave before my eyes were but now
my eyes are cing before my back is
that's crazy just s here I'm sitting
here like like like right now my eyes
just are stinging and I just like I
could have done it like ever since I got
this chair I've been able to actually
get more work done because like I'm not
uncomfort it's not like I had a secret
Labs chair that what that was a big
chair and it held my weight how how how
you know the the size of of my uh my
body but it didn't it wasn't the com the
most comfortable thing but I dealt with
because I'm like yo I've been through
chairs and then like they'll start to
wear out like this one and it would be
really fast just subtle stuff that you
have to be in these chairs enough to
actually notice and this chair man I
I've probably sat in this chair
for good amount I I I don't feel any
fatigue from it like I don't get up in
my like a a sharp pain goes for my whole
backbone
anymore you know sometimes I'd have to
like use my hands to get up from the
other chair yeah yeah like you push up
like that you don't I have to do like do
this and you it and obviously you want
to go to the price it's not a cheap
chair not cheap chair not cheap yeah
it's not you can use that IOP affiliate
link that we put
inside the know we put in the chat right
now so you go check that out to you you
know how much does the affiliate link
give you um that's a good
question the RO will have to tell us
when they click the link
but you know one thing I will say is you
know your health is important man yeah
you know and there is a lot of chairs
that do one or the other I will say
there's a lot of shares that's either
comfortable but the quality is bad or
the quality is really good but it's not
comfortable right and and let me tell
you I've been in them
mall and it's just this is the first sh
I could truly say that you know even
though I I look at that price I'm like
I'm like
okay after sitting in up for S time like
I can understand yeah why this chair
costs the way it
does price the price is warrant how much
is it go check go check that out when
you get a chance you need to go check
that out check out our affiliate link so
you go check that out when you get a
chance check the affiliate link first
yeah make sure you hit that then you go
look at it I I would talk to like more
of like my content creator uh audience
that that watches this like
you know I don't know if like a casual
person like this is a good comfortable
chair it just depends on how long you're
realistically in a chair yeah and I
would say the longer you're in a chair
the more money you're gonna have to put
into that chair to make sure it it's
around in six months and you know you
can ask sols well we we bought we bought
a chair it was like $5 $600 and I even
joke I'm like what s like eight months
that thing was dumb it was D and the
secret The Secret Lives chair I was in
it for about a year and it's still good
but you know this chair I can actually
sit here and confidently
say when I beat Spider-Man it was the
first time I'm like like damn my back
isn't a mess like good point you don't
even think about it that's what I knew I
was like y I'm thinking about remember I
I had a car accident so I got uh two two
her8 discs in my lower back and two on
my neck
and when I just lay back and I'm sitting
here I don't have the my I don't get the
tingle into my legs I used to suffer
with sciatica yeah I don't get that
anymore with this chair and there's no
cap I'm not I'm not Capp I don't know
what they did with this chair um but I'm
telling you it's super comfortable I'm
still here only reason why I gotta go CU
I gotta go but but I'm telling you this
chair is definitely worth every penny
that they ask for and you guys know you
know we we're honest with the the stuff
that we support you know it's like I
said you know if if you got it and you
and you V and you're sitting that's
that's the key point if you're sitting
in a chair for longer than five to eight
hours facts I would recommend going
north on the price that you would
normally spend on a chair especially
streamers yeah like you you you might
need custom chairs for streamers facts
cuz I'm other chairs be looking fly but
your back be hurting you know what I'm
saying it's a fact would to get solved
in right quick you we have the fern yeah
we have the Xbox Fern with lumbar
support so when you go to the when you
click on link go to the um gaming
section and then go to the Xbox
collection and in there you'll see ours
in there it'll say x it'll say the um
the Xbox Fern FN with lumbar support
that's the one we're using those the one
we cosign officially but s you've had
some time with the what is good friends
at Hall and real quick I don't know if
if you guys said like like you're seat
you can adjust your seat up and down you
I mean this this chair literally the
only reason it can fit big people like
me and King is because you can literally
adjust everything on the chair
everything yeah that's a fact so solve
your uh thoughts on this yeah I mean you
get what you pay
for that's and it you know you may look
at the price of this chair and say
hey if you're doing this we've been
sitting here sometimes a lot of us get
up during the podcast I yeah you
knowable and my I didn't get up once
during this podcast and to King's Point
like I I will get the tingling in in the
feet and the toes after a while um I I
will just have to readjust because my
back starts to ache a little bit um I'm
fortunate that I didn't have to do
anything to the CH I didn't have to lift
it or whatever once I took it out of the
box I I set up the Lum I set up the uh
the headrest and it was perfect in terms
of height I sat down I'm like wow and I
think what helps a lot is the fact that
when you're sitting upright and you know
if you if you start feeling a little
fatigued like you're holding yourself up
a little bit more you just lean back in
the chair and the chair supports you
completely and by doing that it's like
you're constantly getting this sort of
respit from having to sit super stiff up
in the chair and good word resp it
resp I didn't know J was still there I
love it I love it I'm stting for the
whole damn show man you know what is
that I stopped looking at our regular
chest so I'm like oh just
left yeah so I I'm going to be honest
with you man I I love this thing and I
was like when I first got it I'm like
damn that's a I looked at my chair the
one that I had I'm like it's a nice
office chair
whatever nah man you it really does
elevate uh the experience a whole lot
because again I haven't gotten up once
during the show and my you know my my
foot isn't asleep uh my back isn't
killing me I feel great I feel great and
you know for those long gaming sessions
and I know like you know when adct was
ordering his other other chairs and
whatnot we went through a whole process
of like yo I can't this doesn't work
this doesn't work I need something
better and we spent we spent a decent
amount of money on that chair oh yeah
and it did not last him even a year so
yeah the these chairs are are very
special no I'm with you and again I one
of two things I want to say add on
everything said big boy approved if
you're a big boy this is a big boy this
is definitely a beefy situation if you
are a big boy it can support you with no
problems and again the setup it comes
box is huge when it comes I will say
that but it's already preet up out the
box L all you got to do is really just
do the the headrest part right here just
snap that bad boy on everything's fully
adjustable from your armrest to the seat
to the way you hike the Leaning the lean
back it's super comfortable and the
thing go Ahad not many chairs could do
this man look how far I go back yeah
it's it's super lit super comfortable
and again the key is for again if you
streamer someone is sitting for hours
gaming for hours and you sit all day
highly recommend I've been to two or
three chairs already and I do not have
that that that problem and I ain't going
front to join The Stylist you see with
King SP the block and the back if again
you want your Xbox uh branding and lo
and and the thing I like about last
thing I said it's more of the
traditional office chair style with
proper posture that's the key my back is
not doing any arching is not doing any
crazy when I get up I'm still feeling
refreshed I'm feeling okay and y'all
know me I usually do about four or five
getups during the show you know what I'm
saying I probably only got to got once
that's cuz you know I'm old I got a
bladder but at the end of the day shout
out to hardw work shout out to the chair
shout out to them supporting the podcast
again if you want to get get a hardw get
the Xbox firm we got the link in the
description in the chat I'll put it in
there again and again salute to hardw
for the partnership uh we definitely a
fan cuz one thing about LP we like to
try these products we ain't cosigning
nothing unless it go through us official
if we not using it and we don't like it
you're not getting the coside so that's
just how it is but salute to this is an
excellent excellent chair that's all I
got anything else off super chats got
superat we got to couple we got to go
cuz it's like six seven hours and we
ain't trying to be here with we're not
trying to be here with J for 10
hours how many hours too long
continue you muted so so didn't hear
anything Dam you laughing my my fa I'm
laughing Dr Strange Love five Super Chat
I had to mute again because I'm there's
something going on on the street I don't
know what's going on um5 Super Chat Cog
is so beefy he'd give the Symbiote
heartburn if it tried bonding to him
yo there we have Lord
Metro call
[Laughter]
Insomniac they will they will they get
that right they get my yo my wife was
appalled yesterday she was like and then
we I I mentioned it to her and then I
showed it to her and she was like okay
she left it alone and then like 10
minutes later she's like I'm really
bothered by this like what the hell she
was yeah she she was not not happy well
Puerto Rico came out I I feel a lot of
he Porto Rock how you feel about that no
he tweeted no no he TW he tweeted he was
he was one the one that I got the
information from oh did you take your
game
back called him out on it now shut he
called him out but he's still playing of
course you're ridiculous what are you
supp to boycott just you got to call him
out you're ridiculous anyway I'm messing
with him hey you like it you like it
continue messy King I think we're good
we all right look that is it Lord addict
where can I find people find you what
you got going on
sir you can find me on YouTube at uh
gaming addicts going to release some uh
nice little uh you know some some nice
take videos this week sure I have a new
thing cuz I'm starting like a new chall
a new stream every Saturday and I've
already had my community bully me to
take my shirt off on stream yes we saw
you your only fans saw that I see you
was going back to back with with your
nipples
out what oh you ain't see the all let
let's let's go let's go wrap it up wrap
it up it was they wanted to see all of
addict wrap it up my man has lost his
mind so Len I I I do I'm doing thing on
those Saturday live streams I I'm
reading the comments on the the you
better stop following
Alex you been smacking thighs and leing
out nipples how about how about his
viewers need to leave me alone hey man
Super Chat got paid bills I I went and
looked at the uh ft so so what I'm doing
is I'm I'm reading comments on videos
that uh people didn't like my take on so
we went we went over uh my my my hot
take on the The Spider-Man
and Xbox needs its own Super so yeah
definitely go out there you appreciate
we had up to like it was like 12 1300
people wow you know we're close to 700
likes let's get that we'll see you next
week man we'll see you next week you got
SPAC man king let's go come on stop
playing I'm I'mma see where we can uh
send you guys so no doubt L sa way past
the curfew but we I yeah yeah for sure I
know you're in trouble I gotta go get my
pops a haircut that's what I'm going to
do um yeah you'll find me hopefully
playing some more Mario wonder and uh
Spider-Man next weekend cuz that's how
it works for me so that's what I'll be
doing Spaceman and Spiderman king where
can they find you guess who's inside
Starfield oh man yo you can find me on
Twitter blowing stuff up and acting
crazy Advance the line it's not over it
has just
begun and um hey check the balance on
your credit cards I think you bounce
something ridiculous peace no doubt and
of course the legendary judge go thank
you for rocking would I really
appreciate you brother and yes thanks
for having man I'm sorry if being
chaotic we love you we love drunk Jazz
we just wanted more leaks and we want to
get you more to get an hour and a half
later I got I got to be careful man like
I got to be careful like I get myself
into trouble but there is so much good
stuff coming for Xbox so much good stuff
I'm really excited I told you guys be
careful I can't wait to you yes again
again again everybody thank you for the
support thanks for everybody that came
through thank to our our wonderful
sponsors manscaped and and hallworth and
all that good stuff and again you guys
support and we it helps promote the show
and do good things and we got more
things cooking for you guys enjoy your
Sunday that's all I got so we go super
chats anybody last minute let me see
anybody last minute sending you guys to
fend oh go to the yeah game talk live no
doubt all right everybody enjoy your
Sunday we out peace
[Music]
pre
w